Unreal Engine is a 3D computer Graphics
game engine that has been used to create
many popular games in this full course
for beginners tsurav will teach you how
to use Unreal Engine 5. surov has seven
years of game development experience and
has developed multiple games hi there
game devs welcome to my beginner to
Advanced game development course on
Unreal Engine 5. in this course we'll be
taking a deep dive into the engine and
hopefully by the end of this course you
would be able to create a game
completely by yourself
foreign
start developing a game in Unreal Engine
some of you guys may have a question on
what sort of a system to get for Unreal
Engine now the docs is a bit outdated on
this page however uh this page whatever
is there is uh insufficient in my
opinion I have been working on Unreal
Engine for almost 7 years now and I feel
this system isn't going to be handling
anything
so
8 gigs of RAM isn't enough and for the
video card I would recommend at least
going for something like a 1650 or an
RTX 3050 if you were to ask me I have
worked in unreal for about four to five
years with a 1050 TI that totally works
however your experience isn't going to
be that great and you will have to turn
down all the settings as well
and for the CPU a ryzen 5 or an Intel i7
would do six cores or higher uh
preferably eight or even 12 cores would
be better but make sure if you do get
more number of cores you scale up the
other components as well there are a
couple of things for example in Visual
Studio
uh when you compile a program
you will actually need more RAM as
you scale up the number of cores on your
CPU so that's one thing to note
and if you scroll it down you would see
this list over here although the system
is highly Overkill and the GPU is
outdated of course one noteworthy thing
is a solid state drive which I highly
recommend
do not use a hard drive for your active
projects the experience isn't going to
be that great so with that all being
said let's actually start by talking
about the installation process
[Music]
now there are two ways in which you can
get hands on Unreal Engine one is
through the epic games launcher so just
search epic games launcher download the
launcher and once you actually log in
and do the regular sign up stuff you can
go ahead and click on Unreal Engine
and head into library and you should be
able to add an engine version now as of
this date the the latest table build is
5.0.3 however 5.1 is in preview and we
we shall hopefully upgrade to that it
has quite a few exciting features which
I would love to show
and the other way is to download the
source code now you could use git or
something and copy the link and clone it
like that or you could just download the
zip file from here and then there are a
bunch of steps to actually install it uh
we'll be going through this later in the
course and also for more advanced users
those of you who will be working with
dedicated servers might need the source
build as well now if you guys don't have
access to this repository you just have
to request the permission this is a
private repository by default and it's
pretty easy to get it
and once you do get access to it you
will be able to view this page there are
quite a few tutorials on YouTube on how
to do that so you guys could check any
one of those out
once you install the unreal editor
through the epic games launcher uh
you'll also need a code editor in order
to work with the c plus files so
generally you use visual studio for it
now the documentation goes pretty well
on what components you need and stuff
and if you do need any additional
components the installer is going to
prompt you and it's pretty
straightforward to be honest
now you don't require vs 2019 you could
use 2022 there is absolutely no issues
uh I'll be showing you guys how to set
the default code Editor to be vs2022 as
well a bit later
so that's about it for the code editor I
guess now we can go ahead and create a
project and let's create a game
so I'm in the epic games launcher right
now and before we actually launch the
engine I just wanted to talk about the
installation options
try your best even though it looks large
to have debugging symbols those are
going to help us out later
[Music]
now you can go ahead and click launch
once the loading is done you should be
inside the unreal project browser where
you can create your projects now yours
might look a bit different I haven't
selected templates so I don't see first
person third person and all that however
Our intention here is to learn so we
aren't really going to use those
templates we might look into them a bit
later on but for now we'll be starting
with a blank project and a couple of
noteworthy things
two things actually the first thing is
the project location I always suggest
having an unreal projects folder in your
solid state drive and maybe move them to
a secondary drive if you're not working
on them
now for the project defaults everything
is fine except blueprint and C plus plus
basically every C plus plus project will
have blueprint and everything else that
you will need to work with the editor
however when you select a blueprint
project there is one additional step if
you want to start working with C plus
plus as well please note that blueprint
and C plus plus work complementary with
each other and every project in my
opinion should use a combination of the
two and shouldn't be purely C plus plus
nor should be purely blueprint so let's
create a c plus project and let's leave
it at desktop maximum and we didn't
download the starter content so we don't
have it but that's totally fine we can
add it later on now
for the project name we can go ahead and
name it let's call it beginner to
Advanced course
or I'll just call it beginner course
so let's create that
once you open your project a visual
studio window like this with your
project solution open should be open by
default if not head into the editor go
to tools and click on open Visual Studio
2022 and here's where I'll just show you
guys how to change the default code
editor let's say you have a slower
computer head into editor preferences
and over here type in code editor
and you should be able to change it to
visual studio code or whatever let's say
you do change it to vs code
over here under Tools again you should
be able to find refresh Visual Studio
code project
once you do that you should be good to
go
one thing that you will immediately
notice is my editor layout does not look
exactly like yours the reason is I have
set mine to the Unreal Engine 4 layout
so the way you do that is by heading
into Windows load layout and this is the
one you will probably have
and you can hit
control space in order to get your
content drawer but I feel like it just
adds an additional step in viewing your
content and
I honestly prefer the Unreal Engine 4
layout but it's completely up to you
everything else should be in the same
place so I'm going to be using the ue4
layout you can choose to use the default
one if you wish
and in case you want to go full screen
here in the ue4 layout just get your
viewport into Focus just in case you're
wondering the middle large portion of
the screen is called the viewport once
you get it into Focus hit f11 on your
keyboard to go full screen
[Music]
let's start talking about the actual GUI
of the unreal editor so the first thing
is your menu bar which contains file
edit window tools build select and so on
these are just the normal options that
you would see on in any other computer
software so let's say you wanted to save
everything you would go go ahead and
click save all however there's a key
over here as well on the content browser
which you will be using more often in
this editor and under edit you also have
a couple of important things
obviously for undo redo and
functionality like that you'd prefer the
shortcut keys so for example let's say I
add in a light over here
and I go to edit you could undo that but
I just prefer using Ctrl Z and Ctrl y
and editor preferences project settings
and plugins are a couple of options
which you will use quite a bit we will
be getting into all of those in detail
later on
now window as the name suggests has to
do with uh your actual GUI so here for
example if I wanted to know what game
mode I have and again we will be getting
into all of that so I can just go to
world settings which contains the game
mode info so it says game mode override
none we can set that to be game mode for
example and stuff like that
it all depends on what you exactly need
you could grab in a second viewport as
well in case you needed it
stuff like that and under Tools the only
thing which we'll probably use here is
going to be creating a new C plus plus
class and occasionally we might need to
refresh our project file
and nothing else actually find in
blueprints is something handy so in case
you have written some blueprint code and
you want to find it
like in your entire project then it's a
useful thing
and build is for building your lighting
and stuff basically uh baking your
lighting
select not really sure who would use
that because most of the operations are
there can be done by shortcut keys
so that's your menu bar
and under this there's another panel
over here
where you have another save button
and under this select mode option
over here you have quite a few options
landscape is something which you will
use when you're working with you know
larger Maps so you can go ahead and
create landscapes
so what I'll do is I'll create a brand
new level to Showcase those things and
over here in blueprints this is where
you'd access your level blueprint and I
will get to what is that a bit later
this option right here is mostly for
cinematics so let's say I'm making a
trailer for your game or something these
are the things which you would use
and this is just to play your game so if
I hit play I can see what the game looks
like while you're playing it
one more thing let's say you wanted to
look at how your game looked while
you're playing without actually playing
it you can press G on your keyboard and
it it's going to go into game mode which
will show you exactly how your game will
look when it is being played
and next up you have this button right
here where it allows you to launch the
game and stuff will be going into this a
bit in detail later on
now for those of you guys who have
slower computers you can head into
settings over here engine scalability
settings and you can set Yours to low
now how do you check your frame rate you
may ask because that's a major concern I
feel like you do require about 50 to 60
FPS in order to have a smooth editor
experience so the way you check that is
by hitting your tailed key under your
Escape key that is if you guys aren't
familiar
once you do that your focus should be in
this enter console command window at the
bottom of your screen type in stat FPS
and you might see that it's locked at
120 if you have a fast computer so what
I'll do is I'll type in t dot Max FPS
and you can just type in a crazy value
like 999. so this is my actual uncapped
frame rate
now this introduces us to another window
this is known as the console now the
console is really useful
basically almost every setting you see
over here and quite a few other settings
which we will talk about later can be
set using the console
it's quite handy let's say you're
debugging your game and you don't have
an actual button to change your graphic
settings you could use the console and
change it as well there are many other
uses for it for example in multiplayer
you can simulate lag and stuff like that
in order to represent an actual
multiplayer game
so that's the console and your output
log is your output log so let's say I've
printed something
it's going to stay on your screen for
about two seconds or how much ever you
set the duration
but the output log is always going to
have
the print so for example
now we haven't gone into blueprints but
I'll just print something and show you
guys
if I just type in print string hello
you see you get hello over here but it's
gone after two seconds
however in the output log you should be
able to still see Hello it should be all
the way down
as you see
you get hello
now don't worry about all these errors
it's really nothing to worry about
so that's about it and on the left hand
side you have the place actors panel
where you know you have various options
you'll really not be using this you will
generally just drag those from the
content browser
it just contains the same old things and
the recent step may be helpful if you're
placing the same object over and over
again
one thing that you might use this for is
for a player start player start is
basically where your player is going to
spawn
just press G on your keyboard if it ever
disappears you're probably in game mode
if you don't see it
and if you want to get close to it like
how I did
uh make sure that is selected and press
F on your keyboard
F stands for focus and it's going to go
near it the camera is going to go near
that
now once that's done let's talk about
this massive chunk of the screen
this is known as the viewport this is
where you will actually arrange your
level and do stuff
so for example if you want to place
something you drag that in the viewport
and that's going to be added into your
level
now in order to navigate your viewport
there are quite a few methods which you
can use one is known as the Maya style
navigation where you use alt and your
mouse buttons and there are many other
styles which I won't get into it's kind
of pointless but there is one style
which I personally prefer and I feel
almost everyone is going to prefer that
that is by using your right Mouse button
and your wasd this is similar to how you
move in video games except you're
holding the right Mouse button here so
hold down your right Mouse button and
you can use your w a s and D keys and
move your mouse so this gives you all
degrees of freedom so you can rotate you
can pan around you can do everything
so this is my favorite way of navigating
just try it a couple of times it's just
a matter of getting the feel of it and
if I want to speed up the camera which I
will get into later you can use your
scroll wheel along with this and your
camera speed is going to change
there are a couple of options again here
now here uh instead of the console
command you could use this as well to
show your FPS
and there are quite a few other options
which you would generally not use screen
percentage is basically a resolution
scale you could set that all the way up
there
I'd leave mine at 100.
and this is to change between
perspective and orthographic views let's
say you're aligning something from the
top you would go to your top
orthographic View
now you might see everything is
wireframe so you can change that here as
well go to lit let's say there are
shadows interrupting your work you could
head into unlit there are many other
view modes which you generally use for
optimization and things like that
but generally you'd stay in lit unlit or
wireframe itself
maybe a couple of times you might use
one of these uh other settings but I've
never found myself needing those
so that's there
and scalability is basically the same
thing which we saw over here
I can set that to cinematic for example
in my case it shouldn't really matter
that's about it and in these options on
the right hand side
this one basically allows you to select
objects so let's say I click on this I
select this now let me get closer a bit
set into perspective
so if I click on this I can select it
now when I click on something now I'll
create another Point light when I click
on something and I have it selected
if I want to move it I can press W on
the keyboard
or if I want to rotate it I can press e
on the keyboard
and if I want to scale it for a light
it's kind of useless but it is going to
scale the radius I believe
so for that I can hit r on my keyboard
in order to scale things or you could
use these buttons over here
so this is for move
this is for rotate
and this is for scale
all right so once that said
this button right here changes between
uh local and World space
now over here if I just drag in a cube
for example under shapes you should find
Cube
and if I change this
to local space
now when I rotate this Cube you see the
Gizmo rotates along with it and now I
can move it along its rotation
but let's say I wanted to rotate it
along with the world's XYZ the way I do
that is by heading into World space
so now you see it's aligned to the
world's XYZ that is your actual
coordinate axis
but this cube is rotated as you can see
so if I want to move it along that
rotation I can head into local space
again if you are familiar with 3D
modeling software these will sound
pretty familiar to you
the next thing is grid snapping
now if I were to come close enough you
would see that it's moving in increments
it's not moving smoothly that's because
grid snapping is enabled and snapping
distance is set to 10. so I can just
click on this button and disable grid
snapping and now you see the object
moves smoothly same goes with rotation
if I disable that I can smoothly rotate
the object
if I enable that it's going to rotate in
increments of 10
same with the scale as well
now this map is pretty huge and it's
taking quite a while for me to actually
go this far
so the way I can actually
move faster is by using this camera
speed button so if I head into 8
as you see we are moving very fast one
more thing
is if you scroll while using your right
click and wasd basically I'm using that
to move
if you use right click and wasd and you
scroll at the same time you can actually
adjust your camera speed so I have my
right Mouse button held I have wasd to
move and if I scroll forward I'm going
to move real fast
now let's say scroll backwards I'm going
to go slower
so you can adjust your camera speed with
your scroll wheel as well and of course
you can adjust it over here and if you
want the camera to be even faster you
can go ahead and set this multiplier
thing
and that's about it
[Music]
now let's actually start creating
something so the way you would actually
go about doing stuff is creating
something under your content folder now
you might have some things over here if
you have enabled starter content and
stuff but in our case we don't have
anything
so one thing is whenever you create new
levels it's always advisable to have a
Maps folder in your content folder where
you actually put all your Maps
so head into this folder and in order to
actually create a blank level where you
can start making your own right click
click on create basic asset level or you
can head into file new level anyway is
okay
and we can call this one
beginner course level you could call it
anything you want
double click on it to open it up
and I've already saved it
uh it's asking us to save this map
actually so actually don't save this
now head into your project settings
and this is where we start talking about
some of the things which you might need
the first thing is maps and modes
so in order to decide which level is
going to open when you start the editor
this is where you actually set it so
anything associated with your project
will be over here so for example your
input bindings is something which you'll
use a lot so all of those are there in
the project settings so we can change
the editor startup map to be beginner
course level
and we can set this to be beginner
course level as well
close that
and if you were to notice there is
actually a small note here
it says
these settings are saved in default
engine dot ini which is currently
writable what do I mean by that is if I
head into my project directory
and if I head into config there are
actually many config files so for
example if I open up default engine.ini
it says editor startup map equals and it
has the relative path of the map
and you have a bunch of other settings
as you can see these are useful we will
actually talk about console config files
in detail later on
there are other config files as well
most of which you won't use you would
mostly just use default engine.ini
now heading back to our level you see
everything is completely empty
now one of the first things that you
will need is a sky actually so if you
just search in sky
you're going to find a skylight Sky
atmosphere we are just going to be using
a skylight for now
and if you just type in atmosphere you'd
you get the same Sky atmosphere here
so you can go ahead and drag that as
well
and if you type in fog you'll be able to
get exponential height fog
now you will see the effects of it if
you Tinker around with this yourself
basically all of these things just do
what they say so exponential height fog
is going to add fog and if you want to
change the properties of this always
head into your details panel and this is
where you will adjust all the properties
now for something like fog the location
and stuff doesn't matter
so anything you place the location of it
is going to be stored here location
rotation and scale just know that
location rotation and scale combined in
Unreal Engine is known as a transform
we'll be using that a lot
now let's say you had a light which was
fixed and you want the Shadows to just
be baked in and you have nothing to
calculate dynamically you could set your
light to be static or it it goes the
same with any other object if you're not
going to be moving it it's going to be
static
stationary is almost like static but
there are a couple of things which
dynamically changes
it's generally used for your directional
lights which acts as your sun basically
so we can drag that as well so if I type
in directional light
you see we get everything else that we
need
if I remove the fog you'd see that the
fog went
now for example here I have lost my
directional light and
or any other component so in order to
navigate to that you can use this
outliner window which will have a list
of all the objects that are in your
scene you can do quite a few things
actually if you want you could select
these and you could actually put those
in one folder so I can go ahead and
right click create a folder and I can
just drag those inside this folder you
could do that as well in the outliner so
now let's say you lose your directional
light you can head over here and let's
just call this one
sky for example
let's just call it Sky actors I'll tell
you guys why we call them actors a bit
later on so you can drag in a sky
atmosphere Skylight and stuff like that
so these are the basic components of
your Sky now if I go ahead and zoom into
my directional light
press e on my keyboard and rotate it you
see the sun moves along with it
so let's say we wanted an evening Sky we
would use something like this
and if you would notice the mobilities
that set to stationary
you could set it to movable then
everything will be calculated
dynamically and you won't have to build
the lighting
you could set it to stationary as well
you could set it to static if you don't
have any moving objects in your level
now let's go ahead and just save
everything
now let's start actually creating
something in our level
[Music]
so first of all remember I told you
about the landscape tab this is what you
would use if you have a larger world but
for our purposes I'll just show you guys
how to work with Landscapes even though
we aren't really looking for a large
world
so here you can select your landscape
material but you can change it anytime
anyways and let's say you wanted a water
body or something or let's say you
wanted to have multiple multiple layers
you know in your landscape you can click
on enable edit layers
uh and these things are basically a
transform and stuff like that and these
things are just these options number of
components and the overall resolution
adjust the size of your landscape so you
can play around with that
to see uh what the Precision or rather I
should say the detail level of the
landscape and the size should be
depending on that you can increase that
or you can go ahead and use a height map
I actually have a chart on my channel on
how to use height Maps properly in
Unreal Engine
but for our purposes we'll just create
our own
so let's just create everything with the
default options
and let's hit on create
so it is going to take a while
and once we are done with that we have a
landscape
now if I go ahead and press play as you
can see I can navigate around this
landscape just like you can navigate in
any other level
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to edit the landscape now these are the
tools that we'll be using to edit our
landscape
so you have to be under landscape mode
and under this section over here you
would find sculpt
you can increase the tool strength you
can get the brush type over here as well
uh one thing that you will use is
probably the alpha brush basically you
can have your own mask and stuff but for
our purposes we are going to be using
the regular old Circle brush so I'll
just increase the size now this need not
be the limit actually I can set this to
10 000 as well
so if I go ahead and do that Let's see
we have kind of a mountain here
now what if I wanted to randomize the
bumpiness in the map I could use noise
so you see it's going to be like this
but this is overkill so I can go ahead
and change the tool strength to
something like 0.05
and as you see this is a lot more
reasonable
so this is what noise does flatten as
the name suggests is going to flatten
your landscape at that level so let's
say select this level everything else is
going to go to that level if I use
flatten now obviously I can increase
your tool strength if you wish
completely up to you and there are many
other things such as the brush fall off
so basically if you want a softer brush
so you could use the brush fall off and
increase that if you want a completely
hard brush you could go ahead and use
this but as you can see it produces
harsh effects so we aren't going to be
using that
again completely up to you
and erosion is basically if you wanted
to create natural looking slopes and
stuff so for example
so I'll just reset some of these
settings here
so something like this you could
experiment and find out what what each
one does
but generally you would stick to sculpt
smooth flatten Ram
and maybe sometimes you would use
erosion and you would use noise
and let me show what ramp does real
quick
so if I select ramp
and if I go ahead
and click somewhere and click in another
place and click on ADD ramp
you see it Bridges those two locations
with a straight line and this is going
to be a ramp
you could add a ram
anywhere like this so I can go ahead and
do this
and I can click enter or I can press add
ramp on the menu over there and it's
going to add a ramp now if you had a
character or something you can walk over
it
now again we can use the smooth tool in
order to smoothen this out
so now these two in this intersection
looks seamless
so these are basically a landscape
editing tools there is not much depth to
it and not sure what it is does actually
so I've never used eres to be honest you
just undo changes if you really had to
and one more thing if you wanted to do
the inverse of an operation so let's say
I am sculpting a landscape so let's say
I wanted something like this so I'll
increase the tool strength
so make that let's say 0.14
now this is one way but what if you
wanted a pit instead of a hill the way
you do that is by holding shift it's
going to reverse the operation and it is
going to make a pit
same goes for the other tools as well
shift is going to be the inverse of the
operation
so that's about what you'll use in the
unreal editor most of the time so now we
can start creating our own assets make
sure you first of all go into select
mode again don't forget that and now we
can go ahead and start talking about
blueprints
[Music]
foreign
so let's start talking about blueprint
blueprint basically is the visual
scripting language which is used to
write game logic in Unreal Engine
so blueprint code can be written in many
types of assets if you right click go to
blueprint class you can write blueprint
code in most of these assets
and we will get to some of the important
ones a bit later for example act upon
character player controller game mode
there are few others such as the game
State player State and so on we'll be
getting into all that now the most basic
type of blueprint is going to be a level
blueprint so if you head into this menu
over here click on open level blueprint
you would say you'd get a blueprint
associated with your level
now begin play is as the name suggests
something which is called as soon as the
game begins or in this case as soon as
you open the level
please do not interpret begin play as
when you click on the play button
this is only called once you load into
the level so let's say you load it into
another level the begin play for that
level will be called as well in order to
actually start writing code you would
use some built-in functions or you could
write your own so the way you do it is
if you right click for example and if
you just type in I don't know let's say
set location
now let's say you wanted to set the
location of something in your level
let's actually do that
uh since this is object oriented you
will need context for everything so you
need to know for Which object you're
actually moving so for example let's say
we have a point light here now one handy
thing which I forgot to mention before
let's say it's up over here and you want
to snap it to the ground you can hit end
on your keyboard and it's going to go to
the ground level
now we have this
have that selected and head back into
your level blueprint if you right click
you get an option create a reference to
point light now
internally this is a pointer to this
object or rather I should say to this
actor anything that can be placed in a
level is called an actor just remember
that
now if I drag off of this now I want to
get its location let's say for example
now the search bar is really useful for
that you don't really need to know the
function names especially in blueprints
so just type in get location and you see
get actor location
now I can go ahead and print it for
example so if I right click and type in
print you see print string now this is
called a function
even this will be called a function so
let's say I drag off of this and I type
in set actor location
again every getter will usually have its
own Setter if it can be set
so what we are saying what we are
implying by this
is
set the location of this point light to
be zero
which is what you've defined over here
now let's say we just wanted to move it
up a bit so we can do plus
and on the Z we can do 200 because Z is
the up Axis in Unreal Engine
and we can set that to be the new
location
so if I go ahead and press play
don't see much uh see mobility of the
light is set to stationary so we have to
make it movable of course uh remember
what I was telling you guys earlier with
static and stationary you would assume
it to be in the same place but with
movable it's fully Dynamic so now if I
press play you see it became dimmer in
case you guys wanted to see the change
if you just press D on your keyboard and
left click you get a delay node or you
could right click and search for delay
but I prefer using D if you press D and
left click you get a delay node let's
just keep a delay of two seconds and
then let's move it up
so if I press play
as you see it got dimmer because it went
up
now this blueprint function has a couple
of pins on the left so these are called
pins the stuff from which you can drag
off of
now the Triangular one or the pentagonal
one I don't know what shape this is the
one which drags off the white wires
these ones are called execution pins so
this function will be executed only when
this pin goes from left to right so only
when you connect something to it from
the left and when this is executed this
is going to be called and once this is
done this is going to be executed now
this one is a function as well get actor
location is a function too however it
does not have an execution pin you might
notice the reason is this is a pure
function you can define a pure function
whenever you need a function to return
immediate values
so what I mean by that so for example if
I have this hit result and let's say I
print this out
so I can't print out a hit result I
figured so let's just take location now
this is just a sweep hit result so let's
say we move it somewhere and it collides
with something in between it's going to
return a hit result if you have sweep
enabled
uh now if I print this out this value
right here is actually cached so let's
say I copy a print string and let's say
I print this out again
set actor location is not going to be
called once again
this value what you had is going to be
cached in your memory however over here
if I just drag off of get actor location
and let's drag off of this once again so
let me drag this over here this value is
not cached what I mean is get actor
location is executed each time I'm
calling this print string wherever I am
referring to this value the entire
function is going to be called once
again and in this case it makes sense
because whenever we execute get actor
location we want at the live location of
of the actor not the location which it
was in previously if we go by that logic
we would get the location before it was
set so we will get the live data using a
pure function
and the target Works in a similar way we
are getting the point lights location so
the target is point light
now one more thing you might notice is
event tick tick is basically a function
which is called on every frame so if I
just hit print and if I just print out
tick for example
you'd see it prints it a bunch of times
basically every time a new frame is
drawn uh the tick function is called
[Music]
now whatever I told you guys is just a
vague overview of how blueprint works so
I just talked about execution pins and
that it's object oriented and types are
color coded but now let's actually start
talking about them one by one so the
first thing you would want to do in any
sort of a programming language or if
you're writing any code is first of all
be able to store data and that's done
through variables now the way you create
a new variable in Blueprint is by
clicking on this little plus icon on the
left hand side
this menu is available in almost every
blueprint so click on the plus icon and
you can create a variable
now let's just call it my variable for
example
now over here since blueprint is based
on C plus plus obviously you you have to
define a type for it so by default it's
set to Boolean but you can select any
one of the other types I'll go over some
of the important ones if you are
familiar with C plus plus these things
will seem pretty simple to you guys so
Boolean is basically a true or false
value so for example
if I drag my variable and let's say you
want to get the value of a variable you
can drag it and hit get so this is going
to be the value so off of this pin let's
say I I type in if
we'll get to branching and stuff a bit
later but I can do stuff like this since
this is a true or false value if this
variable is true this execution pin is
going to come out if the value is false
this execution pin is going to come out
so that's basically how it works same
way with all the other types so I can
click on this variable and change the
type to integer
which is basically a non-fractional
number N64 is basically 64 but integer
so let's say you have larger numbers so
you would use integer 64. however I
don't really find many use cases for it
float is a decimal number and then you
have name String and text all of which
are string types most of the times you
would be using string
however in some cases you would use name
as well for example in tags which we
will talk about later and text is mostly
used for UI and stuff like that so if
whatever you see in menus and things
like that uh the text the strings over
there are stored as text so that's the
data type you'll use now a vector is a
struct with three floats in it x y and z
now obviously if you don't know what a
struct is we will again talk about that
no issues Rotator is a similar thing
except uh there is a limitation on what
values you can have you can only have a
value of 0 up until 360. beyond that the
Rotator is going to be invalid
and transform is basically a struct
again which contains a vector
a rotator and a vector so location
rotation and scale so this is
transformed these are the fundamental
types which you use most of the time
however if you go undestruct you would
see there are a lot more you will not
use most of these uh some of the common
ones that you will use are things such
as hit result so hit result is a common
one that you'll use now if I compile
this and if I go ahead and drag this out
and if I go ahead and break and one more
thing if you want to get this variable
there's a shortcut if you hold Ctrl and
drag it you will get the value and if
you want to set this variable you can
all drag it so that's just a small tip I
can give you guys
so now bracket result is going to show
us all the different
variables inside this now similarly you
can do that with any other struct if you
just drag off of this and try type in
break you can do that or with some
structs you can you can even do split
struct pin
or actually with all structs
so that's basically another way to see
what members are there in the struct so
for example uh similar to this this was
the same struct over here so you see
initial overlap so this is going to be
their blocking hit location and things
like that so that's basically your
struct that's how it works in Blueprint
and one
different type is going to be our object
type variable so for example if I select
an actor and this was an object type as
well if I drag off of this the variable
which is color coded in your sky blue or
your light blue color so these are
basically object references
internally when you write these in C
plus plus so let's say you create an
object reference for blueprint in C plus
you can expose C plus plus variables to
blueprint by the way they are stored as
pointers so basically it's the memory
address to that object now if some of
these things sound confusing to you just
stick along and watch the course till
the end and if you guys still have any
confusions make sure you guys do check
out a video on pointers and I will go
over actors and stuff like that
basically uh this variable is going to
refer to an actor and since this is a
pointer and the default value is none so
if I go ahead and click on this you see
it says None so what this means is this
is not a valid pointer and if we
actually had some logic in C plus plus
it would throw an exception so that's
basically how object types work and you
all also have enumerations which are are
in in some disguise just your byte which
is an unsigned 8-bit integer so
basically uh for example if I just grab
a random enum over here I can do a
switch which we'll talk about
so basically depending on the value of
this variable you can perform your logic
so a common thing that you would use it
for is let's say you have a weapon in a
game and depending on the type so let's
say a weapon is fully automatic you
would have an enumeration so one of
these enumerators is going to be full
auto the other one is going to be
semi-auto the other one is going to be
bolt action and depending on that you
would execute the appropriate logic so
that's one way of using enums there are
many applications of course we will get
to most of them later
[Music]
now that's about how you basically
create variables so now let's actually
talk about a few special types of
variables namely structs and enums now I
did show you what's a struct and Anum
but I'm pretty sure it went all over
your head if you're a beginner so let's
just delete that and click on this
variable and hit delete to delete that
as well compile and save that
now go ahead and right click create a
new folder and call it structs and I'm
doing this in my content folder uh you
could do it in the same place if you
want to follow along
right click go ahead into Blueprints and
create a structure
and for now let's just call it my struct
now
structs by definition in C plus plus is
going to be similar to your classes
so basically you wrap a bunch of data
and methods
into a single unit
however in Blueprint as a structure
purely refers to a collection of
variables you cannot have functions for
structs in Blueprint sadly however you
could just create a library for that so
you have blueprint function libraries
and you could just create functions for
your structs
anyways so the way you work with this is
you can create a bunch of member
variables a very simple example is going
to be a 2d Vector Unreal Engine already
has a 2d Vector type but just for
demonstration purposes let's just create
one so let's just call this X and make
this of type float because it's a
decimal number
add in another variable
make it of type Y and make this of type
float once again so basically my struct
is going to contain these two variables
now if I head back into my level make
sure you save this
and if I go ahead and right click
somewhere and type in Maestra
you see you get an option called Break
make and set members so if I go ahead
and press break you see you get options
X and Y now just like how you create an
integer or any other variable you can
create a struct as well so let's just
call this one I don't know maybe my
variable once again
and it's going to be of type my struct
so my struct is the type so this is our
user defined data type
now I can go ahead and get this I can
right click perform split struct pin
once again
so this is basically how struct so
basically you have one variable which
stores multiple variables within it so
this can be very handy for example in
this hit result you have all these
variables now it did not need not be the
same type the types can be heterogeneous
so I could have an integer over here I
could have a string over here
so let's say I have a student struct I
could store name
his role number and stuff like that so
just a big example over there
so that's basically how structs work in
Blueprint so I'll just delete that we
don't really need it but we'll keep my
strength let's actually have something
more descriptive let's say we have name
and let's say we have points
this makes no sense right now but we can
use this a bit later on
and you could anytime add a new variable
but remember avoid removing variables
from structs sometimes they do cause
some issues with the blueprint so be
careful with that in C plus plus though
it won't be too much of a problem since
you refer to the members by their names
so that's one thing to note
now one more thing if you guys want to
set the members of a struct what you do
is you just type in set members
and you can get the struct name that is
my struct in our case so we can use this
and set the members now over here on the
right hand side under default category
you can get any one of the variables as
pins and you can set the value now
obviously you will need to tell it which
struct so let's say you created a
variable of type my struct
so by struct
you can go ahead and pass that as the
struct reference now this is a reference
because this pin over here is diamond in
shape or rhombus or whatever that is so
that means it's a reference so it is
referring to the actual
variable that you pass in
so it is going to adjust the value of
this variable
[Music]
oh
we will deal with a lot of structs as we
move on however there's one more special
type which I would like to mention and
those are enumeration so I will right
click create a new folder and I'll call
this one enums
open it up and over here I can head into
blueprints again and type in enumeration
so this is basically a list of values
and you could perform your logic
depending on this list so let's just uh
create an enum and let's call this one
my enum again
now over here you can add enumerators
which basically are list items so let's
say add three items so for example let's
take names of fruits so Apple
banana let's say and maybe a mango
now once you do this these are basically
the enumerators which are there and I
will show you guys what it actually
implies
so I'll just go ahead and create a new
variable and I'll call this one I don't
know let's say
fruits choice for example
and it's going to be of type my enum
now internally ultimately an enumeration
is just a number basically it's a number
between 0 and 256 so for example
over here apple is going to be index to
1. Banana is going to be mapped to 2 and
mango is going to be mapped to I mean
one and uh mango is going to be mapped
to 2 so 0 1 2 so that's how it's going
to be internally now obviously you can
give a description as well over here in
Blueprint
uh so if I just drag this in now by
default it is set to Apple you can see
the default value on the right hand side
and we will talk about all these options
a bit later on in the variable section
so just to be brief uh if you are like
creating new objects in your scene uh
you would need some of these and for
multiplayer and stuff you would need
replication and we will talk about them
in depth so nothing to worry about now
you can cast it to a string so unreal
has it built in to give this out as a
string
so if you see you should get apple
printed
oops I have something on tick so let's
just delete that
so nothing's printing
uh okay we have a delay of two seconds
let's just delete the set actor location
stuff
and just print this in
and we could actually change this as
well
you can copy this and paste it by
hitting Ctrl D so if you click on this
and hit Ctrl D you can duplicate it and
if you drag off of this
you'll see you can perform a switch
so basically if the value of fruits
choice is Apple
it's going to perform this logic so
let's just say
held it for example
and for
banana let's just give something else
so it honestly doesn't matter
copy that over
and let's say we give tasty for mango
so if I go ahead and press play you
should see it says apple and healthy
now
if I set this value so if I alt drag it
and I set this to banana
now you should be able to see that it
prints the second string
so this is basically how enums work and
this was actually a bit of a lengthy way
I did it there's actually another
shortcut you can use in Blueprint in C
plus plus though this is the only way
you would just type in switch instead of
using this node
so one more shortcut is if you drag off
of this and type in select
depending on the value of this enum you
can make it do certain things so let me
remove the switch here
so now what I'm saying is if the value
of fruits choice is Apple this is the
value that will be passed so in this
case I'll just type in one for example
and over here I'm going to type 2 and 3.
so what we are saying is if the value of
this enumeration is Apple it's going to
print out one so the value which will be
returned here is going to be this value
same with the other two choices so if I
press play you see it says apple and it
says two that's because we had set our
choice over here if I change this to
Mango over here we are going to get
three so that's basically how
enumerations work
[Music]
real engine let's start talking about
the core scripting features in Blueprint
so the first thing that you can do is
create functions now a function is
basically a block of code which adds
functionality to your program so what I
mean by that so in order to create a new
function you can go ahead and click on
this plus icon right here
and we could call it whatever we want we
could call this one my function
and generally speaking you would use
Pascal case so basically each word is
going to start with an uppercase
character
so generally that's a convention you use
you could use a space as well in
Blueprint but generally it's not a good
practice
now I can call this function from my
event graph now if you see you have
opened two tabs one is the event graph
and one is my function so I can close my
function and I can double click on this
on the left hand side to open it as well
now if I drag this in
or if I right click and type in my
function
you can go ahead and call it so
basically this is going to execute my
function
so let's go ahead and actually do
something with it now inside my function
this is blank right now I can just go
ahead and print a string
and we can call this one my function is
executed
so I think I butchered the spelling but
doesn't matter
so if I go ahead and press play you see
my function is executed
now we can also pass in values so I have
created this points variable here so
just create a new variable and make it
of type integer and call it points
now if you head into your function and
click on this block right here
you can actually add input and output
parameters so if I click on the plus
icon
and change the type to integer and I can
call this one points
so I can take this points value from
outside the function so if you look at
this now
you see I can pass in points
so that's pretty handy now I can go
ahead and print this out as well
so I can print out my function is
executed and I can print out points as
well
and if you double click on the wire you
can use the reroute node to keep things
a bit clean
now if I press play
you see you get my function is executed
and you get 0. now if I change the value
of points for example
you see we get that number
so this is basically how input
parameters work
now what if you had some return value
now let's say instead of points this was
health so let me just call this one
Health
so compile that and over here if I click
on this once again I can add in an
output and you see it creates a return
node for us
so this is basically like your return
keyword in C plus plus so when your
function goes to this it's going to exit
the function and the value whatever you
want is going to be returned now you
need not have it you can have an empty
return node as well
now in our case let's just return a
Boolean and let's just call it
be killed for example and let's change
the name of this to be
Health as well
and we could do a simple if check we
will talk about if as soon as we finish
functions events and stuff like that
so if
I can't do that so let me just grab in
an if
if this value
that is our health
is less than zero
or less than or equal to 0
then
what we can do
is if it is true and if you type in Ctrl
D you can have two return nodes
so if our health is less than zero
it's going to be true otherwise it's
going to be a false now you can go ahead
and print this out over here
now our health is 32
so we should have false
let's say we set our health to be -1
which is invalid of course but we get
true
so this is how you can return values
outside a function
now one aspect of functions which I did
not cover and I'm recording this a bit
later
it is going to be local variables so
what if you had some variable which you
wanted only within a function
so let's say for example we have a
variable temp for example so let's say
you wanted a number to be stored
temporarily inside so for that case you
would use this local variable option
they work exactly the same as you would
as it works in C plus plus and one more
thing the input parameters whatever you
take are also local variables so you can
just grab an in and instead of dragging
this actually you can right click and
type in in
and if I just get it so I should find it
at the very end of somewhere
or rather let me just type it get in
so N is a really commonly used word so
that's the reason we are getting it so
many times here so let's actually change
it so let's just type in in one two
three let's say so n one two three so
you can get it actually
so you don't actually have to drag this
let's say you have a large blueprint
graph you don't have to drag it actually
you could you could just do this over
here that works totally fine as well
even over here actually you could do
this and it's totally valid
so that's about it for local variables
as you use them you will kind of
understand their purpose but without a
solid example we will not actually be
able to tell the use case however once
we actually get to the end where we
actually create something that is when
we'll get to practical examples
[Music]
at the base level those are what
functions are and we will go a lot more
in depth about functions events and
stuff so not to worry about that I'll
just go ahead and deleted that let's
create a new one once again and now
let's talk about the limitations and
let's talk about the next type of
scripting feature in Blueprint now one
limitation that you would see is you
cannot add a delay so if I right click
and type in delay you actually don't get
a delay note the reason is
you cannot have latent nodes inside a
function in Blueprint
so delay is actually a latent function
so what I mean by that is it actually
takes some time to execute so let's say
I cut or copy this and paste it in here
you see I cannot do that it says one or
more copied notes could not be pasted
into this graph
so the way you can handle this is you
can use a macro now macros and
blueprints are more like functions than
C plus plus macros so they work a little
bit different
now if I call this one my macro for
example
I can go ahead and add a delay so I I
can hold down D on my keyboard and left
click and I can add in a delay one thing
you'll notice is by default it doesn't
have any input or output pins you can go
ahead and add that
but there is another advantage of macros
now for example let's say we we have a
database
on our server and let's say it takes
some time to retrieve the data so let's
say it takes around 0.5 seconds for your
computer to connect to the database and
retrieve the data this is just an
example it could be anything that takes
time for example uh the prime number
program takes some time to execute after
you go to a larger number
so while this is being executed
now let's say you just wanted to print
out something saying that it's starting
and then you want to do something else
when it's completed this is where it can
come handy
now you can type in print string
and you can call this one
starting now
you could come in here and now you would
notice this execution pin got
disconnected you can't do them parallely
but there's a workaround for that you
can type in sorry sequence
and over here you can just print this
out and then you can go ahead and
perform this
and over here in the output as well you
can drag this in and a handy thing which
you cannot do in your return node in
your function is you can have one more
of these
so now if I just give a longer delay so
that we can recognize it
and if I drag in my macro
and if I print out strings over here
and over here
so we'll call this one done and here
let's just print
starting underscore outside for example
so if I press play starting now and
starting outside got executed first then
after two seconds are done was executed
so things like that can be done by
macros which you cannot do in functions
[Music]
now the whole point of using our own
macros and functions is of course code
reusability so let's say I want to call
this macro once again I can just type in
my macro
and I can call it now one difference I
would like to mention and then we'll
head into the next one which is collapse
graphs is with a function let's say I
call this my function
my function
I can actually execute this from another
blueprint but this is not true for level
blueprints it's a little more tricky to
do it from level level blueprints you
you guys will understand why once we
actually head into classes and stuff
but I'll just show you guys a simple
example so I'll just create a blueprint
here of type actor and we'll talk in
depth about this later and let's say I
create a function as you can see the
same uh
features in the blueprint are available
here and let's just call it warrant test
for example
compile that now if I were to get an
object reference to new blueprint so
I'll just do that by dragging it into
the level
so I'll drag this
and I'll create a reference
and if you can notice I can actually
call test from here however if I create
a macro
so let's just call this one test M for
test macro
you would see even once I save and
compile everything
I cannot call test m i see test but I
don't see test M so that's one more
difference between a macro and a
function you cannot call a macro from
you know uh other blueprints but you can
call functions from other blueprints of
course if you set the axis specifier to
be private in that then you can't call
functions either but you can by default
now what if you didn't want to reuse
them what if you just had this code but
this looks a bit messy so you wanted
them to be shown as one node let's say
this whole thing did something one you
could just press C on your keyboard and
comment it
however there's another feature in
unreal called collapsed graphs now you
can right click and click on collapse
nodes and it's going to create a
collapsed graph now you can have inputs
and outputs here as well but in my
experience I have never really bothered
using them
and let's just call this one my collapse
graph
and if I go ahead and type in my
collapse graph by right clicking
so let's say I type in my collapse graph
you see I cannot call it because this is
not a function this is just all of this
code
just stuffed into this collapsed graph
so I lost my event graph here you can
head back in or you can click on this
away
so that's basically a collapsed craft
that's about it and when we actually use
them you will get an idea you can
actually have further execution so let's
say I have this
so it's going to come out of here as
well
so stuff like that so I'll go ahead and
delete that it's not of much relevance
[Music]
now that we have studied about functions
macros and collapse graphs let's
actually look at implementing the
various programming constructs inside
blueprint so we'll use the level
blueprint again and after this we will
get to actually working with blueprint
classes now the first thing that you
would want to do is do an if check and
we already did that several times so if
you right click and type in Branch or
you could just type in if
or you could hold down B on your
keyboard and left click that's another
shortcut which I like to use you would
bring up a branch node so a branch node
takes in a Boolean and depending on its
value it's either going to go true or
false this is an execution pin again so
depending on the value of this variable
you can go ahead and execute some logic
so instead of Health let's say I have B
Alive as a variable so if the player is
alive for example
so put that in so if the player is alive
then we are going to go ahead and run
this logic otherwise we are going to run
this
now there's another thing which you can
do with booleans which I probably
mentioned for enums but you can actually
do a select as well so if I go ahead and
select
you can go ahead and do this so again
you can actually get this return value
to take it to change depending on the
value of this variable
so this comes in pretty handy
now this is the most basic type and
there's nothing much to explain really
so you could go ahead and print
something and maybe do something else
and if he's not alive maybe you can go
ahead and you can quit the game or
anything like that
so that's basically it
[Music]
now the next construct that you'll use
is switch now switch is something which
we already talked about but we are going
to go a bit more in depth now now I'll
change this variable to an integer again
or rather I'll just undo everything so
that we have our integer back okay I've
saved it in between so we can't
so I'll just change the variable type
and for this we are going to rename this
to let's say health again
now I have health
so oops let's just compile that again
control drag it now if I drag off of
this and type in switch
you would see that I get the switch on
end node now basically what this means
is if I just click on ADD pin
and you can also set the start index so
let's say you want it to be negative 1
to start with you could do that as well
negative 2 for example
so what you are basically saying is if
the value of health is 1
head into this execution pin
otherwise default is basically like an
else
so if none of these corresponds so let's
say we have one two and three if the
health is neither one nor two not three
it's going to head into default
so for example if I just go ahead and
print now since our health is 0 and we
are starting at 1 we should get hello
printed in theory
so we get hello
if I go ahead and drag off of one you're
not going to get anything
now the same thing if I just change the
value to 1
I change the health variable value to 1.
now you should get hello
so this is how switch Works generally I
would be using this with enumeration so
for example we have my inner mother
so let's just delete everything in the
graph now my enum
my enum now if I
grab this into the graph and if I then
type in switch you see
you get the options so if health
okay we can rename that to something a
little more descriptive so let's just
type in some enum
so if our enum if some enum is Apple
this is going to be executed if some
enum is banana this is going to be
executed if some enum is mango this is
going to be executed so this is
basically how switch works so that's
about it actually now
this was for your selection and to
evaluate condition
[Music]
now coming to the iterative constructs
let's say you wanted to print numbers
from 1 to 10 you can use a loop now if
you guys are familiar with CC plus plus
these will seem much much easier to deal
with there are basically two types of
Loop and there is a version of while
loop called do while loop so the types
are while and far
and there is one more type which you use
a lot which is for each and we will get
to that once we start talking out arrays
now if I right click and type in while
you see you get while loop
so what this basically means is as long
as this Boolean is true
so I can change this to Boolean once
again
as long as this is true
this value is going this Loop body is
going to be executed so for example
uh let's say uh let's actually make this
a number again let's change this let's
say I wanted to print numbers from 0 to
10. so I'd set the sum enum or we'll
call this one num we can set num to be
equal to 0 by default
and now we can do an if check as long as
number is less than or equal to 0
or rather 10
we can go ahead and print our number so
we can go ahead and type in print string
and we can just Ctrl D print it out
now obviously the this is an infinite
Loop you have to change the value of num
itself so what I can do is I can set
num
to be equal to num Plus 1.
so this is one way to do it
also if you were to notice if you just
drag off of the sentiment plus plus you
can actually do increment as well so
this is basically like your num plus
plus in C plus plus that's how we would
interpret that
now if I go ahead and press play you
should see we get numbers from 0 to 10
as expected so that's basically how you
use a while loop and once this Loop is
done again you can go ahead and print
something so let's say printed numbers
printed numbers
now you see it prints from 0 to 10
and it just goes to completed this is
how we would execute your logic one
thing to note though avoid using Loops
in your program especially in Blueprint
unless the array length is you know less
than about a few hundred it's fine but
let's say you're dealing with larger
data sets please refrain from using
Loops in Blueprint uh try to use as much
as you can in C plus plus
because blueprint if I haven't mentioned
yet is slower compared to C plus plus
when you call Print string for example
this is actually a function called in C
plus plus so the actual function of
print string is written in C plus plus
it actually takes a little bit of
processing to actually switch between
blueprint and C plus plus blueprint is
kind of like your jvm where it actually
runs on a virtual machine so blueprint
code is going to be comparatively slower
than C plus plus but in this case this
code is pretty simple so you don't
really need to do that we will get to
where to use blueprint and C plus plus
much much later there's nothing much to
worry about for simple games
[Music]
now the other type is going to be a for
Loop
so if I just type in for Loop you see
you get for Loop this is how you
basically execute your for Loop however
this is a little more or actually much
more easier than what you have to do in
C plus plus in C plus plus you give an
initialization expression an update
expression and a conditional expression
I am mixed up the order but anyways you
get the point and you got to actually
give the body of the loop like that but
here in Blueprint you just type in a
first and the last index which makes it
very very simple for you to execute a
for Loop and if you were to just drag
this in let's say I just type in 0 and
10. and I just go ahead and print this
we don't even need a variable at this
point
we can just grab this
and we can go ahead and run this and
it's going to print 0 to 10. so this is
how you use a for Loop now there is
another variation known as the for each
Loop which is used similar to range
based for Loop in C plus plus to iterate
arrays and stuff like that we will talk
about that now again the completed works
the same way once this Loop is completed
executing you can go ahead and print
something
or execute whatever logic you have so
this is your for Loop and there is
another variant of for Loop called the
for loop with brick
so if I just type in for loop with brick
you see you get this now let's say I
wanted to stop at a certain point
let's say
uh I mean in this case it's kind of
useless to do it but let's say I wanted
to stop in between let's say I have some
logic we can just grab in some random
logic uh let's say this number divided
by 15 you know uh we have to make this
float remember because integer division
works in a different way
so let's say this number divided by 15
if it is greater than 3.5 we want to
break let's say we have that logic
so we are going to print as long as this
number divided by 15 is greater than 3.5
so do that if this is true we are going
to break whoops
and if we go ahead and print this we can
just go ahead and print the number
instead
and once this is completed we can print
something else now obviously to tidy
this up you can use a reroute node and
you can do this
so this is one way to keep your
blueprint craft ID
so we can type in completed
so that's done
and we have a compiler error it says
so
okay we'll we'll take that in as a float
so convert this pin to a float
convert this pin to a float and then
let's just do that
and let's compile this again
save
and go ahead and press play
now we would see it's 52
so if we actually bring up our
calculator
so we get 51 by 15 is going to be 3.4
and 52 divided by 15 is going to be
3.466 so that should be the last number
so now if I do 53 divided by 15 you see
you get 3.53 which is greater than 3.5
so it did not print that
foreign
to head into R for each Loop now for
this we'll need to learn about another
data structure now this is a variable
right over here where you select the
variable type to the right of it you get
an option to change it to an array set
or a map now an array is basically
a collection of homogeneous elements so
basically in this case num is now no
longer a single number
instead it is a collection of numbers
and why I say homogeneous is because I
can only have integers in this list I
can't have 0 and I can't have a string
in the next index so basically each item
is going to be referenced by an index so
the first item which you put in is going
to be 0 and stuff like that you can put
in any number and if I have to iterate
through this I will use a for each Loop
now if I go ahead and print this out
you would be able to see that I print in
all the elements in that array so I
printed in 2 and 32.
which is what exactly what we have so
that's basically how it works now one
more thing you can have it of any type
in case you guys were confused I'll
create a new one for example uh let's
just call it one Str array
and let's make it of type string and
let's compile that and I can go ahead
and add a few elements I can I can just
type in any set of characters
and I could iterate through this as well
so I can just drag this in
compile that and go ahead and run this
program
now you see you can print that as well
so this basically stores multiple of the
data types elements and one more thing
since this is an array this is more of a
theory thing but
the elements here so this string so
let's just actually name it one two and
three for our reference
so 1 is 1 2 and 3 these are actually
stored in continuous memory locations so
iterating through them is actually a
relatively cheap option now
unfortunately Unreal Engine does not
provide us with a linked list structures
in Blueprint we have to implement that
ourselves if we needed to but most of
the times you'll be using arrays and
Maps you will not be using sets or
linked lists most of the time however it
is Handy to use linked lists in some
very rare occasions but we will not be
going over that anyways so let's just
delete all of this we are done with this
so that's basically our array and your
for each Loop now you can have an array
of structures as well it's totally fine
so I guess we called our my struct if
I'm not wrong
we could have an array of those that's
about it basically you could store any
type of element now I can go ahead and
click on the plus icon and I can add the
name and points and it works just as you
would expect so I can go ahead and
delete this we don't need that anymore
[Music]
foreign
now along with your regular if switch
and your Loops unreal in blueprints
provides us with a a couple of Handy
nodes which you might need one of them
is called flip flop
so what does it mean so flip flop is
basically basically this is how a flip
flop works if this execution pin goes in
once a is going to be executed otherwise
if you come here again B is going to be
executed so let me actually show you
what I mean
so if I just drag this in
and if I print and let's just say a is
executed
and now if I just go ahead and given a
delay of let's say a second
and if I copy this over and let's just
type in B is executed give a delay of a
second and again head back over there so
I'll just use a reroute to make things a
little more clear for you guys
now make sure you guys do comprehend
this logic correctly
if I go ahead and press play
you would see it says a is executed B is
executed and it's going to be
alternating like that so that's the use
of a flip flop you could use this uh for
key presses so let's say you wanted
something to happen when you press the
key once but you wanted something else
to happen when you press the key again
so for example let's say you have a
scoping in uh thing in your game so
let's say a scoping into your weapon
let's say the first time when you flip
flop to a you want the guy to scope in
and when you flip flop to B you want
your weapon to scope out so that's
basically one place where you can use
flip flop so it's pretty simple
[Music]
now one more thing which the engine
provides is do once
now do ones and there's also a gate node
which you might need but I honestly
never gotten an actual use case for this
so there's nothing much to really worry
about this but it's it can come in handy
depending on your game especially if
you're going for you know puzzle type
games maybe
not really sure so do ones basically as
the name suggests it just allows you to
execute this one time so let's say I
print the string
and I go back to this this is no longer
an infinite loop it's just going to
execute it once
look it just executed hello and that's
about it
now let's say I want to call this
function just once again so what I can
do is I can drag this into reset so if
anything goes into this reset the
function which goes after completed will
be allowed to execute once again so
that's basically how do once works I
don't think there's any explanation
required for it so if I do it on tick so
basically every frame it's going to
allow you to do it once again and if I
just go ahead and re-execute this I know
this is an infinite Loop but we do have
a little bit of a duration for us in the
tick
so that's how it will work
okay so it did stop the execution over
there that's a different thing but yeah
basically reset is going to let you do
that once again
so I can actually get a more practical
example so let's say we have a delay of
0.2 seconds and we do this I can
actually use a sequence so sequence
remember the node which we used before
so after 0.2 seconds I can go ahead and
reset that
and after let's say not 0.5 seconds I
can try executing that once again
so if I go ahead and press play you see
it works as expected
[Music]
whatever we spoke until now were just
the basics in order to get you started
with Unreal Engine but in order to
actually practically create a game we
need to First go into some background so
that we can learn how to use classes and
objects now if you guys aren't aware
Unreal Engine or any game engine in
general is going to be working on the
principle of object oriented programming
a bit of a background here so there are
two main programming methods that we'll
talk about now the first one is
procedural programming so this is the
approach used in languages such as C
where basically your approach is mainly
using functions so procedures that's
what basically procedural programming
stands for so you have a main function
and you have several other functions
now this is the most simplest form of
what it could be however you could have
a function over here as well so let's
say you have function 4 for example and
maybe function 4 can call function 2 or
vice versa doesn't really matter but
basically your whole program is divided
into multiple functions and there is
some global data on which it operates on
so you have some data over here and
maybe function three accesses some data
here stuff like that could happen in
procedural programming
however the approach which is used in
unreal in object-oriented programming
languages such as C plus plus is going
to be object oriented programming of
course as the name suggests
and here we use a principle known as
classes
and an instance of this class is known
as an object so let me be a little more
specific here so all the data and
functions so for example or in this case
this was a method this was the main
function so we have one method here
another one and we also have some data
over here
so all of this is going to be
encapsulated into a unit known as a
class and I will get to some examples
later
so once we have this encapsulated we can
go ahead and create instances of these
called objects so basically your class
acts as a template for these objects
now
the first question that pops up in your
mind would be why do we use object
oriented programming over procedural
well it's pretty simple to explain that
so if we look at the wrong approach that
is procedural programming
you would know that you would have a
character let's say for example so let's
actually talk about a character which
you'll have in a game and how we would
approach it with both programming
methods
so in procedural programming you would
have a character of course you are not
defining any unit known as character but
let's say we have a character in a
program and you you're going to have
several functions so you have move turn
jump of course you'll have other
functions I just took the most Bare
Bones example and obviously you'll have
the characters transform and if you guys
forgot about what transform is transform
is basically location rotation and the
scale combined then you're also going to
have a velocity for the character health
and other variables pertaining to your
gameplay
however there is one problem which you
might notice we do not have a unit which
we can recognize as a character so we
have several functions let's say we call
the move function for example now when
we move when we call the move function
we actually have no idea which character
we are moving so character itself
is not actually an entity so we don't
have an actual entity known as a
character our program just has functions
same with the transform we cannot
instantiate another character so this
code this entire code isn't reusable so
that's the problem now what if we head
back into the object oriented type so if
we head back
and if you can see here we have a class
and we have instantiated several objects
now if you were to actually model a
character with this you would have your
character class obviously with the above
mentioned functions and data I didn't
want to rewrite that so you'd have a
character class
and now that we actually have a unit
which we can identify as a character we
can go ahead and instantiate a character
and let's say we call it character one
so we are going to instantiate it so we
are going to instantiate it and let's
say we have another player let's say an
enemy so we can go ahead and reuse that
once again and instantiate character too
so now we don't have to rewrite all the
functions and whenever we are actually
writing code we have an idea of which
exact character we are referring to so
character 2 is actually a real time
entity and this is known as an object so
character one is an object character two
and character 3 all these three are
objects now if you were to remember in
our blueprint notes we had a Target pin
so if I bring in for example set actor
location
so I'll just use the same node so set
actor location
now you would notice there is a
character pin now if you were to just
hover over it it says actor object
reference now
in our programming approach what this
basically means is we have set actor
location defined in our class so let's
say for example
we have something like this so we have
our actor class now anything that can be
placed in the level is called an actor
so let's actually
create that so actor
so inside this inside actor you actually
have a set actor location method so set
that to location and not write the whole
thing
and let's say you instantiate actor one
so let's call it A1 for example when you
instantiate actor 1 your program needs
to know on which actor set actor
location has to be called
so we have actor 1 so that is our Target
so when we call set actor location in
our case in a blueprint we call set at
the location now it needs to know on
which actor it has to perform it so when
you call this in the through the target
pin in Blueprint that's how we will do
it in the Target pin you specify that
and the program knows that it has to set
a one's location so that's how it
basically works foreign
so it's time we apply whatever we
learned just now so head into your
content folder and create a new folder
and we'll just call this one blueprints
and inside here we'll create all our
blueprint classes and we will compare
all of them so basically the most Bare
Bones one which you can create is an
object now please do not confuse this
with an actual object we are creating a
class and the class name is going to be
object we are basically deriving a class
from this object class this is how you
basically start in Blueprint however as
you proceed further you will understand
note that this is not an actor so I
cannot drag this into a level now if as
I mentioned before Unreal Engine already
has a 2d Vector structure but just to
Showcase what we can do with such
classes let me just actually create a 2d
Vector so let's just call this one
2D Vector for example
now please note you cannot name a type
with a number beginning in you know C
plus plus however you can do that in
Blueprint so let me just call this on
Vector 2 for example
so if I open this up
you you would see you have a standard
blueprint editor you have an event graph
but you don't have your viewport and
stuff like that which you would see in
an actor now one more thing you would
notice is you don't have an event pick
and play so you get an option to add a
custom event which is basically like
defining a function but it does not
return anything and you can call it just
like a function and we will be using a
lot of custom events so you would get an
idea of what I mean
now in Vector 2 we are going to have two
variables the first two are going to be
floats
so obviously we'll think about what we
can have later on so it's going to be an
X and A Y
so these are the variables which are
encapsulated inside this Vector 2 class
note that this is not an object this is
a class and when we actually create an
instance of this we create a vector too
so that's how it basically works now we
don't want this X and Y variable to be
directly accessible
now the reason I wanted this way is for
data security now I don't want to be
directly able to write any random value
to X and Y let's say this was exposed
and you could actually change this
directly in memory what would happen is
now for example let's say I have a
vector 2 object so let me just create
that so use the construct object
function so construct object from class
so I think I misspelled that so
construct
object from class yep there we have it
so I'll just delete this and if you go
ahead we will get access to our vector
2.
so Vector 2 for example
now we have a vector 2 object over here
so this is actually a vector 2 object we
could go ahead and promote that to a
variable so it's going to create a
variable of that type and let's just
call this one R vector
now we don't want any other
external entity to actually be able to
directly set X
so this would be prone to lots of
exploits basically
so that's the reason what you generally
do in object oriented is you make this
private you see the option over here
called private now basically you will
not be able to access X and Y from here
so now if I type in get X you see I
can't get it if I type in set X
I cannot set X so that's one way of
providing security to the data now what
if you just wanted to access the value
that's pretty simple you would just go
ahead and create a function so you type
in get x value for example so get X
and get y
and we are going to make this PR
functions because we are just returning
the immediate value
and we could add a compact node title
and call This One X
and we'll call this one y
now in the return node we could just go
ahead and return the value so return
node
and we can go ahead and grab our y here
and return that
and over here as well we can go ahead
and return X
so grabbing the return node and return X
so now if you wanted to access X or Y
you can go ahead and type in get X
so you will get access to the x value
however you will not be able to edit X
directly
so again for that we can go ahead and
create setters
so Setters are basically just functions
which are going to set the value so
let's say I type in set X
and I type in set set y I accidentally
type text again
so set White
all right so once that's set we can go
ahead and take in the value
and this is going to be
of type float
and we can go ahead and set our y to be
equal to that
and we can go ahead and type in let it
the return node we don't really need it
in this case but anyways we'll have it
and in our set X function we could do
the exact same thing we could add in an
input pin and call this one value once
again
value
and we can go ahead and add in a return
node
whoops we didn't need that
now what if you just wanted to set this
entire vector
now when we set R Vector we are actually
just getting a reference to it we are
not actually setting our members
so we can go ahead and write a function
for that again we could get add a get
Vector to
and we could also have a set Vector too
so something like this this was just to
show you guys how we would work with
classes and objects so
for get Vector 2
we can go ahead and
actually return the value
so we can go ahead and add in the return
node
and we can get our X and our y
so things like that
so for a set Vector 2 we can go ahead
and all track this
or track this once again
now obviously please do understand that
this is kind of impractical
unreal already has a struct built in
which handles all this for us I'm just
trying to show you an example of how you
would actually use it
so this is how you do it so now if I
type in set Vector 2 you see I can
actually set its value and the target is
R Vector so we are adjusting this value
and we could go ahead and write in a few
more functions so for example we could
write a function to print the vector to
so print vector 2.
so we can go ahead and type in print
string
and we need a word context object
however it is going to take the outer
object by default I believe but anyways
in these contexts what you would want to
do with something which I haven't seen
much is you would just get the outer
object there is a function for this
basically the outer object is the object
from which the subject was created so in
our case it's our level blueprint and we
can call the print function from there
the reason is it actually needs to know
uh where to actually print the string so
that's the reason actually
so now I can just type in self self
refers to this object itself so we can
just pass that in
now we can go ahead and actually print
something so in our case we can get our
X
and one handy function which you'll use
a lot is going to be append so we can go
ahead and type in X for the x value give
a space and then print out RX
move that over there to keep things
clean
and we can go ahead and do the same for
the Y as well so we can go ahead and
give a space
and we can type in y with a colon
and we can go ahead and print that
so we have our y
we can go ahead and convert that once
again
and we can go ahead and print that if
you right click you can actually remove
the extra pin so that's an option
available as well
so now this is how you do it now if I go
ahead and press play
obviously we are not calling it anywhere
so now now that we have R Vector we can
go ahead and call Print vector2
so this is going to print our vector
so this is how it works
and obviously we can also test out our
set functions so we can type in set
vector2
and we can just give some random values
to this and if we go ahead and print
Vector 2 we should get that value
so this is basically how we would work
with the most basic type of object now
this is mostly useful in cases where you
only need some data and methods and you
want methods basically because in
Blueprint you cannot have struct methods
so in those cases you would use an
object type
so we are not going to be messing with
this any further
[Music]
now the the next type which you will use
is going to be an actor now this is
probably the most commonly used type and
most of the other types of class
official create will also be derived
from actor so let me just create that
right click go to blueprint class and
create an actor it's directly available
here or you could search down there
so if I create an actor we'll call this
one my actor for example
now if you were to notice if I drag this
I cannot do that because you cannot
place a vector 2 in your scene right
however I can drag my actor and I can
place it in the scene and if I hit F on
my keyboard I can actually see it now
this is just a visual representation in
the editor so that you can actually see
it however if you hit G on your keyboard
to go to game view it actually won't be
seen
now if you were to open your actor you
would see the editor is a little more
complicated than your basic object you
have three tabs the viewport the
construction script and the event graph
where you will be working with most of
the time we will separately talk about
construction scripts and we'll also get
to the viewport but of our relevance is
the event graph right now and we will
talk a little bit more about actors
you would also notice that we have our
begin play and tick which we missed in
our basic object type class
now if we wanted to have multiple of
these actors so let's actually do
something practical let's say we had a
pickup actor in our game so we have pick
up actor
and it's generally a convention you do
something like this
BP underscore pickup
because more often than not or here if
you see the parent class it says actor
right so more often than not you will
actually create another class of your
own in C plus plus so any code that
needs to run fast or something you would
put that in C plus plus and then you
would derive BP pickup from the C plus
plus pickup actor so that's why it's a
convention I usually name it like this
so I can go ahead and grab this so I
have BP pickup whoops deleted the wrong
thing so I can delete my actor here BP
pickup 2 will be created so these two
are pickups and both of these contain
all the variables and functions which
this creates
so you can go ahead and edit our
blueprint just like how we would usually
all right so it's time to dive a little
bit more deeper into some of these
events and let's actually start writing
some practical code
so event begin play is called not when
the game begins actually that's the
wrong way to interpret it however event
begin play is called when this actor is
instantiated so for example we have our
BP pickup here and since this is placed
in our level this will get created as
soon as our level starts so it is
technically called when the game starts
however if I just go ahead and print
this
and
let's just call this begin play
you would see two begin place because we
have two instances of our BP pickup
however
it need not be called when the game
begins it is called when the pickup
actor is actually created so when BP
pickup is created that is when it is
called so let's delete a vector 2 stuff
we don't really need it now in order to
actually create an actor remember that
every actor is going to have a location
rotation and scale so that's the reason
you cannot just create an object because
you do need a certain number of
default parameters in order to actually
be able to place something in the scene
so without a location the engine has no
idea of where to place it that's the
reason actor exists now if you head back
into your level blueprint let's actually
give a delay of a few seconds just to
show you guys
so let's say we give a delay of two
seconds and in order to create an actor
you call a function known as Pawn actor
so spawn actor from class and over here
under spawn transform we could just set
that to zero for now it's since we don't
have any visual representation it
doesn't matter honestly
so once that's done we can go ahead and
select our BP pickup
and we can go ahead and compile it now
if I press play you see begin play is
called but two seconds later another
begin place called if you guys couldn't
catch that I'll leave a longer delay
begin play
and another begin play was called and if
you would notice in the outliner
you would actually notice another
instance being created here
so if you were to notice there is
another BP pickup that is created so
that's basically how it works
and tick is called every frame however
it need not be once again
so if I just go ahead or I can just go
and reuse it actually
so instead of this I'm going to type in
tick
and now this should be called every
frame let's have let's only have one
pickup actor and let's go ahead and not
spawn this
so if you want to disconnect pins like
that by the way you can go ahead and
press alt over here and it's going to
disconnect the pin so we don't need that
now
if you were to notice it's going to
constantly print tick
so this should be about 200 to 300 times
a second on my computer so if I just
type in stat FPS
whoops missed that start FPS
it's locked at 120 so it's 120 times a
second
so if you want to increase it actually
you can remove the cap by typing in t
dot Max FPS space Max FPS give something
like 999 or 1000
all right so I don't know I did that
now head back into your blueprints
under your pickup and under your class
defaults you can actually disable your
tick
so you can go ahead and disable and as
you can see nothing's being printed
now there's another thing
you can actually change this parameter
at runtime as well people don't know
this but any and all details which are
there in this panel over here so let's
say for example I go to my class
defaults
I will definitely be able to change most
of these at runtime so for example we
have start with tick enabled so we
should be able to enable or disable tick
at runtime so let's actually just type
in tick enabled
and as you can see there is actually a
function which lets us do it so if I go
ahead and actually enable tick first of
all
and if I go ahead and disable it after
one second you would notice that Tech is
being printed and a second letter it
stops printing tick so that's basically
how it works and not only that any and
all parameters and you can actually
change the tick interval as well let's
say it's printing too often you could
just set it to 0.5 so it will be roughly
0.5 seconds now as you can see it is not
printing as frequently so that's
basically one aspect in blueprints that
that is Handy to know because any and
all settings that will be there will be
usually uh exposed as functions to be
adjusted at runtime otherwise again you
have your class defaults where you can
actually set them I think whatever we
did till now is clear now so we can go
ahead and delete this code we won't be
using it as of now so now let's go ahead
and actually write some code for the
pickup itself so let's say we had an
object and we had to pick it up first
things first there is no visual
representation for the object so let's
say we actually just go ahead and oops
okay go ahead and press play you would
see that you can't actually see anything
no
if I zoom into this so as you can see
you can't actually see this pickup so
first of all let's actually add in a
model and stuff like that now there is
one thing
uh the default scene root is not
actually required if I delete it I won't
be able to however I can actually add in
a static mesh now a skeletal mesh is a
mesh which contains Burns and stuff like
that so basically your characters and
anything with animations is going to be
a skeletal mesh basically however your
models like your pickups and stuff
usually are going to be static meshes
so that's basically how it works as you
use them you will understand so now if I
drag this into the default scene root
I'll go ahead and delete the visual
representation and the static mesh will
be replaced now one thing to note when
you do this the most high component the
component which is the uppermost in the
hierarchy over here is called the root
component so for example this default
scene root is the root component now
when I drag the static mesh this is the
root component and if physics has to be
simulated in our case let's actually try
that let's make the pickup fall down and
follow the laws of physics so in that
case we will need it to be the root
component so that's one thing to note
now if I go ahead and select a mesh so
for example I can just select this
random sphere that we have I think it's
way too big so
yeah we got to adjust that
now I can go ahead and enable simulate
physics
so now if I go ahead and press play
you see that it falls like you would
expect
so we basically simulated physics now we
have a visual representation now how are
we actually going to pick this up now
actually let's select something a little
more smaller because
I don't think this is convenient
okay this seems like a reasonable size
so if we go ahead and press play
we are simulating physics so absolutely
no problem with that and one thing to
remember in case you are not simulating
physics make sure you do have collision
and stuff like that if you if we
actually encounter such an issue I will
go ahead and show you guys how to deal
with that
so we have physics now now we can go
ahead and set up some logic now
we want to be able to pick this up when
we overlap it let's say for example so
we can do on actor begin overlap
so what this says is when another actor
overlaps this actor so in our case it's
going to be this when it overlaps this
actor we can go ahead and perform some
logic and Unreal Engine has set this up
for us now there is one problem though
this is just R Cube which is our model
however we don't have an actual bound so
our code won't really be able to know
when to actually call on actor begin
overlap so even if I disable Collision
so the way you do that is you can head
over here
and from physics actor you could go
ahead and change it but we do need
physics so we can't do that even if we
actually bump into this you won't really
notice anything happen so if I go ahead
and bump it to this nothing is really
going to happen
now if I actually go ahead and creates a
bound so the way you do that is right
click or rather go to add and you can
type in a sphere I believe
sphere Collision yes
so when you create a sphere Collision we
could call this one bounds
you would have created a sphere and you
can't see that because the size is too
small can go ahead and increase the
sphere radius
now these are our bounds so as soon as
we enter this our on active begin
overlap will be triggered so we can go
ahead and print it
and if you were to notice the Collision
preset over here under the details panel
select this and head into your Collision
preset you see it says overlap all
Dynamic and obviously if you select
custom you can go ahead and edit each
Channel and we will talk about this
later
so if I go ahead and press play
you see we get hello every time we
overlap it
[Music]
now hello is going to be printed every
time any other actor overlaps this
however we want to print hello only if a
character overlaps it and it need not be
a character as well now in unreal
character is actually a derived class of
another class known as pawn and I will
talk a little more in depth about this
right now so basically this is how it's
laid out in unreal basically we are
looking for a pawn and I will get to
that in just about a minute so we can
type in pawn and if you were to scroll
down you would see cast to pawn so cast
is another programming feature now if
you were to feed in an object to this
you can check whether it is upon object
so now if I go ahead and print this out
now uh you would go ahead and actually
get hello just normally
the reason is when you are actually
controlling your camera over here
you are actually controlling a pawn
actor
anything that can be possessed by a
player controller is known as a pawn and
we will talk a little more in depth
right now and just to clear your doubts
on whether this logic actually work
let's say it wasn't a pawn so which
means it's not a player basically so if
I copy this over and instead of hello
let's just print not player
and now if I go ahead and press play
you'd see you won't get anything
and if I overlap it it says hello but if
I go ahead and copy this over and let's
say I keep it above this and if I press
play you see you get not player printed
that is because
the Box overlapped another box
or rather RBP pickup overlapped another
BP pickup however those are not
characters so this cast right here
failed because the object which came
from this actor begin overlap was not a
pawn hence we got not player printed
foreign
part of the course I'll just tell you
guys the most basic form of inheritance
hierarchy which is there and unreal
however once we get to the more advanced
part I will tell you guys more in depth
but as far as what you guys need to know
so at the base level the most simplest
type of class from which you can
instantiate objects is known as object
in Blueprint so object is the simplest
type and from that the most basic one
which you can create is going to be an
actor now an actor is basically an
object which has a transform and can be
placed in the level as you would have
figured by now now under this you have
various other classes however for the
most basic level we are going to be
considering only two
so there are many more and we will talk
about many others where once we actually
come to the advanced part but these are
the two which you do require to get up
and running so the first one under this
is going to be your controller
so a controller as the name suggests is
a class which has functionality for your
built-in to take player input and stuff
like that
and under controller you also have a
special type known as a player
controller and there are others such as
AI controller so you have a player
controller so player
and I'm just going to put this so play a
controller
now a player controller is basically a
controller which belongs to an actual
player you also have other things such
as AI controllers which is assigned to
CPU players basically so if you have
enemies in game for an offline game or
something you design an AI controller
now another class that you'll need is
pun and that's what we talked about so
this is called Pawn now a pawn is
basically
a class
which is an actor obviously and can be
placed in the level and note that you
cannot place a controller in a level
although it is derived from actor it is
actually an exception controllers player
States game states there are a few other
classes which are exceptions and you
can't place them in the level however
pawns can be placed in the level and a
pawn is always possessed by a player
controller so a player controller is
going to be possessing a pawn so when
you call the possess function and you
give the target as a pawn you are going
to be possessing the pawn and one
special type of Pawn which has a lot of
functionality built in for us already
is called a character most of the times
you will be working with characters and
not puns however you can use puns so by
character I mean a character such as a
living being basically so generally if
you have like a human or if you have
like an animal or something like that
you would generally use characters
however if you have something like a
vehicle you would usually stay away from
characters because it has some
properties which are not realistic for
those however it is completely possible
to use a character class for something
like a vehicle as well so you can
possess a character as well there is no
harm in that pawn or any derived class
of Pawn can be possessed by a player
controller
foreign
we can go ahead and actually create our
own character class or I should rather
say Pawn class which is also a character
class in our case so we can create that
as well as a player controller and I'll
show you guys how to set those and how
we can go about interacting with this
pickup using those so right click go
ahead and create blueprint class and as
you would see you have character and
clear controller right here because they
are really really common
so type in character and let's just type
in BP underscore character
again you can you can name it
appropriately or as per your wish
now if I go ahead and open it up you see
this looks a little more different and
it already has something set up for us
and some of these are quite handy
especially the character movement
component which is there and if I
haven't mentioned yet whatever we did
here
under the component step these are
called components basically basically
every actor is made up of several
components and you can actually create
your own components as well and make
them behave as you wish but as of now
just know that these are just
constituents of these this actor and
these are the constituents of BP pickup
and this is these are the constituents
of BP character basically now we haven't
set a mesh and we don't really have one
so let's just take okay we have
a character tutorial PPP and one thing
to note this Arrow actually represents
the forward direction of the character
so you can go ahead and move it down
and you can go ahead and rotate it 90
degrees so let let me have snapping
enabled
so rotate it by negative 90 and you can
go ahead and bring him all the way down
until I feel it's correct
now we don't have any animations but I'm
not really sure if we do have an
animation blueprint for him
so let's just check
tutorial animation blueprint I guess
tutorial animation blueprint so yeah we
do have an animation blueprint for him
now if you want to change the default
character that you will be using the way
you'll do that is by first of all
heading into Window World settings make
sure that is enabled and then over here
on the right hand side head into World
settings and under game mode override
you can go ahead and set your own game
mode now if I were to just select game
mode I still cannot edit it so I will
get to Game Mode classes later on
because they are not that important but
for now you can just go ahead and create
a new game mode and it could be of type
game mode base or it could be of type
game mode it doesn't really matter but I
would suggest sticking with game mode
base
and let's just call this one uh BP
underscore game mode
uh I just did something there
so yeah BP underscore game mode
that's what we'll call it and now under
this we will get our option to select
the game mode now since this is our
custom or custom made game mode we get
the option to select the default Pawn
class and over here we can select our BP
character and if I save everything and
if I go ahead and press play you would
see that we have indeed possessed our
character and you were to notice that
the camera is a bit off
so what you can do is you can actually
create a camera
if I go ahead and type in camera under
the component section
you can create a camera and you can
align it as per your requirement so this
should be about correct
so I feel rotating this a bit maybe a
bit back maybe a bit to the side would
be nice
so there you have it so this is our
character
however we are not actually able to move
the reason is we haven't actually
written the code for it to take our
input
Now setting up input in unreal is really
really easy and I will show you guys the
brute force method as well as the proper
way to do it so The Brood force method
is for example we want W to be able to
make us move forward so I can press W
and if you just give a space and type in
keyboard
you would be able to get W and we can
make the character move forward
so in order to make your character move
basically there's a function for us
built in already under the character
movement and not character movement I
believe it's there in our Pawn class I
believe or a character class so if you
right click and type in add movement
input
so it's written in our Pawn class we can
go ahead and make him move
and if you were to notice we have to
provide a direction and a scale value
scale value is useful if you are on a
joystick or something where you can
partially press down so let's say you're
halfway pushing the joystick uh
knob so in that case it would be 0.5 so
the scale value can be given through an
axis value
now if you were to notice ah there is
another problem here when I actually
plug this in
it's not really going to work as you
would expect so for our direction we
need the forward direction of the
character so a very simple way to do
that is typing in get forward Vector so
get actor forward vector
so get actor forward Vector so that's
the way you would actually get the word
Direction that's how you do it
and if you were to notice
it's not going to work as expected at
all the reason is this has to be called
every frame in order to actually work
so the way you do it is Type in uh or
rather we can do it on event tick for
example
so if we go ahead and do it on event
tick I'm just doing this to show you
guys how to do it if I do this now we
would see that our character is moving
forward
now the most obvious question is how am
I actually going to set this up so there
is something known as an axis mapping
which runs every frame basically what
add movement input does is it moves you
a very very slight amount and by calling
this multiple times in a single second
you are going to be adding considerable
amount of movement now if I head into my
project settings
and under input this is the right way to
do it the Brute Force wave would have
been like doing this on tick and I'll
just show you this really shouldn't be
your option but I'll just show you just
in case so for example you could just
have a Boolean here and we could just
set this to true for example and when
you release it we could set this to
false
now this is wrong so don't really worry
about the logic this is just gonna work
but you shouldn't really do this so we
could do if new variable is true we want
to move otherwise we don't want to do
anything
so if I go ahead and press play I can
press W and move but as soon as I
release it I'm going to stop this is the
Brute Force way to do it but unreal has
a much more elegant system to do it so
we can go ahead and delete all of this
head into our project settings once
again
and under input you would see action and
access mappings
now we want an axis mapping because we
do want to be able to control the scale
and since add movement input is actually
a function which depends on the scale
value so remember what I told you about
the joystick so we can create an access
mapping so for things such as jump where
there is no scale value so it's either
jumping or not jumping so wherever you
have a toggle you would have an action
mapping wherever you you have some value
which goes linearly you would have an
access mapping so we can call this one
move forward
and
make that Pascal case and we could have
W on the keyboard for that and again
for move backward we could reuse this
actually so s is going to be moved
backward
and for the scale value you can make
this negative one
now if I right click over here and if I
type in move forward
you would notice that we have an axis
mapping
so if I grab this into this input event
or rather if I bring this into this axis
move forward event and for the scale
value if I put this under access value
now this will work exactly as I would
want it to so if I go ahead and press W
it's going to work and even s is going
to work now for us
so this is basically how you do access
mappings similarly you could do it for
move right
so we could have move right or we could
call it move sideways
and we'd have our A and D keys so we
have our a key and we have our D key so
D is going to be
this one and it's going to be negative
1.
so let's actually just test it out
so
it's not really doing anything because
we didn't set up the logic obviously so
move
sideways
whoops
axis
move sideways
so once you have the event set up you
can go ahead and add the movement input
and again you can get the right Vector
of the actor so basically the right
direction of the actor is going to be
your right Vector so your forward Vector
is always in this arrows Direction and
your right Vector is going to be a
vector in this direction basically
so right vector and if I go ahead and
press play
so it's always one so that's the reason
it's happening so
if I plug that into the axis value
I am moving reverse actually right now
so that's just a simple mistake I did
here so I can type in minus one for this
and I can type in plus one for this now
everything should work as expected so if
any of your directions are reversed just
multiply the access value by -1 now as
you can see we are able to move forward
left right and all of that good stuff
now that is about it for the keyboard
input however if you were to notice I
really can't rotate the character so
let's actually set that up first so
first things first head back into your
BP character and the functions which we
require to set up keyboard input I mean
Mouse input for a character is going to
be your controller pitch input and your
controller your input so controller
pitch input
and controller your input
so these are the functions that we need
now again since our Mouse needs to be
captured as much as possible because it
it has to detect every tiny movement so
we again need to create an axis mapping
so go ahead into inputs
and create two new access mappings and
call one
look around
and the next one call it look up
and for this look around is going to be
the x-axis of the mouse so type in Mouse
X
and for this one type in Mouse y
so that should be good
and over here
if I go back and if I type in Access
look around
and we can go ahead and add your input
over here
and over here access
lookup
oops I misspelled that
so head back into input so look up
now if I go ahead and compile this and
press play
you would see that I am able to look
around
however I really am not able to you know
look up and down
that's mostly because your character
isn't really meant to rotate along with
it so that's the reason it's happening
so if I head into my camera and enable
use spawn control rotation and if I
press play you see I am able to rotate
my camera
however there's one small problem here
we are again uh doing it reverse
so again in that case as I told you guys
before just change the scale value to
negative 1.
now if I go ahead and press play you
would be able to see that our camera is
working as expected now there is one
slight issue though
that is
uh our view is kind of off which you can
fix
but when we actually look up our
character doesn't seem to be looking up
but the reason that's not happening is
because you can't just rotate the whole
character now if I were to actually go
to this uh main tab over here under BP
character
and if I search for control rotation so
if I type in control rotation
and if I enable it to use pitch
you would actually see
that I am in fact able to do that but
there is a small problem now if I hit f8
to unpossess my character you see he
just rotates like that however we want
only his spine to rotate and that is
something which we have to set up using
an animation blueprint which we will do
later so for now we'll just disable this
and even for the yaw part you could you
could disable this and
you could technically do something like
this and maybe set up some other logic
in order to actually rotate your
character but for our purposes we'll
only do it for the pitch
another tiny thing that I would love to
cover here is how do you actually set up
different sensitivities because
obviously right now
the current sensitivity may be a little
too much for some for some maybe it's a
little too less
so the way you do that
is just multiply this axis value by your
sensitivity value that's basically how
you do it
so multiply this
and multiply this as well press Ctrl D
to duplicate that
now we could just promote this to a
variable however remember that this BP
character refers to only the character
which we are playing so let's say we are
playing a death match or something where
your character dies and you respawn with
a new character you would have to pass
in the variable every time so instead of
doing this we are going to set this up
in a class which will be common
even when your character is destroyed so
the class which we'll use and as you
would expect is called player controller
so go ahead and create BP player
controller
so make sure everything is in Pascal
case
now if you open this up now over here we
can go ahead and create a variable and
call this one sensitivity
and now uh this is going to be of type
float obviously
and let's make this one private and
let's create a method to get the
sensitivity
now this player controller is going to
be persistent even after your character
dies so that's the reason we're using it
and since we need the immediate value
this will be pure and for the return
value we are just going to return the
sensitivity
now obviously the reason we're doing it
this way is you don't want an external
entity to actually modify sensitivity
that would be crazy
and one more thing make sure you set
this value to anything other than zero
because if it's zero your mouse
obviously will not move so maybe
something like 0.5
so once that's done I should be able to
set my player controller first of all
over here in your game mode override for
your BP game mode go ahead and change
your black controller to the one you
created
save that and open up your BP character
and now
on begin play what we can do is we can
actually get our player controller so we
can type in get player controller
and we can cast this to our as you would
guess BP player controller so we are
getting our play controller and we are
checking if it is a BP player control
obviously we set it over there in the
game mode so it will be there is no
there's no way it's going to head into
cast field so we can just right click
and make this appear cast so this just
helps us save some space in the graph
this will be a success for sure and we
can go ahead and type in promote to
variable and we'll call this one pcrf
for player controller ref
now go ahead and compile that again you
can go ahead and make this one private
but honestly it doesn't matter in this
case
so on begin play we have gone ahead and
stored our player controller
and from our player controller object we
can go ahead and get the sensitivity
go ahead and get the sensitivity
go ahead and do the same thing over here
compile that
and if I go ahead and press play
you would see our sensitivity works and
not only that actually if I go ahead and
change the value so let's say I make
this point O one or rather point of 5
for example
0.01 would have been too less now as you
can see I can make very precise
movements
so now this sensitivity option
definitely works
so this is how we would actually go
about setting up sensitivity obviously
if you really didn't care you could just
have a variable here and stuff like that
doesn't really matter honestly
and there's another thing which you
could do is first on begin play itself
you could go ahead and pass your
sensitivity over here
and you could promote this to a variable
over here
and instead of calling the function
every time
and make this one private once again
instead of calling the function every
time you can go ahead and use the
sensitivity variable
so that's a little more better in terms
of performance this is something which
you could do as well
now remember we are only able to do this
because the player controller is always
created before your character spawns
let's say a player controller is not yet
created by the engine you can't actually
do this so let's say I go to my player
controller and I'm not sure if I can do
it on begin play maybe it would work on
begin play but technically if I type in
get player character
and if I type in cost to my BP character
and if I go ahead and print the string
copy that over
and I'll just type
failed for this
and doesn't matter to be honest and I'll
type in success now if I go ahead and
press play you see we get success
however this happens only because our
player controller is probably created or
rather the begin play is actually called
after the character is created as well
however now I'll just show you guys
another class now we'll discuss more in
depth about this but if I just type in
game instance I can go ahead and create
a game instance class and this is
actually referring to your whole game
application so if I type in event init
this is when your game starts this is
It's not like the begin play where you
are actually you know talking about when
this entity is created
the event in it is actually called uh
act when the game starts so that's one
difference so over here if I go ahead
and put this logic over here
and if I go ahead and go to my project
settings
and change the game instance
game instance to new blueprint we'll
delete that soon
and if I go ahead and press play you see
it says failed because our character is
not yet created so that's one thing to
note the the begin play logic only work
because our character is already created
now let's say we added a two second
delay now this is gonna work
so now if I do this it's gonna work
because our character is now
successfully created so that's basically
one thing that you guys need to
understand just make sure all your
entities are valid before you actually
set them and we can go ahead and revert
our game instance so
again we'll talk about all of this more
in depth this is not something which you
would really worry about at a beginner
level
now save everything and that should be
good to go
to go a little more in depth on the part
where you know you'd actually check if
this object is created so in our case I
mean everything just worked out smoothly
but what if it didn't what if this
wasn't valid yet because as I told you
guys the default value is none what if
this wasn't valid well there is a fix
for that as well there is actually a
function called is valid so if I go
ahead and type in is valid there's
actually a macro which is created for us
so what we can do is we can go ahead and
actually do this
so if we we can convert this to a normal
MPR cast
so on begin play we can go ahead and do
this
we can check if it is valid and if it is
not valid we would not want to do
anything but I mean if it is valid we
want to set the reference obviously but
if it is not valid we want to again
check after a while and if it is valid
obviously uh after setting the reference
you would want to go ahead and set the
sensitivity and do the regular stuff
foreign
now
how do we actually check once again so
for this you would use a technique known
as polling so polling is where you
repeatedly call a certain function until
a certain condition is met and you
actually get your desired result
so the way you can do this is by using a
timer and that takes us to the next
important concept
now if I right click and type in set
timer you would see you you'd get a few
nodes over here
however the only one which you'll use is
set timer by function name
set timer by event is kinda pointless in
my opinion because even if you do use
this you can actually refer to an event
by the function name itself so most of
the times you would be using set timer
by function name
so you set timer by function name now it
returns as a timer handle which allows
us to control this timer
and what this basically means is it is
going to call the function with a given
name so we can right click on this and
type in collapse to function and let's
call this one for example get references
or let's call this one initialize
and we don't really need this in the
event graph
and over here we can copy over this name
so what we are basically saying is after
certain time call this function once
again so we can have a very small time
such as 0.01 seconds and make this one
looping because if you just uh set this
to point on without the looping it's
just going to execute it once
and we can go ahead and store the handle
of the timer so we can call this one
initialization timer
and once we have that
this timer is now set and we could just
comment it out and call this one polling
for references
again you could name it a little more
descriptively you could give it a color
as well that's one cool feature in
unreal honestly you'd never use it but
yeah I just showed it and under
initialize
we need to stop the timer once we
actually finish everything so once we
finish setting the sensitivity there's
no reason for this function to run again
so we can go ahead and get our timer
handle first of all
and if you just type in clear you'd get
an option called clear and invalidate
timer by handle go ahead and call that
this is how you stop the timer
copy this and if it is not valid we
don't really want to do anything and if
the cast failed again we don't really
want to do anything
so again yeah this cast is bound to fail
actually this check is kind of useless
in this case
so we can just go ahead and do this
because if we don't have a player
controller this cast will obviously fail
but anyways I'll just keep it like this
and now if I go ahead and run this what
will actually happen is every 0.01
seconds it is going to repeatedly call
the function until we have cleared it so
once we get all the references we go
ahead and clear the function I mean
clear the timer there are some key
differences though between doing this
and using a delay obviously you could
have done this as well so you could have
done delay
and let's say we give 0.01 once again
and over here we can go ahead and call
initialize and we can go ahead and loop
this obviously we can call this first so
initialize then after 0.01 seconds we
could do this and maybe we could check
if we have all the references we could
maybe return a Boolean over here or
something and do something like that the
difference between a delay and a timer
is that a timer is going to be very very
precise it is going to be precise
usually up to micro or even nanoseconds
if you have a precise timer this one I
believe is precise up to a couple
hundred microseconds so as far as my
testing is concerned you could use
Chrono in C plus plus and actually test
it so this is going to be accurate
however a delay is going to be very very
inaccurate so that's one thing to note
if you want something to time accurately
you would use a timer or in our case we
needed the looping functionality so
that's the reason we use the timer
[Music]
since we have built a fundamental idea
on how inputs work now we can go ahead
and check the other type of input that
is input action mapping now before that
let's actually just clean this up a
little bit so just comment it out and
type in movement
movement and maybe you could type in
movement and Camera maybe so movement
and Camera
so now we can just group this
now head back into your project settings
and under input again
if you look at action mappings you can
go ahead and add one and we can call
this one interact
and we could set that to the F key
now the advantage of using it through
the project settings like this rather
than brute forcing so you could do F
over here as well so if I just type in F
and give a space and type in keyboard I
can actually do this but this is not the
proper way to do it because this uh
these action mappings can be actually
changed through your in-game settings
menus so you can actually create a menu
inside the game and allow the user to
change or allow the player to change
these key bindings
so we'll call the call this one interact
now so action event interact and this
gives us a pretty basic pressed and
released option so when we actually
press it
so we want to be able to pick up an
actor now how are we going to actually
set this up
so first things first
remember we had our actor begin overlap
instead of doing it here it's always
advisable we do it from the character
so do your actor begin overlap here
actor begin overlap
once you call the actor uh begin overlap
or here for the other actor instead of
casting to a character since we are the
character ourselves here because we are
inside the character class right now we
can cast to the pickup instead
now that we have casted to BP pickup we
are checking if this is actually a
pickup now there is a better way to do
it using interfaces but that is a much
higher level concept than casting but I
will definitely get to that a little
later in this course so we'll probably
change this to use an interface even
that is casting at the very fundamental
level but that's a more elegant solution
to do things
now if this is actually a pickup we can
go ahead and actually store it so
promote to variable
and let's just say let's just call this
one nearby pickup
nearby pickup
and what we can do is on our actor end
all app so end overlap
over here we can go ahead and again cast
it first things first and if it is we
can check if it is equal to the nearby
pickup
and if it is equal to the nearby pickup
and we have left its bounds we can go
ahead and remove it
and invalidate the reference so we can
all drag it and we can set it to be
equal to none that is going to
invalidate a reference
so that's about it
now once we have our reference what we
can do is we can head in our interact
function check if this is valid one more
way you can do it is by right clicking
and converting this to a validated git
so if our pickup is valid which means we
are near a pickup so what we can do is
we can actually call a function for now
let's just print out a string let's say
so or rather we can just destroy it so
type in Destroy and you will get destroy
actor
if I go ahead and press play
and if I go close to it and if I hit
interact you see I destroy the pickup
and if I do that once again that is not
gonna work
the reason is once our pickup is
destroyed it's no longer valid so what
we have to do basically is check once
again if we have any pickups nearby
so that's actually really easy to do so
once we destroy it we know that our
nearby pickup isn't actually valid
so we can go ahead and set our nearby
pickup to the nearest one now how do you
check that again using a function so we
want to see if we are overlapping so
type in overlapping
and you already see
you actually get
options for get overlapping actors which
is exactly what we need and for the
class filter it's obviously going to be
BP pickup
and over here we get an array of actor
references
instead of getting all of them we can
just get the first one this is an array
so obviously we have to get the first
index of the array
so once we get that we can go ahead and
cast this to BP pickup once again
and it is going to be successful all the
time so we can just make this a pure
cast
because we are actually using the class
filter here
and then we can go ahead and set the
nearby pickup
so now our logic should work
for both the pickup so if I hit f one of
the pickups got destroyed
so I shouldn't have moved back actually
so if I press f one got destroyed if I
press F again the other one got
destroyed as well and there are no
errors
so this is basically how you do
something like a pickup now obviously
before you destroy it let's say you had
some properties let's say for example
let's say this was a health portion or
something which gave your player a
couple of Health points
so we can add in
I don't know let's say health points
obviously you will have a better
inheritance hierarchy and we will get
into that
so Health points make this a float let's
say we have 10
so what we can do is for now we can just
go ahead and print it so we can grab
this
Health points and we can just print it
out
so move all of this logic a bit over
there to make space
we can just print that before destroying
it make sure you call Print before
destroy otherwise you're going to get a
log error
now if I go nearby if I press f we are
going to get 10 printed every time
so that's basically how you do it
[Music]
however
let's say you wanted to change some of
these properties
depending on which pickup it is
now apart from having these as a
variable
you can go ahead and check these two
options called instance editable and
expose on spawn
what these will do is allow us to edit
these properties when we actually spawn
it so let's say we spawn a pickup for
example
so over here
let's say I do spawn actor
let's have a spawn a pickup
you see we actually get an option to
change our health points so we could do
something like 90 for example and for
the spawn transform we can just uh get a
random location let's say uh let me just
add in
something for us to recognize so
something which you would use for such a
case is called a Target point
so I can use a Target point so this will
represent a target a point in space you
can copy this over and we can go ahead
and paste it in or okay maybe we can't
do that here you can do it in the
details panel so one one five zero
uh negative whatever this value is
and 650.
so 650.
and we have health points set to 90 over
there now as you would see we actually
spawn another pickup now if I go ahead
and pick these up you get 10 but when I
go near this I get 90.
however it need not be restricted to
spawning it through the blueprint you
can actually edit Expos on spawn
variables right here as well so even
when you're placing them in the level
you could have this to be 20 for example
so if I go nearby
you would see 10
20 and this one is obviously going to be
90. so stuff like that which you can do
using expose on spawn you can expose any
variable on spawn and they will be
passed right into the actor and the
value which you pass in would be set to
that variable
and now we can go ahead and remove this
logic that was just for showcasing
purposes
and we can go ahead and collapse system
function and call this one whoops call
this one pickup
and along with this maybe we could also
have something like door open or
something let's say this is not valid we
could go ahead and perform door open or
something like that we could go to the
return node and we could have a sequence
node here
so first we would check for a pickup
and we could also do something like a
door open or maybe anything else
probably maybe if you had some sort of
an interaction system with a player or
something so you could interact with the
other player stuff like that which you
can do using these input bindings and
using the overlap events
foreign
events now I will show you guys how to
do it the better way with interfaces
later but this is the Brute Force way
and if you have maybe one two or maybe
three or not more than four interactions
you could use this method itself the one
which we did with casting so this is
totally okay for small things
now let's actually do it so right click
create a new actor and let's call this
one interaction actor
maybe we could just uh nudge it or
something so
let's say we have we have another static
mesh make that the root component and we
need some sort of bound so sphere
Collision Maybe
and for the mesh let's just take a cone
for example and also I've gone ahead and
deleted the code which we had inside BP
pickup since we are not using it
and over here go ahead and simulate
physics make sure you don't forget that
and we can go ahead and okay maybe we
can have a smaller one for example
so I'm not really sure I'm just looking
for
any mesh that's available to us because
we haven't imported ours
okay this is way too big
okay this sphere seems like a reasonable
size we can go ahead and increase our
bounds
that's about it
and once again over here we can head
into our BP character
and what we can do is we can copy our
the same logic
so instead of nearby pickup we are going
to have something else so if this cast
fails so if
whatever we are nearby is not a pickup
we can check if this is actually an
interaction actor so we can do cast to
interaction actor
and again other actor is what we are
checking if it is the interaction actor
we can go ahead and promote this to
variable and call this one interaction
actor again I prefer going with Pascal
case
all right now when we actually
go away from it we can again do the same
cast so we can copy this over
we can paste it
and for this actor if it is equal to the
interaction actor which we were nearby
so copy this over
grab in the interaction actor if it was
in fact the interaction actor then we
can go ahead and invalidate it
and set that to be equal to none
so that should be about it now over here
in the interaction logic we can go ahead
and check if this is valid right click
convert to validated get so if we are
near an interaction actor uh what we can
do is we can instead of destroying let's
actually add impulse so add impulse
so add impulse
so ins so we want to add impulse to the
root component here which is simulating
physics
basically these are the physics
functions you have impulse Force dark
and all sorts of stuff obviously you
could spend some time and study those
but we'll not get into that so we have a
sphere here so
static mesh is the root component so we
need to get the static mesh
if I go ahead and scroll all the way
down I should see get static mesh now
this variable refers to the component
even components are objects so you can
just get them as variables
and for the impulse what we can do is we
can go ahead and get the forward
direction of a character get forward
vector
now you could change it according to
y'all this is logic based so it's
nothing much really and you can multiply
this by a certain value so you can make
this one a float
and change this to a float
make this let's say something like 10
000 something big Maybe
get active forward Vector multiply that
by ten thousand
and that should be good to go
now we can collapse this to a function
and we can call this one nudge ball or
something because the sphere looks like
a ball so
nudge ball Maybe
and if I go ahead and press play okay we
have a compilation error so we can check
what's that
so it says
let's read the arrow first of all okay
it was just uh it just compiled it in
the wrong order it compiled character
before this so it didn't know what
static mesh was now we should be able to
go ahead and play this and first of all
we don't have an interaction actor let's
actually create one go ahead and press
play
now if I go ahead and bump into this
oops I shouldn't have bumped into that
if I press F on my keyboard when I'm
overlapping it
uh the bounce is a little too small let
me just increase that
so increase the radius don't scale it up
and one more thing if you want to see
the bounds just for testing purposes you
can set this flag called hidden in game
to false so now it is going to be
visible in the game as well
so if I look around yeah there we have
it so we can enter our bounds and now if
I press F on the keyboard you see we
actually not jit
so the force is way too small so I can
go ahead and make this something like 50
000 let's say
so if I go ahead and press F over here
you see we are actually not doing it
so this is the way you would set up
interaction using casting obviously you
can use interfaces to simplify things a
little bit
but yeah this is the basic idea
[Music]
all right so in order to understand
whatever I just told now in case it went
above your head please do Tinker around
and try some of the functions yourself
using the context sensitive and the and
the search bar basically so when you
right click and let's say you drag
something off of this you can go ahead
and type any random function so for
example if I just press a you get a
bunch of functions maybe you could have
a look at all of these maybe have a look
at documentation and maybe try out some
of your own logic
and try out something else maybe add in
another actor to do something else with
maybe add in a door and make it open or
something so you guys should be able to
try it out yourself and once you are
actually done with that now we can go
ahead and talk about the next part now
until now we talked about the basics and
I'm pretty sure you can write some basic
game logic with whatever we have done
already but there are a couple of
functions which the engine provides us
which is going to make our job a lot
easier
the first one and one of the most
commonly used ones which I would like to
talk about is Ray casting now if you
guys are familiar with other engines you
guys would know what a raycast is
but in Unreal Engine you call it a line
dress so if I right click and call line
Trace so you see you get a bunch of
options the one you'll use most of the
time is line Trace by Channel multi is
basically used when you have penetration
and stuff when you are detecting
multiple hits in the same line I'll I'll
tell you guys what's line Trace first
so line Trace is basically a function
which lets us draw a line from a given
starting point to a given ending point
and in between these two points if you
are actually hitting anything you are
going to get it as a hit result
so I can get access to the hit location
and in case you want to see the line
itself you can change this draw debug
type enum and make this for duration and
if you guys wondered this is an
enumeration that's the reason we are
getting these options so none for one
frame for duration and persistent are
the enumerators so if we select for
duration we are going to get the line
for some time persistent means the line
is going to be shown to us forever until
you close the game of course
so let's actually do something with this
so let's actually set up an input event
let's say when we click our left Mouse
button so we can type in left Mouse
now I'm just setting this up brood Force
because I don't really know what exactly
we are going to set up once we actually
get to the examples we'll do that
now for the start location
you can choose the camera's location of
the player because this is where you
would be seeing stuff so you can select
the camera's location for example
so if I go ahead and get the start
location the way you do that is there
are a couple of ways
you could do this and you could do get
location
so you can get get World location and
you could use this as a starting point
and the way you would go forward towards
the center of your screen is going to be
first of all by getting the forward
vector
so you can get the forward Vector of
this camera
and multiply this by a certain value
Again by a float
uh we'll do that add that to the
starting location so starting location
plus forward Vector into a certain
number of a certain number that is going
to be your end and we can go ahead and
change this to a float
and we can do let's say 50 000. I mean
the number is arbitrary obviously unreal
uses centimeters remember that
so anything that you type in will be in
centimeters so 50 000 centimeters is
going to be divided by 100 so it's going
to be like 500 meters
now if I go ahead and Press Play If I
press my left Mouse button you see you
get a line drawn over there so if I
press f8
you see I can actually see the line
which was drawn so the red thing which
you see that is the line which was drawn
and as you can see
uh where where it hit the surface it
actually registered a hit
and in order to show that there is one
more thing which you can do actually Oh
and about the other options Trace
channel is something we'll talk about
later but basically you can do stuff
like ignoring several uh types of
objects so let's say you had a shooter
game and let's say you wanted to like
ignore teammates you could use it for
that but you'd use tags for that as well
but there are several other use cases
camera is another thing depending on
what type of objects you want to you
want the hit to detect you would do that
and actually if you were to notice if I
select my mesh and if I scroll down to
the Collision part
so I'll just type in Collision instead
of searching for it like this so
Collision
you have to notice it says character
mesh for the preset and over here if you
see there is actually visibility and
camera so what you can do is you can
actually make it block certain things so
now let's say I wanted this line Trace
which is using visibility right now to
block it I would have to change this to
custom and make this one block
visibility so then I would be able to
I would be able to make this line block
it
stuff like that which you could do now
obviously I'll change it back to
character mesh we didn't do anything but
still
so over here change it back to character
mesh
and let's say you wanted to ignore the
camera Channel you could do that as well
now let's say you wanted to just Mark
the place where you actually hit so now
we have access to the hit location so
there is a function called Draw debug
sphere
you can actually draw many other shapes
but sphere is the one which you'll use
most often
and the center is obviously the place
where you hit it so out hit location
and radius 100 maybe we can have 10
seconds for the duration and thickness
let's just say two units line color
let's set that to maybe something like a
greenish yellow or something
now if I go ahead and Press Play If I
left click you see it's drawing a sphere
where it actually hit it
and you could change some of the
properties let's say you wanted a more
details here I don't know why you would
want that though and maybe reduce the
radius of the sphere you could do that
as well
so as you can see we are registering a
hit over there so that's what it's
basically showing us
so this is how you do a line Trace
basically you draw a line from one end
to the other and you can detect hits
obviously for shooting a weapon and
stuff like that you use it now there is
another way you can actually determine
the start and end location now whatever
logic you have here is fine if you only
have one camera but what if you had a
first person view and a third person
view for example let's say you had two
cameras
you cannot check which camera you are
using and stuff that would make the
logic complicated so the way you do it
is you would use a function called get
player camera manager
now this is going to get the current
camera which you're using and it's going
to be an actor so we can just type in
get actor location
and this is going to be your camera's
location so let's say you switch between
cameras this is going to work
universally regardless of which camera
you're using however since in this logic
we are using this camera's reference
let's say we had another camera this
logic is not going to work it is going
to work with respect to this camera
so instead of this I can go ahead and
replace it
and we can get the actor for Vector
again
get actor forward vector
and we can replace this by this
and we can go ahead and delete it and
the rest of the logic Remains the Same
obviously and now if I were to press
play you would see that the logic does
not work okay we didn't plug it in so
the actor location is going to be the
start of course not zero
press play and the logic works exactly
the same one more thing you'll notice is
that the line Trace is going exactly to
the center of our screen if you were to
notice
that's one more thing the reason it's
happening like that is because we are
going from the center of our Viewpoint
and going exactly forward to the view so
that's the reason it's actually going
right at the center of the screen and if
you add a Crosshair in game it would
land right at the center
so this was recasting there are many
other options as well such as hit actor
so you can cast it so let's say we cast
it to pick up for example so we can
check if we actually hit the pickup so
if we actually did hit a pickup what we
can do in fact is we can go ahead and
run some logic let's say we destroy it
so I'm just showing you guys one more
example to make things clear
so if I press play
so that's not the pickup so nothing
happened but if I hit a pickup as you
can see we are destroying it so
something like a gun
[Music]
all this is fine but we do not have any
sort of a user interface now apart from
the lighting needs to be rebuilt then
you can actually delete that by typing
in disable all screen messages
so oops I didn't type that so disable
all screen messages
so you can go ahead and type that and
it's going to remove that
so there's nothing much really we don't
even have a simple health bar so we can
go ahead and add a couple of components
on screen
so in order to create widgets on the
screen if you want user interfaces the
way you do that is using widget
blueprints so let's get to that inside
your content folder I want you guys to
create a new folder and we can call this
one UI
and inside this we can call this one for
example HUD to denote heads up display
now open it up and inside this folder
right click and create a widget
blueprint by heading into user interface
now you could do it through the
blueprint class menu as well type in
widget blueprint you should you should
find a widget blueprint somewhere over
here so user widget is the one actually
so go ahead and select that and we can
call this one HUD
BP underscore HUD generally I also like
to add underscore WB to represent widget
blueprint but if we are going to have
separate folders for each one it's not
really required
open it up and you will get a blank
canvas
and you'll have two tabs over here on
the top you have a designer and a graph
as well
so what we'll be using most of the time
is the designer and to add the logic for
it we are going to use the graph if you
guys have used the QT framework in C
plus plus the functions and stuff work
pretty similarly over here but since
this is going to be in Blueprint it's
going to be much much easier to
comprehend
now the most basic type of widget that
you can add is a canvas panel so add in
a canvas panel before this actually used
to come by default without you having to
actually add it now you won't worry
about most of the settings actually the
only thing that you'll worry about is
custom or fill screen actually these are
the only two which you'll most probably
use custom is basically used if you have
stuff like drop down and you're making
like a child widget for something
and I will show you guys examples for
that when we go to the higher level part
so for now we'll use fill screen so this
is going to take up the entire screen
now in order to actually create this now
there is nothing but we we can just
create it nonetheless
generally it's not advisable to create
it in in the character widgets usually
would be created in something a little
more persistent such as a player
controller so we have one setup already
so we make sure you set that in the game
mode open it up and we could do it on
begin play
add in a custom event and this is where
you actually use custom events so you
could use a function no harm with that
but let's use custom events this is what
you would use them for
so we are going to be calling this one
for example create HUD
and we can call that so create HUD
over here we can go ahead and type in
create widget
we'll get to select it so BP HUD does
what we want to create and we can
promote this to a variable and call this
one HUD
or you could call it hardref if you
really want to be that specific
now we have a reference to the HUD
however we still haven't actually
created it we have just internally
stored it but if you want to show it on
the screen type in add to viewport
so now this should be added to your
screen
however there is there is another thing
which you could do actually there is
another option called add to player
screen
however this is not really used that
much so this is usually used for split
screen and stuff like that will not get
into this so you'll use add to viewport
most of the times
all right so now under your HUD
for the health bar obviously we need a
progress bar so type in progress bar and
unreal has everything built in for us so
let's add it at the bottom left hand
side of the screen that's the reason I
chose the canvas panel
so that we can easily uh just drag stuff
in with other types of widget it's
usually like a layout which you create
so it's going to be harder for you to
just move things around
all right so let's add the progress bar
and on the right hand side under the
details panel we can rename it we can
call this one health bar
and we can set all sorts of parameters
maybe we can make this one 350 by 45
and over here you'll see another tab
called anchors now anchor is basically
telling you the position with respect to
it basically for example let's say set
it to bottom left in this case bottom
left is ideal
so this is going to be your 0 comma 0
and with respect to that your Y and your
other values are going to be set so when
I say the anchor is at the bottom left
and my position is 88 what I mean is I
have placed this progress bar 88 units
to the right of this anchor
and Y is basically your vertical
Direction so minus 120 is 120 units
upwards basically
and size X and size y will remain the
same
alignment is basically telling you what
to take as this the reference point so
if I make this 0.5
you see it's going to Center off so it's
the distance between this and the center
now
same with the Y so if I type in 0.5 it
will move a little bit down or up
actually because it was over here so now
the point shifted over there so it moved
a bit up and if you want to Center
something exactly at the center of the
screen so for example across here so you
would set the anchor to be this the
center one
and over here you will change the
alignment to 0.5 and set the position to
0 and 0. now this is going to be
perfectly centered regardless of your
resolution
now another reason to actually use this
so let me just actually move this back
so zero zero
another reason to use anchors is for
different resolutions let's say you had
an 800 by 600 screen let's say somebody
is playing with that and you had a
progress bar over here
let's say you left it at the default
anchor let's say you didn't actually
modify the anchors this widget is
actually going to go outside the player
screen
however if you change the anchor to the
bottom right now this widget is
minus 461 and minus 137 relative to the
bottom right corner so then it will
always be inside the screen so that's
another reason to use anchor so I'll go
ahead and undo all of that
so that should be good now if I go ahead
and create this so in apply controller
on begin play we are actually creating
it now if I go ahead and press play you
see we see our progress bar and since we
have our anchor over here you see it
always stays at the same relative
position on the screen
the next thing that you obviously want
to do is actually bring in the values of
Health from the character to the actual
widget so it's actually pretty simple to
do that so let's go step by step there
are quite a few ways you in which you
can do it so if you would have created
the widget on the character it would
have been simple to just pass in the
health value to the widget however since
we have done it in the player control
there is an extra step but nothing to be
worried about
so now let's create an event in the
player controller so that we can
actually interact with the widget
so we can call this one update health
for example so type in custom event and
call this one update help
and for the new value we can go ahead
and add in an input and it's going to be
of type float obviously and we'll call
this one new health
now over here in the progress bar we can
go ahead and create another event or we
could even directly adjust it here so we
could get the HUD
and over here we could type in first of
all let's check if our progress bar is a
variable make sure it's set to is
variable otherwise you won't be able to
access it
so if once that is variable get the
health bar
and again this is where your blue print
menu is going to help you a lot now you
want to set the percentage so type in
set percent
you will go ahead and get this node now
in case you guys don't know this percent
is going to be a value between 0 and 1
and our health is a value between 0 and
100 so let's just divide this by 100.
so do that or you could make your health
variables store 0 to 1 that works too
all right so you can do that or you
could have a custom event inside your BP
HUD that works too
so let's head back into a character now
and what we can do is we can actually do
something so let's say when we actually
pick something up let's say we reduce
our health for example so we can head
into our interaction so when we pick it
up let's say we reduce our health by 10
maybe
now if it is valid we destroy it and we
invalidate the nearby pickup and let's
reduce our health by 10. so create a
health variable first of all now health
is a variable which is dependent on
which character you are in so that's why
we are creating it in the character make
this private
over here
make this variable private
and we can go ahead and set the health
to be equal to whoops
we can go ahead and set the health to be
equal to health
minus
10.
and we don't want it to actually go
below zero so we can go ahead and clamp
the value so we can call this one clamp
so clamp float minimum is 0 maximum is
100 obviously
so I can go ahead and set it now if our
health is zero so if our health is less
than or equal to 0 if you don't clamp it
you can check for less than or equal to
so let's do that actually
so if our health is less than or equal
to 0
whoops less than or equal to zero
we can go ahead and just kill our player
so instead of killing it let's just exit
the game instead so we can call
we can execute a console command so type
in execute console command
and this one will simply type in exit
it's going to exit the game even quit
works
now this is something which you might
need multiple times
so what we can do instead of this is we
can actually make a set Health function
because we want to exit the game even if
our health is reduced for some other
reason
so here in this case we picked it up so
our health reduced but we want to be
able to reuse this so right click
collapse the store function and call
this one set health
now let's say you don't want this to be
able to call it on the other blueprints
so let's say you want to only be able to
call it in this BP character you can
make it a macro instead and obviously we
need the health value so grab in health
and head back into your event graph pick
up over here we can go ahead and pass in
the health so this is going to handle
everything for us and let's actually
make this a larger value let's say 40.
so on our third pickup in theory we
should exit our game
and if it is not less than or equal to
zero uh we can go ahead and update the
progress bar first things first and
remember we had our play controller
reference now we can go ahead and use
that
so regardless of what we do we want to
update the helper I mean we'll exit over
here so we don't need to update it so we
can type in update health
and new health is going to be our health
variable
now some people might show you how to do
this using a binding so you can actually
go into your progress bar and you can
type in bind and create a binding
however this is very very inefficient
and it is going to run on tick so
actually don't really bother using that
do it the way I am showing you guys this
is the proper way to do it however there
is a good there is a small chance that
it might miss it might not update but
that's nothing to worry about it's going
to be like one in a million maybe so it
honestly doesn't matter
so once that said we should be good to
go and make sure by default your health
is set to 100
and once just update the progress bar
once you set the player controller
reference because we are not actually
setting the health by default
uh in the heart you could set it however
what if a player disconnected from a
match and is coming back so you don't
want it to be 100 because you'll be
creating the widget once again right so
set it once you get the player
controller so in our initialize function
once we get the play controller
reference we can go ahead and set that
and we'll clear the timer at the last
order doesn't matter here since this
function is already being executed the
order honestly doesn't matter but we can
do it like this
now if I go ahead and press play you'd
see our health is set to 100
and if I go closer okay let me just
speed that up a bit
so if I interact with this nothing
happens but if I go ahead and interact
with this our health reduces my health
reduced and now we exit the game the
third time we do that
so this is basically how you work with
widgets so if you want to update it you
would just use one of the functions
which are there in one of these widgets
and what if you wanted text obviously
you just search accordingly type in text
and you should be able to find text
so let's actually type in the actual
health value
so over here
what we can do is we can just give 100
by default or we could leave it a text
block and set it normally so over here
get back into your play controller
and in your update Health function we
can go ahead and grab our text I don't
know if it's set variable so it is not
set to be variable so we can type this
one Health text
now you should be able to access health
text from the player controller once you
set that to its variable
so grab in our HUD
Health text so get your health text
and over here we can go ahead and set
the text
to be equal to the health value itself
now there is a special node which you'll
use a lot called format text
so this is very simple actually use
curly braces
and type in health
it will make a pin for you whatever you
type in curly braces will be a pin
and the first one let's just put a plus
over there because it's usually usually
health is denoted with a plus before
so your current so your text is
basically going to be plus along with a
health appended with your health so let
me just show that actually so grab in
your new health
you can grab in any sort of pin by the
way
now if I go ahead and press play you see
it says plus hundred because it took
plus and the actual health value itself
now I apologize I do realize that the
screen is a little bit black and white
so now it should be fine
so you have plus and you have your
health
similarly you could you could do
something like maybe hyphens
so it's just going to append it as is
you can go ahead and mess around with it
a little bit let's say you wanted
another parameter you could put curly
braces once again and type this one
maybe
something
and over here you can go ahead and make
make a little a little string or a text
so
let's just say hi for example so it's
going to print
plus 100 space High
if I put a hyphen here it's going to
take it as is so plus 100 hyphen height
so stuff like that which you can do
using this format text node and it's
really handy in my opinion
so now if I go ahead and press play we
have our health bar
now we could do a little more of
Designing so head back into your HUD
and you can actually wrap this around
with a border if you right click and
type in wrap with
you can wrap it with a border and
actually have a border color and stuff
so I can select this and make sure you
set your padding to whatever you want
padding is basically the spacing you
give
so if I change the padding in this case
so if I change this to 10 you'd see that
you're giving more space on all
directions I'll just set it to something
like 5 Maybe
and I'll make this one black so not
content color that's going to be a
progress Parts color instead go to brush
color and change that to something dark
Maybe
and over here as well let's just change
the fill color to Green because that's
more appropriate for your health widget
so change that to something a bit more
greener
now if I go ahead and press play you'll
be able to see we get the appropriate
color and our health bar updates as
normal under text updates as well
so that's basically it so that's the
basics of widget blueprints we will talk
a lot more in depth about this as we
move further but now you guys should
have a pretty basic idea on how to
create stuff now the palette is
something which I want you guys to
explore so check boxes a checkbox and
you won't use most of these most often
you'll use text slider button image
border and images as it says it's an
image and one more which you might use
if you want something like a username
password menu is a text box
so you can grab in a text box and this
will allow the user to enter any text
inside
stuff like that
now
I want to cover widgets in a little more
detail
so let's actually
create another level called main menu
and let's accelerate transition to this
level using a widget so like you click
the play button in your widget and then
you would enter this level let's do that
now
first we can go ahead and create our map
so heading to content maps right click
create a new level and we can call this
one main menu
open it up or rather let's just be a
little more descriptive call this one
main menu level open it up and this
should be blank and that's really none
of our concern head into UI create a new
folder and we'll call this one main menu
over here go to user interface widget
blueprint and go ahead and select user
widget
now we can start making our main menu so
we can call this one BP underscore main
menu
open the widget
and we can just have a canvas panel
again
add in a button
we can Center it first of all
so make it 0.5 and 0.5
and set the positions to be zero
we can increase the size a little bit
maybe we could make that something like
350 by 100 Maybe
maybe 450 again size is your personal
preference
and we can make the background black so
background color change that to
something darker
maybe something like a dark gray
we can go in and add in some text and we
can call this one play
now you can change the font as well by
the way under font
uh you can actually import your own
custom fonts will not get into that but
it's actually pretty simple to do it
we'll try to get into that in the later
part of the course but I'm not really
sure if I will so maybe change that to
regular increase the font size to 35
let's say this should be good
now head into your event graph and let's
call this one play button
so select the button and then under the
details panel rename that
now if you select the play button
variable you should get a bunch of
events including on clicked on pressed
on release all of these are as they
stand obviously maybe if you have a
sound effect or something you could play
it on on hovered or there's another way
actually where you can play sound effect
when you hover your mouse so over here
if I just type in Hover
I should be able to find Howard sound
let's just play uh
so
maybe let's just play this I mean it
doesn't make any sense but anyways
and
I think there is a clicked sound or a
pla press sound I guess it's called
so we can play press sound so
click on button
and what we can do is on click we can go
ahead and open our map so we can type in
open level
and we can do by object reference
so over here let's just select our level
beginner course level and that should be
good now if I go ahead and press play
as you see nothing happens because we
haven't created the widget yet now since
this is a widget which is the only thing
in this level you could simply go ahead
and create the widget here on begin play
so create widget
create widget
BP main menu add to viewport we don't
really need to store it because we are
not actually calling any functions
so if I press play you can see it and
when we hover over it you see you get
the sound effect
however one thing you would notice is if
you actually have your focus on the
window
you can't see a mouse cursor so the way
you do that is first of all get your
player controller so type in get player
controller this is a static function
so in inside any actor basically you can
get your player controller reference
and from here there's actually a
variable called set show mouse cursor so
show mouse cursor is the variable
set that to true and another thing which
you can do actually is change the input
mode to UI only so that it only focuses
on this widget there is another option
called game and UI only we'll use that
set input mode to game and UI only
grab in the player controller reference
and that should be good so we can just
reroute it double click on the PIN to
reroute it
and now if I go ahead and press play
you see even when I focus it I can still
see my mouse cursor now if I press play
you see we transition to the level now
we obviously spawned at 0 comma zero
comma zero so that's the reason that
happened
now if you want to fix that you can go
ahead and add in a player start where
your default player will spawn so now if
I head back into the main menu play it
if I head in we will spawn where our
player start was but one thing you'll
notice is uh we still haven't actually
got rid of the mouse focusing part so
your mouse isn't behaving like how it
should
so what we can do is on begin play now
we are in a main menu level
head into our beginner course level
generally you do it on your player
controller so BP black controller and
what you can do is you can set input
mode
game only
and we can get a reference to self
and you can also set show mouse cursor
to false so set show mouse cursor make
that false
now if I go ahead and press play okay I
mean that wasn't what I intended
now
head back into your main menu
go ahead and press play now you see your
mouse is going to behave normally
so that's basically how you deal with it
now you can do your normal gameplay
stuff so that's how you would actually
create
you would actually interact with your
actual levels and stuff your transition
levels and stuff using widget blueprints
so head back into UI main menu and if we
take a look at our code it's really
simple and a widget as well it's really
simple
so that's about it now let's say we
wanted to have more than one option
and let's say we wanted to layer them
vertically so if you want to add
multiple rows you can go ahead and use
something known as a vertical box so if
I right click on this type in wrap width
and use a vertical box
you can go ahead and get this now the
vertical box will automatically use the
same anchor as we used for the child
but nonetheless just something which you
can change
the size y to something big Maybe
and press Ctrl D to duplicate this
button
now over here I can type in exit let's
say
and again on clicked we can change that
so play button one is not appropriate
we'll change that to exit button
so exit button
and on clicked we can go ahead and
execute console command and we can type
in exit
so that should be good to go and you'll
notice one thing it's just taking up a
fixed amount of space and it's not
actually filling it properly so if you
want to do that you can select both of
these and select fill
now let's say you wanted your play
button to occupy more amount of space
than exit so you can increase this uh
what a text box which is available to
you so if I hit 2
and the exit button has one on this
option basically they are occupying
space in the ratio two is to one that's
basically what it means so you don't
want your place to exit obviously so
you'd make the play button bigger so
this is how you do it
now if I press play
now the same logic is copied over the
reason why the sound is playing even for
the exit button is because we copied
over the code so that's why so all the
sound effects as well is copied so as
you can see press sound and hover sound
are actually the same in both of these
now if I press play I press exit we are
going to quit the game if I press play
We load into this level
so that's pretty cool so that's about it
for this part
foreign
talking about another feature which
blueprint offers that is blueprint
function libraries now let's say you
wanted to have some functions which
might be used in multiple places but are
not relative to a certain object
so in that case you would use a
blueprint function Library so let me
actually show you guys an example
so head into blueprints and or maybe we
could create another folder let's call
this one function libraries
open it up and over here right click
head into Blueprints and
select blueprint function Library
and we can call this one my or our
blueprint function Library
now inside here you would notice that we
actually have functions options to write
functions
so for example let's say we have
something generic so for example let's
say
uh we have a vector and let's say we
wanted to normalize it now obviously
there is a normalized function already
but I'm just taking an example now
normalizing a vector is a general
operation it's not relative to any
object so we can type in
normalize
and for the input obviously we are going
to take in a vector so take in a vector
and we can type this one in maybe
uh now once we have the vector we are
going to first of all get the magnitude
of this Vector the way you get magnitude
of a vector in Blueprint is by typing in
Vector length so get Vector length
now this is this is the magnitude of the
vector so we can divide this vector by
the magnitude
so that is going to normalize the vector
for us
and once we actually do that we can go
ahead and return it
so this is going to be the return value
and obviously we'll make it a pure
function now
let's just call this one normalize
underscore hours because I I think there
is another function called normalize so
just so that it's understandable for us
now head back into any one of your
blueprints let's say our level blueprint
and over here if we just type in
normalize
so we already had a normalized function
but I just took the example underscore
RS you see we actually get our function
and this is not relative to any object
so you can call this pretty much
Everywhere You Wish so this is basically
our blueprint function Library you just
go on creating functions
[Music]
so once that's all settled now what if
you wanted to use some code or some
assets created by somebody else there is
actually a huge Marketplace called the
unreal Marketplace and you can access it
through the epic games launcher so if I
head into my epic games launcher head
into Marketplace under the Unreal Engine
section you would see that you get a
massive library of assets and there are
a bunch of free ones as well like I I
really mean a lot of free assets
so what if you wanted to use them so
that is where using plugins and other
content packs comes in handy so how you
do it is really simple actually so for
example I know one which is very handy
it's called low entry I believe
oops low entry
so I actually have it in my library so
so it's by this publisher actually
so low entry low entry standard Library
this is the one which I'm using this is
really useful so once you search it up
and you can look it up in the
marketplace and there are many Forums on
Reddit and stuff talking about which
plugins are good and stuff so you can go
ahead and install it according to your
needs so let's say I wanted some weapon
models for prototyping you could just
type in weapon and you're going to get
weapon packs the way you install it is
by clicking on this install to engine
button I've already done that so that's
why it shows that I can't
now over here in my plugins panel now I
should be able to access it over here
under installed or if you just search it
up you would be able to find it and you
can enable it so low entry extended
standard library and I need to restart
the editor so let me go ahead and do
that
now that it's done I can go ahead and
use the content in the plugin now how do
I know what content is there there will
actually be a documentation and source
code and stuff available so you could
just look it up so there will be a place
where the documentation is given so you
have a preview over here then you also
have access to the source code
and a bunch of stuff you could also take
a look at this over here so maybe let's
say we wanted to use uh some function
here so for example I type in is debug
build let's say I wanted to see if I am
currently in a debug build
so I can type in is debug build whoops
debug build and as you can see I can use
the function now this was a plugin which
has to be installed to the engine
however we will also look at other types
of plugins such as let's say I type in
weapon for example I needed a weapon
pack
so I actually have some in the library
you could find a free one so you can
head under free and you can look for it
but again now in my library I actually
have some weapon packs if I want to
install those it's actually really
simple so FPS weapons bundle this is one
thing which I have so I can go ahead and
add this to a project and it does say
none of my projects are compatible but
plugins like these actually it doesn't
really matter if you are using a later
version then what is supported as long
as you're using a later version than
that it should be totally good to go so
click on show all projects and you can
go ahead and select this and you can
change the version to the latest
available one and you can go ahead and
add it now just another thing in case
you don't have a plug-in of this sort so
the one which we saw last time
so let's search for low entry once again
so let's say we have a plugin of this
sort
which you install to the engine but you
actually don't have the appropriate
version
so the way would actually go about
upgrading your version is actually
really simple people haven't made any
tutorials on this I don't see any Forum
or anything talking about that either so
basically you just come into your Unreal
Engine installation directory so I go to
program files Unreal Engine this is
where I have it
and over here under engine
plugins
and the marketplace ones will be in the
marketplace
and for example I go to low entry
extended standard Library I can right
click on this U plugin file and I can
actually open it with any text editor or
I can open it with something like vs
code so I'll open it with Visual Studio
inside the U plugin file you should see
something a little like this so you
don't have to worry about any of these
things the only thing is the engine
version let's say it was there for 4.27
and you are using 5 and if you want to
make it compatible and let's say you're
getting build errors you could just go
ahead and change 4.27 to 5.0.0 so let's
say it was
4.27.0 by default so you can go ahead
and change it to 5.0.0
whoops y dot or dot O So stuff like that
[Music]
all right so that's about it there isn't
really that much depth to plugins I mean
I will talk about creating plugins and
stuff integrating third-party libraries
a bit later on in the advanced part of
this course but now let's go ahead and
actually talk about a recently release
tool and which is quite handy in my
opinion and those are the modeling tools
first of all in your plugin section make
sure your plugin is enabled so make sure
modeling tools editor mode plugin is
enabled and if you don't want to
separately drag your model in the level
and edit it then you can press this as
well
ah now if you check your content browser
uh make sure you have some sort of a 3D
model make sure you have some sort of a
static mesh
so you can import that from your 3D
software
so I just got one in from the engine
content so what I did was basically
actually I'll just go ahead and delete
that and redo it
so delete that
and delete this folder as well
save everything now I just search for SM
underscore usually it's a convention to
name it SM underscore for static mesh
under content I just went ahead and
created a new folder
so new folder and I called it models
open it up and just paste it in uh just
using the one from the engine content
now you can drag it in the level and
start editing it by heading into this
tab right here and heading into modeling
so we have a bunch of options the first
few are for creating objects but some of
the useful ones are for example moving
the pivot so let's say you didn't want
this to rotate along the center you can
go ahead and type pivot and you can move
this point over here now if I rotate it
it's going to rotate along this point
and these changes are actually applied
to this so
even if I just drag in another ball
these changes will be applied to that so
just be careful while using them of
course you can undo them at any point
so just save that and sculpt is
basically to deform the shape so
something like this
and again you can use shift the same
principle works over here as well as we
did with the landscape editing so stuff
like that then descalp does a similar
thing just works a little bit
differently so I can just drag it like
this
I'm not sure what I did there but yeah
so I'm not really here to talk about the
tools in detail but just to give you an
overview of how to actually use it so
you could experiment around with all of
these
so if you type in accept so now we have
the ship obviously this is it just
messed up with the UV map and the
materials and stuff but anyways that was
not our point
now a couple of useful things first of
all creating shapes so if I just type in
stair over here
and if I head into this and I can
actually make it a curved staircase I
can actually increase the number of
stairs I can decrease the step height so
I can increase the curve angle for
example then I can decrease the step
height so I can make it something like
maybe place that and type in complete
now if I go ahead and press play
you would be able to see that I can
actually use my stairs
so that works well
so stuff like that and now shapes are
pretty obvious obviously just create a
box do stuff with that and now you might
be wondering where these are stored over
here just check uh what is selected
under this under the new asset location
if it is selected to Global in your
content folder folder there should be a
underscore generated folder in my case
it was set to World relative so wherever
you have your map over here this you
should see a underscore generated folder
and if you open it up you should be able
to see your static meshes
so for example we have this stair which
we just created and we can drag this in
so this is going to come in really
really handy for many people in my
opinion
now not only that it provides us with
several other cool features I'll just
showcase one of them actually
so if you head into your modeling tools
once again so I'll just close it and
open it up again so I'll open up the
modeling tools and if I type in poly
extrude you can actually draw a shape so
if I just click somewhere drag a point
do something like this
and if I join them
now I would be able to create something
like this so let's say I wanted to
create a castle wall or something
you could do that and the good part
about this is this is UV map by default
you don't have to actually you remap it
the UVS are pretty good so you can
directly go ahead and apply a texture
and it is going to look decent generally
if you create a weird shape like this in
a 3D modeling software you separately
have to go through the effort of UV
mapping it so that the textures don't
look distorted but in this case you are
good to go
so that's about it for the modeling
tools so you can mess around with those
these are really you know specific to
what you're doing
so according to what you would need you
would use the appropriate tools but it
is there now even over here you can
change the Pivot Point let's say for
example so I'll just show you guys once
again so modeling
if I select pivot
and if I
move this over and press accept you
would see that the pivot point mode over
there so that's about it so let's move
on to the next part
[Music]
so what I'm going to be talking about
next is kind of the basics of what we
did till now so basically we worked with
these models over here basically these
are called Static meshes so any and all
3D models which you get in the engine
without any sort of animations or
anything those will generally be static
meshes
uh any mesh with some sort of Animation
is going to be a skeletal mesh basically
so stuff like characters gun models and
those are going to be your skeletal
meshes anything which simulate physics
or which does not have animations so for
example the staircase may be a weapon
model in a pickup blueprint stuff like
that are going to be static meshes
so they are recognized by a light blue
color in the content browser so if I
head into models you see it has a light
blue color coding and this indicates
that it's a static mesh
now we will dive into skeletal meshes a
little more in depth later on but for
now I'll just head into static meshes
there are a couple of things which I
would like to cover first one is
enabling nanite now if I head into
wireframe mode
so now I can actually see
all of the vertices in space
foreign
now say I have many of the Spheres and
in this case I have more than six
thousand so six thousand four hundred
and eighty so your first question over
here is how's the performance still this
great
that is thanks to nanite so if you right
click on your model and enable nanite
over here if you right click and click
on enable you will enable nanite now if
I go ahead and disable this you would
see that the performance dips
immediately
so that's one thing about nanite so as
you can see it's really not playable at
this point now if I mean obviously this
is highly unrealistic and moreover it
will depend more on your computer as
well so if I go ahead and enable nanite
now and if I press play as you can see
even with so many spheres right in front
of me
it's absolutely not affecting
performance now we are not here to talk
about the actual technology involved in
nanite so that's the reason I'm not
telling anything else but this is
basically it currently in 5.0.3 there
are a few limitations for example let's
say I wanted to use this on a tree you
probably cannot because trees contain
leaves and leaves used masked materials
and those are not yet supported on
nanite and it but they will be supported
in 5.1 so very very soon you would be
able to use them
so that's about it there are few
material features which you can't use
and we will talk about materials so
stuff like dithering and stuff you will
have to just disable those notes if you
want to use nanite but for most objects
or stuff like walls or maybe if you have
an insane level something like this
nanite is going to come in handy so
that's about nanite
[Music]
by now one thing that we would have
probably noticed is that any and all
objects in the scene actually have some
sort of a material on them so for
example this has some neon blue texture
on it and it seems to be glowing and
this box right here has some sort of
checkerboard and same with the ground so
what's up with that so basically those
are materials and that's what gives the
color and all the other roughness
related properties of a given surface
now let's actually go about seeing how
to create a material and apply it on
objects so let's just use a cube for
example in order to demonstrate using
materials so let me just grab in a cube
and I'll just place it in the scene
now this has a material basic shape
material you can actually explore this
by clicking on this search icon over
here
so we'll actually go to the directory
where the material is stored but in our
case let's create a new folder called
materials
and let's go ahead and open it up
right click and create a new material or
you can head into materials and create a
new material here now the most important
ones are just materials and material
instances the rest are just stuff which
you might need in specific circumstances
so we'll take a look at material and
let's call this one our material now
applying a material on a surface is
actually really simple now we aren't
going to be dealing with multiple
materials on a single object in this
part of the course we will try to deal
with it later on but for now we won't be
doing anything so by default you get
this Checker material so I'll just drag
this in
and you can in order to apply it you
just drag it basically on the surface
that's how you do it or if you want to
apply it to a static mesh in general so
let's say I wanted all of the uh okay
whatever this object is so let's say I
wanted all of this object to have our
material so what I do is I head into the
static mesh and over here I'm going to
select our material so
let me go back
so all content materials are material
you can select that and you can click on
this Arrow icon which will use our
material so now it's actually using our
material so we haven't seen any change
because
we don't have anything set up in the
material but the way you actually start
working with this is by using these
nodes so this pin right here is as the
name suggests the base color now how do
you define a base color so the most
basic node over here is going to be a
constant
so whoops I press C on the keyboard I'm
supposed to press 1 on the keyboard and
left click and you see you get this node
here which allows you to enter value now
generally you would enter a value
between 0 and 1 but in some cases you
would enter higher and lower values so
in this case if I just plug this in the
base color and you can see it's
compatible
so you would see that our material is
fully black
now
it's just a fully black material what if
I increase this a bit
now save that again as you can see it
became a lighter shade of gray
so one is going to be white so this is
basically a gradient 0 is black and one
is white
what if you wanted to give a color so
you'd hold three on your keyboard and
left click then you'd get something
known as a constant three Vector this is
basically our r g and B value so red
green and blue
so you can go ahead if you wanted red
you could do 100
and as you can see
you get a red color material and it's
applied to all the objects which are
using our material so that's about it
for base color now if you want to bring
in any textures I recommend this website
called cc0 textures
so open it up now it's renamed to
ambient CG keep forgetting about that so
if you just head in and you can just
grab in any texture
so just I'll just grab in the lowest
resolution one
so I can open it up in my folder over
there
and over here I'll just drag it into
images for now I just have it set up
like this
so I'm just going to extract it
and over here you see you get a bunch of
textures if you want to import it in the
engine it's really simple actually to
import any asset B textures models or
whatever so we'll create a new folder
and we'll import it so textures
open it up and if I go ahead and drag
this for example so
I can just select all of these
and I can go ahead and drag this in my
content browser
and we can go ahead and save it
now if I want to apply this texture to
this material now first of all we'll see
which one is the base color sometimes
these textures are labeled as Albedo but
Albedo is basically a base color without
any sort of uh Shadow related
information that's basically what it
means without any other sort of
detailing it's just the raw color
so if I drag this in the base color I
can do that now you could do this as
well
totally fine
so this is how you would bring in a
texture now if I go ahead and look into
my level you see we have this wood
texture on our little wall here now what
if I wanted to tile this texture a
little better now let's say I wanted to
make this bigger or smaller you'd use
something known as a texture coordinate
so you type in text chord and you're
gonna see
texture coordinate plug that into the
UVs
and now let's say I press 0.1 your
texture will now be scaled 10 times you
and we are basically like your X and Y
to be very vague now we zoomed in way
too much so let's let's make two now so
now you see it's going to be more tiled
so now if you would see
you would have a more tiled material so
if I make this three for example
and if I go ahead and save this you
would see that it'll be even more tiled
so I can make this 3.5 I can increase
the value and it's going to be more
tiled so I can click apply save
and I should be able to see there are
more number of Tricks now I'll I'll just
set this to one once again
and save that and as you can see it's
applied to our level now this may be
fine but what if you wanted more details
let's say you wanted to make this very
glossy so in that case you can use the
roughness node now the roughness is
basically a zero to one value so you can
again use a constant if you want so 0 is
going to be fully reflective
now you could use the specular Channel
as well but most of the times you will
only use roughness
it's very rare that you'll actually mess
with the specular channel so now if I go
ahead and apply this
you'd see that it's very glossy
and if that's not really that clear drag
in a point light
just move this and as you can see it's
reflecting everything over there you see
the little point over there so that's
showing roughness 0
now if I change this to 1 for example
and if I hit save
you'd see that it's not reflecting the
light at all
so that's the use of the roughness
Channel now obviously this is some sort
of a wood floor texture so obviously it
will be depending on the grains of
what's there over there so
how you would set it up is by using a
roughness map now generally in in
websites such as cc0 or ambient CG now
as it's called you would get something
known as a roughness map basically the
brighter parts of the image are where
the light is reflected more the darker
parts of the image are where light is
not reflected so let's say there is a
fully black area here so that's where
all the light is going to be reflected
so I might have told it the other way
around basically the more bright the
color the more the roughness
now if I drag this in
use this in the roughness Channel
as you can see this gives us a little
more definition
now as you can see at the borders over
there you can clearly see that the
roughness map is doing something
so this is about roughness
similarly normal is basically uh your
depth so as you can see this texture
although it has a bit of roughness it
looks completely flat
now if I go ahead and add in the normal
map so if I just snap this to the left
and bring in my
unreal editor on the right
and if I go ahead and apply my normal
map here
and if I hit apply
as you can see you would see a little
bit of a depth over there
now if you can't really see it
that's probably because this is pretty
subtle so you can use something known as
a multiply basically it's just going to
multiply the value of each pixel in this
texture so multiply this you can use a
constant or you can set the value over
here itself in the multiply node so if I
type in 100 let's say
for example
so now you would be able to see a little
bit of the depth over there
but since this sort of a texture isn't
really containing much of depth so you
won't really see it
there are other ways to increase the
depth of a normal map but that's not the
point of this tutorial so basically
normal map is for your depth if you are
into PBR rendering you'll probably
already know all this stuff ambient
occlusion is basically like your depth
in your crevices and stuff it's kind of
hard to explain it there's actually a
comment here so simulate the self
shadowing that happens within crevices
of a surface basically that's what
ambient occlusion is so in stuff like
trees and rocks ambient occlusion is
something which would play a major role
on this sort of a texture it's really
not going to do much
so this is about the basics of materials
now obviously this is completely wrong
because we only have a texture
coordinate for that one texture so make
sure you plug everything in
so just plug everything in
now if you go ahead and apply and save
that
now you'd be able to see that it's
applied properly
this had a subtle effect from the start
itself so that's the reason you couldn't
really see anything wrong with it
so we created a basic material here
now for any of these you can actually
use your constants but most of the time
except base color you won't be using
constants you will be using textures
now
that's the very basics of materials
there are a lot you can do let's say you
wanted to make this thing glow so let me
just remove all of this stuff
let's say I just wanted a glowing neon
green color so let me just get a
constant pre vector
so the same right click search menu
exists in the material editor as well
drag that in the base color
and what you want to do is first you can
grab in a constant and maybe let's say
you have 10 this has to be a value
greater than 1.
so let's say I have 2 for example
so now you'd see that it's completely
glowing white in color
now if you wanted it to Glow in this
color itself what you do is you would
actually get this and you would multiply
this by 2.
so you would multiply this by two
now if I go ahead and press save you see
it's glowing in
sort of green color
so this is basically called an emissive
material because it emits light and it's
pretty cool to look at
by adjusting the value you multiplied
with you adjust the intensity now one
problem which you might have noticed
here is every time we want to change a
value so for example we want to make
this less bright let's say 1.5
now every time we have to apply and save
this what if we could dynamically change
this that's where material instances
come in is basically like your derived
class in your C plus plus inheritance
but to put that in short basically you
create another asset known as a material
instance which is subordinate to this
material and you can edit all the
parameters in it so I can right click on
our material and create the material
instance and let's just keep it as the
engine has suggested now instead of
applying our material we'll apply our
material instance nothing has changed
obviously however if I head into our
material instance now I can change the
parameters over here the first thing you
might notice is there is nothing to
change
so how do you do that basically you
would have to head in here right click
and convert it to a parameter
so any constant or any texture which you
convert to a parameter will be a value
which you can change so this is going to
be called brightness let's say
brightness
and this one is going to be called color
so right click convert to parameter and
call this one color
now apply and save it
now if I open up my instance
you would see that you get two
parameters and now I can edit them so
now if I press 2 you see the changes are
live so zero works one
two
not point three
so I can adjust my values just like this
and I can change the color as well and
it's updating dynamically
so for the most part you will be using
material instances for this purpose
itself
so these were the basics of materials
now you could Tinker around a bit look
into the documentation and create
something yourself
[Music]
now we haven't talked too much about the
other type of mesh that is the skeletal
mesh so let's talk about that now now if
I go ahead and press play actually you'd
see that we have a character over here
which is moving around
now the animations aren't actually
complete if you were to notice he's just
sliding around he's not actually doing
anything
now how do you define the logic where
you know if you are moving above a
certain speed
maybe let's say you start moving you
want to play an animation how do you
define that so that is where you use an
animation blueprint and that is what I
was searching at the start of this
course when we actually did the
character so head into your character
over here one thing that you would
notice is if I just head into mesh and
if I just click on the search icon on
the animation blueprint it actually
takes us to a folder inside the engine
directory where there is an animation
blueprint which actually
does something over here
so this is how the animations are
actually controlled and we'll create one
from scratch we can reuse these
animations no problem
so head into your content folder not the
engine so content
and for now we can just head into our
models folder and over here let's assume
we had our character here so let's call
that tutorial character because I guess
that's what it was called tutorial TPP I
guess
I'll just open it up right click create
under animation create an animation
blueprint and select the skeleton now
now I'm assuming you have a little bit
of knowledge of what's a skeleton what
are bones and stuff so at least that
much would be required if you want to
understand this
basically know that each joint which you
have each uh point which can hinge
basically is going to be our bone
so I am not clear about that if I head
into the actual skeletal mesh
so if I head into this one so I'm not
sure what it's called and this one let's
leave it at new and MBP
so let's PPP I guess
so this is the skeletal mesh now if I
were to just click on this
and if I head into the skeleton view
you'd see for example this is going to
be your index so if I rotate it you can
see that we can actually control it
index 2 is going to be the further part
of the finger stuff like that I'm not
actually applying these changes so
that's totally okay
and for example if I take the pelvis I
can go ahead and rotate the entire thing
because that's the root that's the
reason it's happening if I take spine is
going to rotate the back
stuff like that let's say you wanted to
rotate it a little something like this
so you could make him Bend forward stuff
like that
so this is a skeletal mesh and output
pause over here in the anim graph as
soon as you open the animation blueprint
this is what determines what pose here
and by default it'll just take a t-pose
or whatever pose it was in when you
imported the model so let's apply our
animation blueprint to a character so
head into your character select the mesh
and for the animation blueprint let's
select new nmbp or whatever that was
called so new anim blueprint
so as you can see we are stuck in a
t-pose right now
and let's start applying animations
now in order to add an animation the
most basic way you could do it is you
can simply drag in this animation
and you can play it so this is going to
be
the idle animation
and these are animations which the
engine has provided so I haven't really
done anything here so if you have your
own character you would have your own
animations but as you can see there is
really no logic that you can Define over
here
so the way you do that
is by first of all we can start by
creating a state machine this is the
most basic thing you can do in an anime
blueprint so basically you can use your
variables over here
to determine Logic on how to change
between animations let me show you with
an example so we'll just leave it at New
State machine for now or we can call
this one uh walk run Maybe
idle walk run let's say
just name it appropriately and now if I
compile I'll be in a t pose again
now entry is where you would start so
obviously if nothing's really happening
you you'd want to idle so head into
tutorial Idol if you were to notice it
just outputs the animation because this
is something like your return node
basically
head back into your ideal walk run State
machine now if I compile
as you would see
it's playing behind the animation and if
I press play actually this is going to
work
now we want another state so right click
add State and this one is going to be
called walk slash run
now
this is a shortcut way to do it like I'm
not doing a separate Walk and Run face I
will do a separate Walk and Run state
after I do this
so we want to be able to transition from
idle to walk run so drag in an arrow
and when we stop we actually want to be
able to go back as well and I will show
you what I mean by that now if I head
into walk run
and if I drag this animation
you would see that he's not actually
heading into walk run
so what you can do is you can just set
this to true for example
and you would see that he will be in
this walk run state
so what this basically is is if this
Boolean is true
the character will be able to transition
from this animation to this basically
so how do you do that we can actually
set uh set up some logic here
so we can say is moving for example
this is not how you do it I'm just
showing you guys the basics so if he is
moving we want to transition to the
run face
so idle walk run we have that
now in the event graph we'll actually
set up the logic to get is moving
because remember we only have the
variable but we are not actually setting
the value so every time the animation
updates so that's going to be every
frame what we can do is we can try get
Pawn owner basically that's going to be
our character reference
and we can cast it to our uh I don't
know what it was called BP character I
guess
cast it to that don't do a cast on
update actually you can actually uh do
it on I guess it's called start
uh there's an equivalent of begin play
actually
event blueprint begin play so on this
node you can actually cast it and you
can store a reference and use that don't
cast to it every frame it's not
efficient
so you can promote that to a variable
and call this one character reference so
character
reference
and once we have that stored what we can
do is we can use that if this is valid
of course so convert to validated get if
our character reference is valid uh what
we'll do is we will get the speed
so how you get the speed is by getting
the velocity so velocity
get velocity and we are going to get the
vector length
and if this Vector length is greater
than zero
it means we are moving
so now if I compile you see his idle but
now if I press play
if I start moving you see the animation
triggers but now he's not going back
and that is where the transition comes
in we have set up the logic to go from
idle to walk run but the engine doesn't
know when to come back so a very simple
thing you can do is put this back and if
he is not moving so you can type in an
exclamation so if he is not moving
then we can go ahead and transition back
now if I press play
as you can see it's working just fine
now there are only two animations here
but what if you wanted to blend between
them what if you wanted a walk face
let's say
so the way you do it is by using a blend
space
so what a blend space is is basically
transitioning between two animations and
I'll just show that I'm not really going
to talk too much in depth about
animations and stuff but I I guess you
you guys kind of get the basic idea
let's say you had like a jumping
animation so what you do is you'd have
another Boolean for uh the jump State
and in this state machine here you'd
create a new state and call this one
jumping
and then you would transition from this
and you would go back stuff like that
that's basically how you do it
uh now if we wanted to set up our blend
space as I told you guys so head into
your models TP tutorial TPP
and let's just right click animation and
let's create a blend space
so now we can select a skeleton and
we'll call this one walk run for example
so walk run
if you have a separate walking animation
you can inject it in
but for now we won't
now in the access settings here this is
what you will actually be using so your
vertical axis is like your speed
basically I mean it's a convention you
can interchangeably use this but you can
use the vertical axis as speed so
basically you see the value of 0 to 100
so that's what it is so we can type in
speed
because we can use this name later on
and for the horizontal axis we can call
this One Direction
and it's going to be from minus 180 to
Plus 180.
over here for Speed we can go 0 to
whatever maximum speed by default at 600
so we'll go go with that
and we don't have sideways animations
otherwise on the left here you can place
your sideways animations I'll just show
you with these ones so obviously when
your speed and direction is zero you
would be idling
and walk forward is going to be over
here
now if I hold down shift and if I walk
through this
so whoops
so I might just leave that over there so
at 0 and 0.
and hold Ctrl actually hold Ctrl
and if you notice you're transitioning
between the animation so if I play
as you see now if you're walking slowly
so let's say I leave it at here so when
my speed is 373 and my direction is
whatever that is this is how the
animation is going to play
now if you want this to change a little
bit you can actually uh increase or
decrease the values over here
and smoothing time is basically for your
transition time so how long it will take
to transition from one animation to the
other generally I just leave it at zero
I've had no issues honestly
now in our animation blueprint instead
of this we can use our walk around blend
space
all right you can connect this blend
space to the output now we would see
that you have to provide the direction
and speed and doing that is actually
pretty simple so head into your event
graph and what you basically do is you
grab your character reference over here
and from this we can actually get the
velocity
so velocity
get velocity and then from here we can
get the vector length so basically the
magnitude of the vector
all right uh once we get that for the
direction actually uh we have a node
called calculate Direction
which requires uh the velocity
and I will tell you what to do next so
we need direction and speed so we can
promote these two variables so promote
to variable we can call this one
Direction
and we can call this one speed
and if the character is valid we can set
the direction and speed
over here in the direction
for the velocity
we can just directly grab in this pin
over here
and then what we can do is we can get
after
rotation
now if I hit compile and if I go ahead
and plug these in
over here in my blend space layer then
in my transition over here so walk run
to idle instead of not moving what we
can do is we can get the speed and if it
is less than a certain value
so if it is less than let's say about 10
so then we will enter this transition
similarly if the speed is greater than
10 we'll enter this transition
so if the speed is greater than 10
so then we can go ahead and transition
into the walk run state
so once we change that we should have
our logic working so now if I go ahead
and press play
as you can see
the walk run animations are working
so that's about it now we have finished
animating the character with some basic
animation blueprints
so that's all there is to it obviously
there are many more things you can do
with this animation blueprint of course
you can you can have sprinting as well
so if you would have Sprint uh you would
you know have another state called
Sprint and then you would plug it in
according to what logic you want
basically all you have to take care of
is when your character can transition
into States and make sure it's not going
to be in two states at the same time
that's about it and in the event graph
uh anything that has to update so for
example the speed of the character those
can be done over here on blueprint
update animation event
so now I I think this is more than
enough for blueprints and I I think with
this much of blueprint knowledge you
would be able to make an entire game
assuming of course you would be ready to
look into the documentation a bit and
look into what the various functions do
if you actually play around with
whatever we did plus look at a few extra
functions you can create an entire game
and now for the more keen ones out of
you here we are going to head into C
plus plus now
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
more advanced features of the engine now
not to worry for those people who don't
know C plus plus I will also be brushing
through some of the prerequisites that
you need in C plus plus in order to get
started honestly there's not much to do
with the language most of it would just
be function calls and stuff like that so
anyways without any more further delay
let's actually start learning C plus
plus for unreal now I will be going
through the basics now
[Music]
now let's just talk a little bit about
the prerequisite knowledge of C plus
plus which you'll need to actually
understand the further part of the
course I do still recommend you learn C
plus plus separately but I will get you
guys what you need for unreal because
it's really not that important to know
the language more so you need to know
the features which we actually will make
use of in unreal so I'll just create an
empty console application here so it's
just going to be a blank application
with in the terminal now I won't even
use this I'll just use an empty project
template
so I'll just search for empty in Visual
Studio of course
I mean we have it right here so just go
click next and doesn't really matter
I'll just look for a folder
so I'm just going to create it there and
click create
so just leave all the settings at
default none of these would matter for
now
now once I've created this I'll just go
ahead and set up
the basic stuff which you need for C
plus plus so first of all you'll need a
C plus plus file with a main function in
it so just to
uh just for my reference I'm going to
name it main.cpp
and we need a main function we'll not
get into that now so int Main
and we're just going to return 0. now
I'll not get into this but the feature
which first of all we'll need is to
include code from other files
now if you want to do that
you would do
hash include and inside angular brackets
or inside double quotes depending on the
situation
you would include the actual header file
so let's say I have a header file so
I'll create one
so go ahead and call this
I don't know header.h let's just leave
it as is
and pragma once basically means uh this
header file will only be included once
so you won't have circular dependencies
and stuff basically
but anyways let's go ahead and type some
code so in order to create variables
that's the first thing you'll need apart
from including so including this header
file is simple so in double quotes you
can put header dot h
or you could even use angular brackets
you know generally you would use that
only for like standard C plus plus stuff
but both of them will work
so if you want to include header.h
through this you might have to add it in
the include paths so will not do that we
will stick with this so let's say
something standard C plus plus such as
IO stream
so I misspelled that IO stream I can go
ahead and do this
or if I have something standard C for
example windows
dot h so I can do that so for standard C
plus plus libraries you would not use
dot h for standard C1 so you'll use dot
h so for example if you want cmath
that's going to be without a dot h or it
could do maths.h this is the cmat
library
so stuff like this for now we'll include
adder so whoops
so header dot h
now this should work and later on I will
be showing you guys how to include
unreal headers that's not an issue so
this main function I just like to go
over basically our program is going to
start from here but again as I told you
guys when you're developing a game in
unreal you'd really not worry about the
main function that is handled in the
engine so if you actually go through the
engine Source you will find somewhere
where you have int Main and there is
there will be a wild rope while loop
which actually runs the game so we'll
not talk about that so let's write some
code so first of all creating variables
and before we do that one thing to note
is that these are just text files
honestly you can put the same code in a
header and a c plus file
it it really doesn't matter by putting
dot hatch you just indicate that you
want to include it as a header so that's
the only reason both of these are
technically just text files and can be
opened with any text editor such as
notepad notepad plus plus Visual Studio
or Visual Studio code honestly doesn't
matter
so if you want to create a variable
you can first of all head into CPP
reference to know the basic types
but if you want to create an integer for
example you type in int space your
variable name so for example we'll have
my integer
and if you type in equals you can assign
any initial value to it
you actually don't need to do that you
can do this a bit later as well
but you have to do it inside of a
function or something so if I just put
my integer equals 12
and make sure you end everything with a
semicolon this is not going to work
because
even though you have this line here you
are not executing this at all
so remember I told you guys uh the
program starts from the main function
so over here if I put my integer equals
12 this is going to work
why this works is because we have
included header.net so it's as if it
just copied over all of this content and
pasted it in instead of this hash
include
now similarly you can have other types
which we discussed so you can upload
float X for example
and you can have many other types so for
example if you wanted a string you would
put in STD
string in unreal you use F string but
again now we are getting an error that's
simply because you have to include
string so these are the few additional
complexities which come with C plus plus
so STD string my string equals let's say
test string
and you can go ahead and set the value
again
test string
so not sure what we call that so okay my
string is what we called it
so my string
equals and you can assign any value to
it or you could even use the Constructor
for this
anyways this is how you create variables
like this
data type variable name equals value
need not be defined
initialized as soon as you create the
variable you can do it later as well but
it's always a good practice to do it
now one more thing is that these
variables can be printed out which you
will not use in unreal you'll use the
print string function to print it on the
viewport but in in a console application
you do something like STD C out
and you would go ahead and print my
string for example
again we're not using this in unreal so
that's the reason I'm not really
covering this
so the error is because we haven't
included the header which contains this
function
so you can go ahead and include IO
stream
and if you go ahead and run a debugger
here as you see we get 232 printed
because that was our string again if we
just delete this part
you would see we will get test string
and we can also print my integer
like this
so we get 12
so this is how we would go about
printing stuff
and what if you wanted to write your own
function so what if you have like 10
lines of code and you wanted it to
be in be called once so basically you
can create a function with this syntax
so if you want to create a function what
you do is you put the return type let's
say we create an addition function so
our result is going to be an integer so
the return type is in
space your function name so in our case
let's just descriptively name it add
and in the bracket you would put the Val
put the variables which
you know it should take from outside so
in order to add two numbers we will need
two numbers first of all
so we are going to pass two integers so
the same way in which you created a
variable and in the same way in which
you know you would handle anything else
you just to enter a comma into B so you
separate arguments through a comma
so what this basically means is when I
call add so when I say add
and I put my parentheses so this is how
you call a function so if you want to
execute add this is how you do it and
you'll end it with the semicolon
now inside the bracket you would put the
values of A and B so in my case if I
just put in 12 and 43 and I'll just take
some some random numbers
now the result of this
is going to be returned here
and in fact instead of you can set it
inside the variable so if I do my
integer equals add of 1342 comma 43 so
whatever value will be returned here
that will be set inside my integer now
if you want to actually write the logic
for this so it's simply to return a plus
b
something like this so this is how you
do a function but honestly you don't
need the syntax since we'll we like we
actually have a simpler way to actually
write functions we'll be using classes
mostly so you shouldn't really bother
too much about all this
and with that being said let me just
show you guys how to create a class so
I'll do it in my header so for example
I'll just do a class called student
and I'll open up my curly braces
just follow along with the syntax it's
just a matter of getting used to it
so under private so these were the
private variables which we talked about
in Blueprint as well
so I can say we have a name
and let's say we have his Mark so and
marks something simple like that
and under the public section we can have
some methods
so we can say STD string
oops
and we can call this one get name
and instead of writing the definition
over here like this so this is similar
to what we did here it's just that it is
inside the class now
what we can do is we can only have the
Declaration here like this so only the
name is given here
but we can actually have a defined
outside this class itself
so I can do this and I can go ahead and
actually make another function so I can
say in get marks
so now you can also go ahead and Define
this outside the class
how you do that is
you would use this syntax
I'm not talking in depth about this
mostly because there's a shortcut to do
it which I will talk about
so s3d string and what what was a class
called
student
followed by two colons you do get name
and you can write your function
definition over here
so you can go ahead and return
I guess it was called name so name
and similarly you can provide a
definition for the marks as well so int
student
get marks and you can go ahead and write
the definition for it return
locks so basically you are going to get
the marks from this now if you want to
instantiate a student so let's say you
wanted to create a student object from
this remember we talked about classes
and objects so you just to student let's
just call him S1 for example
and you can do S1 dot get name
now dot is what you'd use to
refer to the members inside a class
in unreal though when you create objects
you generally have a pointer to it
so basically the memory address of it is
a pointer nothing much to worry really
so I'll just show you guys a way to
create it
so if I type in student pointer instead
equals
new S1 basically we are Dynamic new
student
so new student
basically we are dynamically creating
this and instead of the actual variable
name we have a pointer to it pretty much
now nothing much to worry about you just
put a star instead of just referring to
student
and if you want to refer to something
through a pointer you do S1 instead of
putting a DOT
now if you were to do dot you see it
just got replaced with an arrow so you'd
refer it with an arrow so something like
this so if we actually just create a
method to set the marks
so I'll just do void set marks and it's
going to be in the parameter which we
need so end marks so we'll take this
value from outside
and we can say
marks
okay we are using this again so we can
type in marks with a lowercase so marks
equals marks
so what we can do is we can say S1 dot
set marks or rather with the arrow set
marks and we can just say 56 for example
just a random number
and we can print it by typing in stdc
out
and we can print this so run a debugger
and as you can see we got 56 printed so
we successfully set the marks
so this is how we would call functions
which are defined inside a class and you
will need to call them through an object
because you need to instantiate them
first of all this is something which you
will not do in unreal you would use the
function such as spawn actor and stuff
in order to actually create objects but
anyways this was just something I showed
you guys now with this much you can
pretty much do it if there's anything
else such as for loops and stuff you can
just follow along and look at the syntax
that's pretty much it and if statements
are also easy so you just do if and you
would have the condition in the bracket
so let's say
the marks is greater than 56 so I can do
S1 get marks
S1 get marks greater than let's say 35
then we can go ahead and print that the
student has passed so stdc out
and I can say past
so if I do this as you would see we get
56 and passed obviously this is not in a
new line but that's pretty easy to do so
you can do STD ndl
and now you'd see 56 passed
so with this much basic C plus plus you
can actually follow along but again I do
recommend you separately learn a bit of
C plus plus before you come in
the upcoming sections of this course is
going to be for intermediate and
advanced users so before you actually
get started I recommend you guys do a
few things first of all spend maybe a
few days actually exploring the engine a
little bit more may be creating a tiny
game or something
and secondly make sure you do know the
basics of object oriented programming in
c plus plus so stuff like your classes
and you know uh stuff like structs
functions and variables and the the
basic stuff basically if you guys are
familiar with that much of C plus plus
and you have used the engine a little
bit you would be able to follow along
with the further part of the course
[Music]
so in order to start coding in C plus
plus for unreal head into tools and open
your Visual Studio project by clicking
on that button over there
and you should be in some sort of a file
over here now you may have something
blank so we'll just close that
now under your games folder you should
see your project name here and this is
where you actually start working with
stuff now we don't have anything
actually under this we are going to be
having our source files
so you don't actually create it here in
unreal in unreal you actually have the
option to just generate all the
boilerplate code for you
you can do that by heading into tools
and by typing in new C plus plus class
now over here
you get various options now if you have
something really simple if you have some
pure C plus plus logic you could just
create an empty class and you could just
sticker around it's just going to create
a Constructor Destructor and it's going
to write the class definition for you
along with no macros just the standard C
plus plus one but the most basic useful
thing that you'll use in unreal is going
to be your object so under all classes
if you select object this is going to be
equivalent to your object in blueprints
however when you actually create it so
if I just create it uh just select
public and this is just to determine
where your CPP file will be whether it
will be in the public folder or the
private folder now over here we can just
call this CPP object
so let's not confuse ourselves let's
just call it CPP underscore yeah object
is fine so this is not an object this is
the class which is named CPP object
please don't get confused with that so
create a class
and now as you can see you have some
really basic code and one thing you
might not have noticed is okay live
coding is on that's a different story
but what you might notice is it already
has several things such as it has
included some header files here
these are just unreal standard header
files and you will need them
and you might have seen a few extra
macros as well so this is a u-class
macro
and inside these these actually taken
arguments too now these are useful for
the unreal header tool basically when
you compile this it happens in two
phases basically your unreal header tool
sets up stuff which are specific to your
objects for unreal called your objects
and in order to implement those features
it does certain extra steps
so when you get a compiler error it
could be either from that or from your
standard C plus compiler anyways that
shouldn't be much of a problem to you
guys
now if you might have noticed
even though we called it CPP object it's
prefixed with a u and we have inherited
it from U object
now why is it like this now basically
any object that you create that is a
derived class of your object must have
the prefix U and even object has the
prefix u in Blueprint it is just shown
as object however in theory it is
actually U object
and similarly for actors so let's
actually create an actor as well so we
can head back into the editor tools new
C plus plus class and as you can see you
see pretty much the same stuff over here
but these are the two important ones
object and actor now obviously character
pawn and stuff like that are important
but they don't have any specific
prefixes so I I'll be talking about them
a bit later and obviously we'll talk in
depth about the inheritance hierarchy so
I'll select actor
and let's call this one CPP underscore
actor
create that
and live coding if it works properly it
should in theory compile it for us
now if we actually open it up and reload
this
you would see
you find something which looks a little
bit overwhelming if you're looking at it
from the first time but if you ignore
this macro and if you ignore this
comment here I don't even know why this
comment exists because if you have come
to an extent where you can write or
interpret this code I don't think you
need to know that a Constructor sets the
default value so we'll just delete that
comment
and begin Place basically our event
begin playing blueprint same thing
uh tick is again your tick and blueprint
you can delete the comment now this code
looks a lot more cleaner now this is a
virtual function and if you were to
notice it's not called CPP actor it's
called ACP actor basically every actor
is prefixed with an A and the actor
class itself as well
[Music]
all right now that we have established a
basic understanding on creating a
blueprint equivalent actors and objects
let's look at the inheritance hierarchy
in unreal in a little more detail now
I'm not covering everything over here
now I have left a few things such as
interfaces and I'm not going into each
class I'm just talking about the ones
that you'll use in almost every project
so that should cover things for you if
you need anything in specific the
documentation should help you if you
understand this much so at the base
level you have your object of course you
have your typical basic C plus plus
class but we are not getting into that
now under that I can categorize a these
into three main other classes which
you'll use now there are many others but
you won't really use them the first one
and which you probably expected is a
actor now an actor
or a actor as it's called in C plus plus
is something which can be placed in the
scene so if you want to place something
in the scene and write the code in C
plus plus you would create an a actor or
in the menu or in the unreal editor it's
referred to as actor everywhere
now similar to pawn you have a pawn
which is basically something which can
be possessed by a controller so
basically you can control it and it need
not be you it could be an AI as well so
maybe you could write some code for Bots
or something so you would use spawn in
that case
and if you have something specific like
a humanoid character or something
generally for most of the things which
will be Pawn you generally use character
so if you need a movement component
and stuff like that you would use
character some functionality is already
set up in your character which is not
set up in Pawn so something such as
adding your controller pitch and your
input and you know many other functions
which we will talk about as we use them
so that's where you'll use character
this might be clear
now a controller is basically an actor
which takes an input now you cannot
place a controller in a level obviously
it sounds a bit stupid to place a
controller in a level but basically uh
each player will have his own controller
and to be specific he will have a player
controller
if it's an AI or something you have
something known as an AI controller but
again we are not getting into that we
it's really not that common to use it
a controller will basically take your
input now although you can set up your
input bindings in other actor blueprints
controller is the right one to actually
hard code bindings and stuff like that
generally when you create widgets which
are not associated with your character
you would create them inside your player
controller blueprint generally you
create a player controller you don't
create a controller and that's about it
for what you'll use for the most part
and if we actually head into more
gameplay oriented classes you have a
info the reason I put this is because
this was
this was just a wrapper for you know
these classes which you'll use you'll
never create an info actor so ignore
this this just for your reference
over here you'd see a game mode base as
the name suggests game mode base it's
basically your game mode so anything any
code logic regarding your game mode will
be there in this and obviously it's
really simple for me to just tell it
like this but once I take a couple of
examples it's going to be crystal clear
for you guys and there is also an a game
mode class which is inherited from this
and it has some additional functionality
for the most part we will stick with a
game mode base but again you can feel
free to use a game mode
similarly a game State base and a game
State now you might ask what's the
difference between these two the main
difference is that game mode exists only
on the server in multiplayer games
whereas game State exists both on the
server and client so things like match
timers which you would want all the
players to be able to see as well you'd
have them stored in the game State and
maybe some other variables which you
only want to use as a means of
calculating something in game so stuff
which will only be there on the server
and multiplayer games or something which
is core to your fundamental gameplay so
something like maybe you know switching
to another level when you enter place or
something I mean it depends on the game
honestly can't just tell what you would
do with it just like that but basically
game mode game state
work together hand in hand now there's
one more actually called the player
State now the player state is really
special because this is replica this is
replicated by default to all the clients
in multiplayer we upload in detail about
multiplayer later on but for now just
know that player state is going to be
kind of the class which you'll use for
anything that all the players must know
at all points of time
and generally you'd store info common to
a given player which other players need
to know uh stuff like your player name
would be there in your play State
because all other players need to be
able to access your player name at any
point of time so I just gave you an
example you could be creative with it
and do whatever you want
now one thing you might have noticed
over here for the last one which I'll
talk about under your object is are
actually two more uh game instances as
the name suggests your game's instance
so this is talking about your game as a
whole and not anything inside the game
so instead of begin play actually you
have something known as event in it here
so let's say you call something off of
event init that actually runs well
before your level actually loads so
we'll look into examples again
if you have anything pertaining to the
game which has to sustain between level
transitions let's say you move from your
main menu to your actual gameplay level
if you want stuff to sustain between
them let's say you wanted a variable to
sustain in that case you'd use the game
instance because the game instance will
not be destroyed between levels but when
you transition from one level to the
other all the actors and all the widgets
everything else that you could possibly
think of are going to be destroyed now
speaking of widgets we have multiple
classes here which you will probably
never even touch even widget to be
honest you will never touch in C plus
plus it's very rare that you re you
would require a C plus plus class for a
widget
so your user visit is the class which
you'll use of course in the editor it's
going to be referred to as user widget
so this is how you would create widgets
but honestly it's too much of a pain to
work with widgets in C plus for
something that's just you know very
simple you could just work with other
Blueprints and just have a blueprint
widget which you would interact with
stuff like that so that's about it
actually
now the way I'd practically use this is
you'd have one C plus Base Class so for
example we can have for a character we
can have one character and we can go
ahead and derive one so let's say we
call this one R character so let's say
it is a
we'll just call it CPP as a convention
ACP underscore our character
I'll just call it our care for now
now what you do is you would have core
functionality written inside this class
so for example your movement maybe maybe
if you have a first person shooter game
you're firing logic basically stuff that
is Mission critical for the game and
stuff which would break if they don't
execute so for that you write it in C
plus plus
but other cosmetic things which you
don't really require and it's fine if it
executes a bit late stuff like you know
uh creating widget maybe uh let's say
you have a Crosshair on the screen maybe
updating its position uh if you have a
dynamic Crosshair that is or maybe you
know stuff which is not essential like
effects spawning FX so if you have stuff
like that which is not really Mission
critical it's fine uh if it's a bit slow
and maybe if you don't have too many
Loops so if you have many Loops in your
code blueprint generally run slower I
will talk about why that is and stuff so
what you do is you'd have the core
functionality in your base class and
then uh you would create a blueprint
class which I'm marking in yellow and we
you'll call this one BP underscore r car
now this is just a convention I use you
could call it anything you could simply
call this one r car
so this is going to be our blueprint
class and this is what you'll spawn in
the level so since this is inherited
from this BPR car will have all the
properties of acpp Archer similarly you
do that for all the other classes and
that's how you would work hand in hand
with blueprint and C plus plus blueprint
is going to make your coding a lot
easier so it's basically your visual
scripting language so it's going to be
very simple to write game logic
but when it comes to finer control and
when it comes to using other libraries
when it comes to doing machine critical
stuff you would use C plus plus so
that's basically how you use blueprint
and C plus plus hand in hand of course
this is a very in-depth topic and we are
going to be talking about this in the
future now let's actually go ahead and
work a little bit more on whatever we
learned till now
[Music]
so now that we know about the basic
inheritance hierarchy let's actually
start creating stuff on our own now the
first thing which you might want to
create are variables now for our case
just for reference we'll be using our
CPP object.h but anyways you don't have
to use this you can you can do this
inside the actor as well so stuff like
that will remain the same most of the
time you will not have anything in the
global scope you will create everything
inside of your class itself so the rest
of your file maybe if you are creating a
new struct or something you'd use it but
most of the times you will be doing
stuff inside the class
so let's create a variable
now you could do your normal C plus plus
syntax thing so for example let me just
create an integer so by using int let's
say our integer variable
all right you could initialize it here
or in the Constructor
now one thing that you might know is
that since this is private are derived
classes hence any blueprint class which
we create out of this cannot access a
variable so in order to actually access
it there are two ways I'll be showing
you guys both the ways so I'll I'll type
in our private integer variable because
we made it private this is how you would
ideally do it I'm just uh explaining you
guys each thing but you could you could
you know brush through if you are
already aware of object oriented
programming but anyways it will give you
a learning experience nonetheless
now another way you could do it is you
could create a variable in the public
section so we'll call this one r
public
integer variable
now this is good if you want to access
it everywhere however it's really not
you know appropriate to do it this way
because if you have it in public any
other class can just straight up modify
this variable which is not good for us
let's say you have something like your
character speed or something it's very
easy to misinterpret that maybe
accidentally change the value so it's
better to have Getters and Setters
instead now this is how you would work
with a public variable I know you guys
are still waiting for the unreals
reflection system so all these macros
which is EU class use truck your
property I'll tell you about all those
not to worry foreign
is that since this is private in order
for other classes to access it we
actually need to define a method so we
can call this one int get
our
private
hint
we called it increaser order so let's
call it
like this
now we also probably need a Setter
so set our private
integer now we don't have a function
definition so if the reason I told you
guys at the beginning that you don't
really need to know too much C plus plus
is that once you know how to write the
Declaration you could just right click
quick actions and you could just create
a definition like this same way with our
Setter function oh and this has to be
void because we aren't actually
returning anything you could make it
bull so let's say you have a condition
where you can't set it so let's say for
a health variable you can't set it to
101 so then you would do those checkings
and stuff but in our case we'll just use
void
head into the file here and instead of
this we will return this variable so not
public we'll return our private integer
variable
now this is how you would set it up for
the private variable and this is the
proper way to do it
also
uh currently none of these use unreals
reflection system now if I just run a
debugger so it's going to launch the
editor make sure it's set to development
editor in the configuration
so wait for that to build
and once it's done building it should
start the editor
[Music]
now in order to actually use this over
here and actually check stuff uh in
Blueprint so what you would do is you
would right click go to blueprint class
and type in CPP underscore object but
you see that it's not visible now the
reason it's not visible but our actor
was visible because by default All
actors if you were to go into this file
by default All actors are going to be
marked as blueprintable so if I actually
head into
uh the actor over here
and if I actually look into this U class
macro you see it says blueprintable
so what we need to do is in our object
if we want to use this in Blueprint that
is inside this u-class macro type in
blueprint table now this is how you
expose your view objects to blueprint so
let's say anything is not accessible in
this menu over here okay under all
classes it probably means you haven't
marked it as blueprintable so let's stop
the debugger and run it again
so wait for it to compile then once the
editor loads up we should be able to use
our
CPP underscore object class
so give it a second for it to load
and now if I head back into blueprints
right click blueprint class CPP
underscore object you see that it's
usable
and this one will call it BP underscore
object
now if I just right click and if I want
to access the function
so we have get our private integer
so get R and as you can see there is
really nothing
the reason is
unreal doesn't really know that you want
this to come in the editor basically
you're not utilizing
uh the unreal standard macros which
enable you to do it
so how you do it is for variables what
you do for a public variable here we are
going to type in U property
and in the arguments will use a
parameter known as blueprint read write
now when you put this in the arguments
basically what you're saying is you want
this to be readable and writeable in
Blueprint let's say you only wanted to
be able to read it you do blueprint read
only now how do I know how to do this
basically you can just head into your
browser and type in you property
ue4
audio A5
oops not properties
so
yep your property so basically you have
to go to the documentation page and
as you can see there should be a list of
specifiers somewhere over here there is
so all of these are the specifiers so
let's say you wanted a function to be
blueprint callable you do that that is
blueprint PR as well I'll be showing you
guys the common ones but you can have a
look at all of these
the documentation is King
now for a private variable actually we
don't need to make this Au property
however you could choose to make it now
if you want to use these Getters and
Setters which will technically
you know enable us to use our private
variable
our get function will be pure of course
so we are going to use a u function now
now view function is another macro again
you could have a look at it so here if I
head into U function over here
you see again there is documentation
which talks in depth about this
we will be looking at the common ones
anyways
this one will be blueprint pure
blueprint PR means those green nodes
which we saw without any execution pins
so if I actually head into any blueprint
these types of nodes basically without
this execution pin
that's going to be our Pure function
and I talked a lot in depth about it
when I talked about Blueprints and stuff
now this one will be a u function as
well and this one will just be blueprint
callable
all right now we can go ahead and run a
debugger
now we should be able to access this
now live coding is a bit finicky that's
the reason I'm not using it otherwise I
would have chose to use it now let me
just create that I didn't actually save
it so CPP underscore object
we'll call this one BP underscore object
save that this time
if I open it up now and if I type in get
our
private integer you see we get this
function which gives us access to the
value similarly set our private integer
also works but it's kinda useless we
actually didn't set up any functionality
so let's just take in a parameter
parameters are pretty simple except
references everything else is going to
be the same for parameters like how you
do in standard C plus plus so you could
type in in new value
and over here as well we could just head
into the definition and change that
and then we could do our private or our
public it should be nope it should be
private so our private integer variable
equals new value
now that should fix things so we should
have our logic corrected over there
but that's not really our concern right
now
what if you wanted to take a value by
reference now this is passed by value
and it will work you could try it out
not really going to waste my time to
show it if you actually want your value
to be passed by reference you use this
macro known as U param
ref
and then you use an ampersand over here
so copy this do the same thing in your
CPP
and now if I go ahead and actually build
this once again
and and in my object if I go ahead and
type set our private integer you see
it's taking in by reference if you hover
over it it says new value integer by
reference
so this is how you do pass by reference
I just showed that this is one thing
which is a little different from C plus
plus you can't just use an ampersand
however if you use an ampersand it is
going to take it as a second return
value in Blueprint basically like your
out parameters so let me show you guys
what I mean by that so if I do this now
this is wrong logically this is wrong I
know that but anyways I'm just showing
you guys what's gonna happen
so if I go ahead and run a debugger once
again
this time it's going to take it as an
output rather than an input
if I open my BP object again
and if I type in
let's say set r
private integer you see the new value
goes out basically this is how you
handle multiple return values as well
you could just do pass by reference and
in Blueprint it's going to interpret it
as an out parameter in our case uh your
param ref was the correct choice so we
are going to do that undo this over here
as well
so that's about it
oops just correct that
also if you guys want to access your
public variable you can just directly
use our public variable so our public
integer variable so it's directly
accessible to us but one thing you might
notice is that unlike these variables
here it does not let you edit the
default value and stuff
now there is one reason for that that's
because you again need to set a flag in
order to do it remember the you property
macro or here you have to type in edit
anywhere in order to be able to do it so
edit
anywhere if I can spell that correctly
if I actually do this and run a debugger
once again I should be able to use our
public integer variable and set its
default value
now if you were to see under the class
defaults we have an option to set the
default value or when we even get our
public integer variable you see that we
can set our default value so this is
basically how you expose that to
blueprint
[Music]
I suggest that you guys now try it with
a few more functions of yourself
and maybe you know check how they work
in the editor and stuff once that's done
let's talk about the next type that is
u-struct so basically if you want to
create structs for the Unreal Engine you
need to use the macro known as you
struct now generally I prefer doing it
inside this dot h file for your project
so you will have a file like this
but you really don't need to you could
do it in any file so for example let me
just do it in our CPP object.h file it
could be really anywhere unreal is going
to recognize it for you so I'll just do
it above our U class so I'll just type
in struct
and if you guys don't know what struct
is uh well you got to learn that before
it's basically like a class but uh by
default all its members are public but
remember when you are working with the
Unreal Engine you don't really work with
struct methods you only work with
variables and any methods you'll have
you'll have it in another class as
static functions so that's how you work
with it anyways I will show you guys
what I mean by that real soon
so for example let's just create a
struct known as let's say book
this is obviously highly impractical but
just as a basic example and for the
variables we could have maybe a string
now remember in Unreal Engine the
variable you use is not STD string so
you don't use STD string actually what
you use is called fstring which is
unreal string type
obviously most of the string types are
just interconvertible at any point of
time so if you are using a third party
library or something you can convert it
so F string is the string type in unreal
so if I type in F string let's say name
and maybe we can have an integer for
number of pages
and we can have a float for rating
all right we have a really basic struct
over here now if I go ahead and build
this actually so I'll close my editor
if I go ahead and build this
you would see that it would build
successfully
however obviously uh as you would expect
you cannot access this struct in the
editor because we haven't used the
unreal macros so in order to use this in
the editor you you call you struct
and inside the parameters what you do is
you would make this
blueprint
type
so this is what you use to expose truck
to blueprints now if I actually run a
debugger right here
so you would find that there are a few
build errors
so what this is is this is not your C
plus plus compiler error
basically there are a few rules in order
to use structs in unreal similar to how
you have a u prefix for all structs you
need to have an F prefix
so now if I go ahead and run this
in the editor it's going to be visible
as book you see that we get another
error now it says expected a generated
body now if you notice our class here it
has a generated body similarly for our
struct as well for all U structs we are
supposed to be having a generated
u-struct body
so it's going to set stuff up for the
editor for us basically
so now if I go ahead and build this you
should see that we compiled successfully
and we open up the editor right now
but you will soon notice one problem
again which you probably would have
guessed if you would have seen these
so the so if I just head into my object
for example and if I if I type in let's
say I create a new variable and call
this one book one
and I get the type book
you see I can access this
there's no issue but if I right click I
can't actually split the struct pins
now if you actually hover over this
cannot split the struct pin it may be
missing blueprint exposed properties
so what is it basically tells us is we
actually need to Mark these as you
property as well so the same macro can
be used here as well so you property
and there's a little bit of an issue
with the indentation there don't mind
so your property again
make this one a you property depending
on what you want let's say we don't want
to be able to change the name so let's
make that blueprint read only so then we
won't be able to change it now if I stop
debugging and open the editor once again
now if I go ahead and take a look and if
I drag this in right click and split
struct pin I am able to split it now if
you drag this in and if you want to edit
the members you would use the set
members function
and obviously you can have number of
pages and rating as a parameter and we
set name as not being editable since we
did blueprint read only as you can see
we don't have that available as a pin so
this is basically how you use structs in
C plus plus now the way you use it in C
plus plus is pretty much the same like
how you would by the way if you want
struct methods you can use them but you
cannot write U functions inside stock
that's the thing so if I actually go
ahead and try it basically I'll show it
to you guys so
if I had in here type in let's say void
test function and I'll just give it a
simple body here and I won't do anything
now we would see that it will build
successfully there won't be any issues
so as you can see it builds but if I
actually make this a u function
I won't I won't even give any parameters
if I just make this a u function
as you would see it says use trucks
cannot contain you functions
so how do you actually do stuff with it
so how do you actually operate on
structs basically what you do is instead
of having the U function here you would
have it inside either a function Library
class or you would have it inside some
other object and make it a static
function maybe so let me actually show
that
so let's create a test function
so for example let's create a u function
here
so U function
and what we can do is we can make this
blueprint callable
and over here instead of just declaring
a regular function let's do a static
function static void test
and now we want to operate on this truck
so if you want to operate it similar to
your objects what you could do is you
could simply create your own Target pin
so the way you do it is fbook
Target and obviously you would make that
a reference so
you param
and in the brackets you would have ref
so you would pass this as a reference
and then you could work with it inside
so I can write the definition here as
well but just to be a bit cleaner so
quick actions
so whoops
quick actions and I can create the
definition
uh now now that we've actually come this
far I'll just show you guys how to print
strings so it's not like blueprint where
you directly just call you know print
string and this is not gonna work so I
can't just do this so let's just say
test function called for example
I actually cannot do this
uh the very simple reason being that
[Music]
in Blueprint unreal actually Imports or
rather includes all your headers for you
as per necessity but basically that
doesn't happen here so it's not exactly
headers but you get the point
so in order to use print string so how
you would go about searching for
functions is you do something like this
so you do print string
unreal C plus plus this is how you just
search it up and you would look for the
one which says docs.unreal engine.com
and you would head in here and it says
it tells you the include file so copy
this path
paste this in no not path rather the
include
and now we would see you have all the
various parameters some of which are
optional there are only two parameters
which actually need but anyways
now what we can do is
now you notice that you are not able to
call it
but that's because this is actually a
static function once again
so what you do is you do you Kismet
system Library
and followed by a scope resolution print
string and now we would see that it
still shows an error that's because you
actually need to pass in a world context
object because it doesn't really know
you know where to uh output the string
like how to show it on the screen so in
order for it to know that you actually
need to pass in an object if this wasn't
a static function you would just use
this so if if this were inside an actor
and it's not static you'd use this but
it says this may only be used inside a
non-static member function so what we
can do is we can just pass in a u object
pointer over here or rather we'll just
pass in an actor pointer so a actor
pointer now remember when you work in C
plus plus
any object any actor anything that you
have which is enclosed in a class
basically any class if you want to use
them you would use a pointer to it you
will never refer to it as a actor it'll
always be a pointer just remember that
so an actor is just to give you know
some context to it so we can just type
in context for example
it could be an object as well I assume
so if I type in context here
now we would see that the error is gone
but obviously we change the function
signature you could make this a u object
pointer I believe
and now what we can do is we can copy
this over
head back into our function declaration
and put that in
so now our error should go now if I go
ahead and actually run this
now if I head in to Blueprints and BP
object or here if I call test for
example I think it's called test as you
can see now we can operate on this truck
and for the context we can what we can
do is simply we can plug
any you know outer object in so I'll
just actually do that
so I'll open up the level blueprint so
for the context what we can do is we can
go ahead and
get a reference to sell
and for the Target what we would do is
we would go ahead and actually get a
struct so instead of this I'll just
create a struct
so I'll just call this truck for example
and it's going to be of type book
so we can use that and now this function
is going to operate on this truck
so this is just a basic way you can do
it now if I go ahead and press play
after three seconds you should see
something being printed test function
called
as you can see that works so that's
pretty much how we would handle struct
methods
[Music]
so that pretty much covers the basics of
using structs in unreal C plus plus now
the next thing is obviously enumerations
and that should be about it and then we
can start you know working with a little
more complicated things at the base
level enumerations in Blueprint and C
plus plus work the same but in order to
create them in C plus plus you can do
the same thing actually you can do enum
this one doesn't really need to have a
prefix by the way so for example let's
just say fruit
uh fruit list let's just call it
and inside that we can have our list
items so let's say we have apple
let's say we have our mango
and let's say we have a banana
stuff like that make sure I just end
everything with a comma
now again the same thing this is not
exactly exposed to blueprint but in
order to actually expose this you you
use the same
specifier as your use struct but instead
you type in you enum
if you use the U in a macro and if you
add in the parameter blueprint type now
this would be usable in Blueprint but if
you wanted to give it a different you
know name for it in Blueprint so if you
wanted to give a display name to this
basically what you do is you'd use
another macro known as you meta and over
here you change display name equals and
you put in the string so in our case uh
let's just call this one apple
underscore underscore one maybe
so just for you just for me to
demonstrate that it works
now if I actually run the editor
and I can just go ahead into any
blueprint and I can operate on that so I
can say switch on whatever we call that
fruit list as you can see instead of
Apple it actually shows apple one and
mango and banana is just shown as this
generally what you do is you would
simply have the display name to just
display exactly what this list item was
so you would simply have this and you
would have mango over here
generally you would just leave it like
this
banana
so this is how you would go about doing
it
[Music]
now we have brushed through the basics
of Unreal Engine C plus plus of course
if you want to know what function calls
to use for your gameplay specific needs
you could refer the documentation and
later on when we actually take an
example we will look into some of the
common ones so it's not really that you
have to refer the docs for everything I
will be going through many of them now
over here let's actually do a quick
exercise let's try to translate this
into C plus plus now if you were to
notice this entire thing is actually
purely in Blueprint and let's say we
wanted our code to run faster or for
whatever reason we needed it to be in C
plus plus so let's actually go ahead and
translate that so it's really simple
uh let's start step by step
so we have our get player camera manager
function let's see which header file we
need so it says Target is gameplay
Statics right so this tells us that we
need gameplay static so if I head into
Chrome and if I type in gameplay Statics
poe4 or ue5
you see you actually get the
documentation page
so over here we can get access to which
header file we need so Kismet gameplay
statics.net so stuff like that let's
actually go about doing it now for the
cast node we need a C plus plus class
because all are C plus plus classes will
not have access to the blueprint classes
but all our blueprint classes will have
access to the C plus ones so you cannot
access a blueprint class from C plus so
that's one disadvantage
now let's go about doing this
so
I'm just showing you guys one example
obviously we will talk about a few of
the common ones such as spawning actors
and stuff which are really common
now let's start in the editor so let's
go ahead and actually create the classes
that we need so first of all we need a
base class for our BP character so go
head into tools new C plus plus class
character and call this one CPP
underscore character of course you can
name it descriptively if you wanted
create the class
head back in
and we need a couple more things
actually
so one thing that we need is the pickup
class itself so type in actor
and call this one
CPP pickup
all right
create the class
now what I want you guys to do is head
into BP pickup and over here under class
settings for the parent class I want you
guys to select CPP pickup
and over here as well I want you guys to
select BP CPP character so CPP
underscore character I want you guys to
select that now what this basically
means is that you are inheriting this BP
character class from CPP character so
everything that's there in CPP character
will also be there in VP character
basically this is your inheritance
now let's head back in let's just reload
this and I think we can close the editor
for now
or actually we might need that for
reference so let's actually open up the
character
so we need a camera manager and from our
header file we from our documentation we
know that we need this header file so
inside our character.h because that's
where we wrote it always when you're
including header files you need to do it
above the generator.h
so over here Kismet gameplay statics.h
and let's just uh do this in the public
section
and let's have a look so when we press
our left Mouse button we get the player
camera manager so let's try calling that
static function
so go ahead
let's actually create the function let's
call this one I don't know what do we
call this
so we're just tracing and destroying so
let's call this one
remove pickup or something so avoid
remove pickup
all right we don't really require any
parameters
now let's go ahead and create a
definition for it
so whoops let's just head in and it has
created the definition for us
so let's go ahead and get that that's a
static function so you gameplay Statics
get player camera manager
and over here what we can do is for the
world context object since this is an
actor characters are actors so you can
just use this generally you just use
this and player index as 0 since we have
only one controller per screen
so we got the camera manager and from
this we need the actor location as well
as the forward vector so what we do is
let's actually just store it in a
temporary variable so we can type Auto
Temp equals
and we can store this in a variable and
what you can do is we can go ahead and
get the actor location
so this is a pointer again so temp
with the pointer operator we can get the
actor location
we have forward Vector here let's do
that as well
and temp
get actor location now this might
actually warn us right now uh to use the
get camera location function so as you
can see use get camera location instead
so get camera location
just spell that correctly and now we
have access to these locations
and what we are doing is we are
basically plugging this into the line
Trace
so what I can do right now over here to
simplify things is we have a forward
vector
we grab that in
and we multiplied by a float
so the operator is already overloaded so
we multiply that by 50 000 in our case
so let's just do that
and if we head back into our blueprint
so we add that to our camera location
so plus our camera location so you could
just do a plus again
so plus our camera location we can put
these in parentheses just to be a little
more clear on what we're actually doing
so we can delete this line
we have that next what we have is our
line Trace so if you just hover over
this you see it says Target is gizmit
system library and I know this header
file so I'll just do it for you guys
anyways uh what we are doing is going to
be correct so let's close this up
so it's going to be Kismet Kismet system
Library you could have a look at the
documentation as well
so Kismet
Kismet system Library
and if we include that our error should
go and if I open up the CPP file once
again
now we should be able to call the line
Trace function so you Kismet system
Library
line Trace if I do that I should find
line Trace single
and for the parameters we have a bunch
of them so first one is the world
context object which is going to be this
again and next we have the start and the
end location we look into all of that so
this
and our start location is going to be
our camera location
so what we can do is we can actually
store this in a variable right now
so what we can do is we can type in auto
camera location
equals
get camera location
now for the start we can go ahead and
type in camera location
and then we have our end so again we can
store this in another variable so Auto
End Lock location or let's just call
this one end
equals
whatever calculation we just did right
there so
end and is what we called it then the
next parameter we have is a trace type
query which is the trace channel so this
is what you see over here
now over here uh this is a little bit
peculiar in C plus plus so if I just do
e Trace type query
so e Trace type query
and if I take a look you get something
like one two three so on basically these
are what you define in the project
settings so if I actually head into my
project settings and just type in Trace
you would be able to see that you get
Trace channels by default we actually
get to uh that is visibility and camera
so if we just do a trace type query one
that is going to be your visibility and
then if we take a look we have a Boolean
for dress complex we don't really want
to dress for complex collisions here so
let's just do 0 or that is false
and over here we have a parameter which
we actually don't need and we also have
a few more I guess we'll just use the
ones which we absolutely need so actors
to ignore we can just create an empty
area and we can just pass that in so
tra
actor pointer
and I will get to TRS don't worry
basically this is like your STD Vector
in standard C plus plus uh instead of
that the one used in unreal is called
tra so all the same functions exist
inside this as well instead of dot size
you have you know dot num there are a
few names which have changed but it this
is pretty much like your STD vector and
let's just call this one ignore
and we'll just pass that in so ignore
and the next parameter is uh e draw
debug Trace so basically whether you
want to see the line trace or not so we
draw
debug Trace
whoops
and over here we have for duration for
one frame persistent uh let's keep that
for duration for now
all right
once that is done we have our head
result which we are going to Output so
we'll just create another variable so if
hit result
and we'll call this one
hit or out hit or whatever
and what we can do is we can just pass
hit over here and once we have our hit
result we have B ignore self yeah we
want to ignore ourselves
and don't really need the dress color
because this has a default value so
that's about it basically
so we can go ahead and close this
so I feel these parameters should be
enough and once this function is
completed we should have access to
everything that we can possibly think of
so the first thing uh that we are going
to do is we are going to cast it to the
pickup
now in order for us to work with this
first of all we need to include the
header file so hash include
because we don't know what CPP pickup is
so we'll just do
CPP
ickup.h
so this should compile because it is in
the same folder and once we actually
include the file what we can do is we
can simply cast it now you won't use a
dynamic cast here unreal actually has
some things built in for us
so we can get our hit
so if
hit
dot actor dot get actor
if this is valid now at this point if we
haven't actually hit any actor with our
line Trace basically this if is going to
be false and we are not going to execute
this code however if we have hit the
actor we can go ahead and cast it to our
pickup so if we can go ahead and cast it
so this is going to be acpp pickup this
is how you cast in unreal C plus plus
basically you have a cast function and
over here we can just pass in the actor
so if this actor is valid so again the
pointer is going to be pointing to an
actor if it is actually valid in that
case what we can do is we can go ahead
and destroy this actor so hit not get
actor and we can call the destroy
function
that's about it and just to make sure
what we can do is we can just print it
so UK is mid system Library
print string and over here we can just
pass in this instead for the world
context object and we can print
destroyed a pickup
and we can go ahead and terminate that
so now in order for us to actually be
able to call this from blueprint uh
we'll set up input and stuff a bit later
in Blueprint it has a couple of extra
steps so in order to expose this to
blueprint field again use a u function
and make this one blueprint callable
make sure I get the case right
and just indent that and now if I go
ahead and close my editor and run a
debugger now
the editor should load up and if we open
up our character we can get rid of all
this code and I don't know what we call
this so we called it remove pickup I
don't even know why we call this but we
can call remove pickup
remove pickup now if I go ahead and
press play
and if I left click as you can see
our logic actually works
and okay this is not a pickup this was
just a cube so that's the reason it
didn't work
but anyways the line Trace works
now the reason it's working is because
BP pickup is also a CPP pickup because
we inherited from it so that's the
reason what's happening is when we
actually cast it over here uh we are
actually
successfully casting to our CPP pickup
as well even though that was a BP pickup
so that's basically how we translate it
now we can go ahead and clear out some
stuff this was just for clarity so
instead of using the camera location as
a separate variable we can go ahead and
copy the server
similarly for n we could just do the
same
and
if we have anything else we could do
that as well so we don't have anything
else we can go ahead and close this up
we'll we'll leave this temp variable
because having such a long line
everywhere is going to be a little bit
weird but again you could you could do
this so you could just place this
instead of temp wherever temp is going
to be there you could go ahead and
get the player camera manager and do
that but in this case actually using
temp would be a better solution so we'll
just stick with using temp
[Music]
so we have brushed through quite a bit
regarding C plus plus and as we create
stuff we will go through more things now
what if apart from a pickup we also
needed to cast some other thing so let's
say let's actually create another actor
so let's do it with our interaction
actor itself so let's go ahead and open
it up not sure why we've used it so
let's just hit Ctrl f to find and let's
just find interaction
so
so we are basically nudging it so what
are you basically doing is we are again
casting so I have to just check where it
is
so if we are overlapping so that's what
we are doing
so let's actually remove this logic and
let's actually have the destroy logic
itself
so remove this
and remove this or actually we could
keep this
now if you wanted to do it with your
cast so what you would have to do is you
have to cast to interaction actor
if this fails and then destroy it and
this for the most part will work
so let me just go ahead and drag that in
forget about the C plus plus logic
and as you can see this works and even
this works
however one thing you might notice is
let's say in an actual game obviously
we'll have many such actors not just an
interaction and a pickup actor
so in that case
you will have to perform many cars and
casting is expensive for your computer's
performance
so the way you get around this is
instead of casting multiple times you
could cast to an interface
and in unreal blueprint there's actually
a very elegant system implemented we'll
be talking about both the blueprint and
C plus versions of interfaces now
so in order to handle this problem
what we can do is we can actually create
an interface so I'll show you guys step
by step to implement this exact logic uh
using an interface and we can actually
have separate logic as well for both the
interaction and the pickup Factor
so head into your blueprints right click
blueprints blueprint interface and let's
just call this one I don't know destruct
I guess
uh generally I have a Convention of
calling it BPI underscore
and we can call this one
destruct pickup Maybe
all right and we don't need anything for
the input
but anyways now the way you actually use
this is for whichever actor that needs
to be casted to so for example we are
casting to our pickup and our
interaction actor so we would head into
both of these and under your class
settings under implemented interfaces we
can go ahead and Implement BPI destruct
and do the same thing for the
interaction actor head into class
settings
DPI destruct
basically at at the fundamental level
what this is doing is it is inheriting
this interface along with actor so
basically your interface is also class
internally in C plus plus I will show
you guys the C plus plus version which
will make things a little more clear
but instead of doing all this what we
can do is we can call destruct
or I guess I call it pickup so let's
just call it destruct in general
to compile and save that so we call this
destruct
and now if I actually go ahead and press
play I mean nothing's going to happen
because
although we have destruct as you can see
we can't really Define the logic here
the way you define the logic is for
example we can head into pickup under
interfaces right click Implement event
and if I go ahead and just print a
string and I can type in
destructing pickup
and if I go ahead and destroy it so
destroy actor and Target will be self
and I'll do the same for the interaction
actor so implement this event oops
paste this in and we can do destructing
whatever this is
interaction after
so now you should be able to see that
both of these different implementations
are actually called so if I press play
you see our pickup is destroyed and if I
actually click on this side our
interaction actors also destroyed
so this is how you basically use
interfaces instead of casting basically
what it's doing internally even though
this looks like we got rid of casting is
instead of casting to our interaction
actor it casts to the interface because
interaction actor implements that
interface the cast is going to succeed
and the function will be executed
the situation where the cast fails is
automatically handled in the engine
now how do you do the same exact thing
in C plus plus you may ask it's pretty
simple actually you just use the concept
of multiple inheritance in C plus plus
so tools
[Music]
create a new C plus plus class and over
here what you have to do is Select
unreal interface
and we can just call this my interface
for example and create the class
it should load up visual studio for you
so just reload that and over here you
should be able to see my interface.h and
my interface.cpp basically this is where
you would write the function definitions
and you can go ahead and Define it in
your various classes
so what you do is for example let's just
have
this function
work for both the pickup and you know
our
whatever that was interaction actor so
let's say we want this function to work
for both of them so let's go ahead and
do that using an interface we'll
actually get rid of the C plus plus
logic
so we'll get rid of that
and what we got to do is first of all uh
since we are actually casting to the
interface here we can go ahead and
include the header for that so hash
include
over here uh we can go okay we are
including pickup already so what we can
go ahead and do is we can go ahead and
include this interface in the pickup
so not after a generated before the
generated dot h
and this is going to be
my
interface dot h
and over here where you see public a
actor
I put in a comma and type in public
I my interface
I is basically the prefix which is used
for interfaces just remember that
so my interface in the editor is going
to correspond to IMI interface in C plus
so let's actually write our function so
let's call this void disrupt Maybe
and we can go ahead and add in our
implementations
so we can right click first of all
and
make this one virtual
right click
actions
create a definition for it
this is just going to be like your
default implementation
so now let's say we wanted to implement
this function in another class it's
really simple to do it now that we have
a virtual function here we can head into
our pickup.h and over here along with
this we can type in Virtual void and I
don't know what the function was so I'll
just copy this over
do the same thing in the pickup
and since we are actually overriding a
base class method what we can do is we
can use the keyword override
uh now if I go ahead and right click
quick actions create a definition
head in here and now let's say we do the
same thing so let's say we do U Kismet
system Library
print string
this and let's just say
destroyed
pickup from C plus plus
and we need to include Kismet of course
so let's just do that real quick so let
me just copy this over
because let's just do this in the dot h
file
so now we can go ahead and actually
destroy it so we can say this
destroy
or rather you can just call destroy
all right so we can go ahead and test
this logic but remember it's not going
to work for our interaction actor
because
we again don't have another C plus class
for it so let's actually create that too
so new C plus plus class actor
let's just call it for example I don't
know
CPP underscore interaction active
okay so we'll create the class
and what we can do is we can again
implement this so in order to implement
the interface
so I'll just stop the editor there so in
order to implement the interface we'll
do the same thing what we did for pickup
so if you head into the header here
copy this over head into your
interaction actor
implement the interface and again we
need the header file so what we can do
is we can do hash include
uh whatever this is so we have my
interface.h
and then we can go ahead and implement
this event by using virtual void
destruct which was a function name and
we are overriding a base class method so
override
and now we can go ahead and create the
definition for it
and over here we can go ahead and print
the string again
we can do that by simply including
Kismet again so let me just copy it over
oops I'd copied that so head back into
your pickup
where we had included it copy that paste
that back in
and let's just copy over the code from
our pickup
you can have different code as well I'm
just showing you guys as an example on
how to use it so we'll change what we
print so destroyed
interaction actor from CPP and this
should work
also just head back into your CPP file
your CPP character and where we cast it
to the pickup what you basically do is
instead of casting to the pickup you
cast to the interface since we inherited
the interface so it's going to be I my
interface and make sure you actually
include the header file I've already
done that so somewhere over here we have
included pickup.h already and pickup.h
already implements the interface and we
have included the header so we don't
really need it so we can cast to this
interface and instead of destroying and
printing what we can do is we can
utilize this
so we can
have this separately so we'll just do
Auto
temp equals I mean I'm doing uppercase
temp because we've already used
lowercase temp here
and temp is going to be valid because
the cost has succeeded
so what we can do is we can call
destruct from here
all right
now we can go ahead and run a debugger
now if I head back into my character
connect this up
uh hit play
and you should see that we say destroyed
pickup from CPP but the interaction
actor doesn't work that's because we
haven't actually set up the parent class
over here so go ahead and change that to
CPP underscore interaction actor and we
could rename this as well BP interaction
actor
all right so if I go ahead and press
play the pickup works
and as you can see destroyed interaction
actor from CPP
so that's pretty much it that's how you
use interfaces and later on we will also
be seeing more practical examples this
was probably a good one but still will
actually implement this in our actual
game
[Music]
now let's look at another case where you
know you want to call blueprint
functions from C plus plus now this
almost seems impossible because your C
plus plus classes aren't actually aware
of what blueprint classes exist but
actually it is
it's really simple too so what you do
you could use it in any actor any object
even in the interface if you want but
I'll just show you guys in the character
by just printing something
so the way you actually call blueprint
from C plus plus is like this so you
just write the normal function so let's
just call this void
test BP func let's say
and now what you got to do is you have
to use the U function
a macro and you can make this blueprint
callable or not but the specifier that
you need is called blueprint
implementable event
so now you can have the function
declaration over here you can actually
have parameters too so we can test that
if you want so in X let's say
so now if I actually run this you won't
actually get a compile error because
unreal or automatically generates the
definition for you and you can Define it
in Blueprint
so if I open up my BP character
and under functions under overrideable
if you just have a look you will have
test BP func and as you can see I can
actually implement this over here and we
also got our input parameter so we can
just go ahead and print a string we can
either call this through blueprint or we
could even call this through C plus plus
let me show you guys by calling it
through C plus plus so I'll do it on
begin play
so what was a function called again test
BP func
and you would see that this is actually
implemented so let's type in 100 for
example
and this will work and in the meantime
now I would like to show you guys one
more thing that you can do I just wanted
to show you guys that yes you can
actually do this you can actually
implement it in Blueprint
[Music]
but there is a possibility that you have
some C plus code but then you also have
some blueprint code which you want to be
executed so in that case what you would
do is you would use another type known
as blueprint native event so we'll just
copy over this function
and let's call this one test BP native
funk and let's just have something else
for example let's say we'll have a float
and for this actually what you need to
do is you need to have another function
called The implementation of this
function
so that is going to be what you define
in C plus plus and this is going to be
our function name in Blueprint so in
order to explain what I mean instead of
implementable type in Native
now if you compile this you'll actually
get an error so what you're supposed to
do is not create a definition however
you are supposed to create an
implementation for this so the way you
do it is you just copy over the
signature and instead of the same
function name you type in underscore
implementation
whoops
so what you can do now is for the
implementation you can go ahead and
create the definition
head into your definition and we can go
ahead and print something so let's say
we go ahead and print
for example let's just say
C plus plus implementation
called
and we can close that in
and for a blueprint implementation we
can set that up in Blueprint no issues
so that should be it now you can go
ahead and actually compile this once
again
so apologies I just made a few typos
over here so
so let me just copy Implement over here
so implementation
and do the same in the CPP file as well
so underscore implementation and now you
should have no problems
so if we head into a BP character
and we can go ahead and override both of
them so test bpfunk we can go ahead and
print it actually uh this is our
blueprint implementation and we called
it from C plus plus so okay we'll just
go ahead and print it we are calling it
from C plus plus so what should be
expected is 100 is going to be printed
even the native event you can call it
from C plus plus I'll just do it over
here
so first of all let me Implement that in
Blueprint so
Implement that go ahead and just print
that
that shouldn't be that hard and just
grab in our begin play here
and instead of okay let's just spawn
this let's keep all of this logic
and we can go ahead and since we made it
blueprint callable
whatever this was and we'll just take in
some random value
now if I compile and if I go ahead and
press play as you can see we get 100 as
well as our four two three four three
printed
now your obvious question is why didn't
the C plus plus implementation get
called so if we if I actually go ahead
and delete this and if I were to press
play now we would see our C plus plus
implementation is called but that's not
really that useful isn't it unless you
just have some sort of a default
implementation
so what you actually need to do in order
to get the C plus plus version called is
right click on the Node and type in add
call to parent function
now it is going to call the C plus
version
now if I go ahead and press play
as you can see
it calls the C plus C plus plus
implementation the blueprint
implementation as well along with it so
that is basically how it works
now if I if you were to do this as you
can see we call the C plus function
along with the parameters of course as
well as the blueprint function what you
are calling here is actually the
blueprint function if it does not find
an implementation it is going to use the
parent class version of the function
remember that foreign
discussed everything which was
foundational in order to actually start
developing in C plus plus however we do
lack a little bit of knowledge regarding
you know the implementation of various
data structures in unreal now apart from
just using normal variables you would
use arrays and Maps there are others
such as sets linked lists and stuff but
for games you would honestly just use
arrays and Maps most of the time
so in order to implement arrays in
unreal so you don't use a static array I
mean value could but you don't use
static arrays uh you don't really use
the STD Vector as well you could use a
3D Vector but you can't expose them to
blueprint and stuff or you would have to
write your own wrapper class now if you
guys don't know what I'm talking about
I'm basically referring to the standard
template library in C plus plus
but in unreal instead of STD Vector we
actually have
another type known as template array or
tra so the way you create that so let's
create a variable in C plus plus let's
do that in the public section we're just
doing it for demonstration so I'll just
make a U property
and make this one blueprint read write
and add it anywhere
so edit
anywhere
and over here what we can do is instead
let's say we have an array of integers
so the way you do it is you type in t
array and as a template argument you
would give the type as integer and let's
just call this our end array
all right now template array is actually
internally
something like your STD Vector so if I
actually Ctrl click on this this is
actually a class which implements it
and the methods which are associated
with this are pretty simple we will go
ahead and check all of this
so similar to the STD vector class in
standard C plus plus tra has a bunch of
functions which gives us info about
various things so let's actually set
some stuff up so in order to initialize
this array so what we do basically we
can do it in the Constructor or right
here we'll do it in the Constructor just
to keep things clean so we'll call R and
array equals
and within curly braces we can just give
some values so I'll just initialize it
with some random values
all right so now let's go ahead and look
at how to add stuff to this so similar
to add and in place we have methods for
that over here as well so we can type in
R int array
Dot add and now we can go ahead and add
an item so let's say for example I want
to add 12. so our fifth element here
that is at index 4 is going to become
12. and this array is going to be
resized since it is similar to an STD
vector
now similarly also have M plus so
constructing an element in place
basically
dot m Plus
this is like your M plus back function
in STD vector
so I'll just add in some random element
over there now our array is going to be
23 6 43 64 12 and 4. now what if I
wanted to remove something so I can type
in R int array and I can remove either
at index so dot remove I can either
remove an element by using the remove
function so let's say I wanted to remove
23 I'm gonna remove 23.
and R and array
whoops
R and array
dot remove at
is going to let us remove something at a
given index so let's say I choose zero
so now it's going to remove 6 because we
already removed 22 so 6 is our first
index so 6 is going to be removed
all right so we did all of these but now
what if we wanted to reserve some memory
for our array so what if you didn't want
it to resize and search for memory so
even those functions are available so
let's call The Reserve function before
all of this so our end array
dot Reserve whoops Reserve
and we can as we can see we have four
elements five six
and we remove two so we have to so we
can reserve for but at Max we have six
elements so let's Reserve six
so we can call that and stuff
so these are the most common ones that
you'll use I won't really use all the
other methods but again you can just
refer the documentation if you really
need it
now we can go ahead and iterate through
this array through a range based for
Loop just like how you can with any of
the STL data structure so you can go
ahead and do for Loop
Auto
we can just call this one element
and we can pass in the array just like
how you would pass an STD Vector so R
and array
and what we can do is we can go ahead
and print it out by calling the print
string function so you Kismet system
Library print string you know that drill
by now so
now in order to print an integer you
actually use this function which is a
static member of the F string class so F
string from int is what you use
and you can go ahead and type in Le here
now remember if you wanted to print a
float you would use this function known
as sanitize float now it's going to cast
it implicitly anyway so even float works
for this
and you also have other functions for
converting between various data types
you could again have a look at either
the F string class or you could go ahead
and just search it up on the
documentation so if I actually head in
over here so we have our sanitized plot
here we have two hex blob from hex blob
we have we have various functions
basically so we have from int as you can
see you can go through this class
see the return type and look at what the
function does and then you can go ahead
and implement it accordingly
so now I'm in the editor if I open up my
BP character and if I actually head back
over here we had made this blueprint
read write so we should be able to
access our
and array so if I just type in our int
array so as you can see we get it just
like any other blueprint variable and
since we initialized it in a Constructor
we already have certain values now in
begin play if we go ahead and iterate
through this
so I'll just do that we'll uh not call
this function anymore now we have an
idea of what that is
so we have already set it up actually so
we we have done it over here so we're
printing stuff
in our begin playing C plus plus so we
don't have to set it up actually so if I
go ahead and press play as you can see
we have 4 12 64 43 in reverse order that
is 43 64 12 and 4. and let's actually
walk through the logic so we have 23 6
43 64. and we went ahead and added 12
and 4 so 12 and 4 should be our last
elements
and we remove 23
and we removed six so our RS should be
43 64 12 and 4. and if we go ahead and
look at our logic here and our output so
we see that we get 43 64 12 and 4. so
this is basically how you use the tra
class functions so this is exactly the
same as your STD Vector but there are a
couple differences in the function names
and most importantly from a readability
perspective all of these functions use
Pascal case so it's readable compared to
the standard C plus plus stuff which
uses underscores which is not really
that readable
so this is how we would it return array
obviously you could use a full length
iterator but there is no actual purpose
to do it as per my experience
anyways let's head into the next part
now and take a look at how else we can
iterate through this through your
standard C style for Loop so I won't be
actually showing you guys the output
since it's obvious that it's going to
work so you just do something like for
INT I equals 0
I less than where now this is where we
talk about another method in this class
so we do I less than
R and array dot num this is similar to
the size function in the standard
template libraries STD vector
and we can do I plus plus so we can just
increment I go to I plus plus or I plus
equals 1. now instead of Ali since this
is not a range base for Loop we can get
our array
and we can get the ith element
now this is going to work exactly the
same
[Music]
apart from RS the other data structure
that you would use in a game is going to
be Maps well there are linked lists and
other data structures which you really
won't use that very much in games
even maps to be honest you just use it
maybe a couple of times in your entire
project
but anyways in order to create a map in
unreal basically you you use the type T
map
so if I just copy of the U property
macro and in the next line you can go
ahead and create a map
and if you guys know about Maps
basically it's just a key value pair so
for example you can have two strings as
key and value and you could have
something like a username password key
value pair something like that so let's
just create a simple one let's say we
map a string to a float
so it's case sensitive obviously
and we can call this one R map
now you can't just initialize a map like
how you would initialize an array so you
would have to call the add or the MPS
function multiple times that's just how
you would do it
so our in Array or rather R map dot add
and what we can do is we can pass in the
string and the float so let's say pi and
3.14
then we can go ahead and call add once
again
so we'll just go ahead and do all of
this in our begin play
so let's just find some other number
let's say num1 for example let's just
grab in a random value
now once that's done
you have other methods but you aren't
really going to be using them for
anything but I'll just show you guys how
to iterate through this and how to
retrieve the key and the value so that's
what you'll be using this most for
now let's say I wanted to access an
element though you could do something
like this so let's just print out uh
what the index num1 will contain
so copy this over
and instead of R and array of I what we
can do is we can get our map
our map
of
num1
basically num1 is the key here and
basically by doing this you're getting
the value of it
so in our case we mapped num1 to 43.4543
and if you want to iterate through this
we can use a range best for Loop here as
well
so we could just say Auto element
and we can pass in our map
and what we can do is we can get the
element so we'll print this so we'll
copy the code over once again
so we'll print both the key and the
value so let's just create a string
variable temporarily
and the way you get the key of this so
each element in this map is going to be
a key value pair
so Le is going to be a key value pair
what we can do is we can do Dot key in
order to get the key
and if we want the value we can go ahead
and do Le dot value the way we'll do
that here is we'll just append the
string so basically we'll concatenate
the two strings so what you can do is
temp dot append
and let's just put a call on Just for
visual purposes
and we can do temp dot append and since
our value is going to be a float we can
do F string
sanitize float and we can go ahead and
get arm
value so Le dot value
that is going to be a float
now we can go ahead and rather than
printing this we can go ahead and print
in temp
so we also learned how to concatenate
strings on the way
so this is how you would iterate through
this this is how you would get a key of
a given element in the map and this is
how you get the value
now remember
you cannot have two keys of the same
value so let's say I actually create
another uh element with the key num1
it's going to throw an exception you
can't actually do that so now we'll
actually stop printing our array now
that we are done with that
so if I go ahead and run a debugger now
since everything is set up now if I go
ahead and press play
you would see that we get Pi 3.14 and
num143.4543 and as you can see we also
get our four three dot four five four
three uh that printed first
because we had printed our map
of num1 so basically
the key here is num1 and we basically
asked for the corresponding value it is
just as if you asked for R int array of
one it's pretty much something like that
so basically instead of the index you
would pass in the key that's basically
how you use this operator here
now this is basically how you iterate
through it now you could you know do
many other things with the map
but for the most part you'd just be
using it to store key value pairs
generally it's useful for having a track
of you know game users and stuff like
that they're really very odd audios
cases for maps you wouldn't really use
it that often so I'll leave this over
here
[Music]
now when it comes to designing your game
once you're actually aware about all the
things that we just discussed over here
up until Maps in order to actually
Implement them in an appropriate and
efficient manner you would use the
classes which the engine provides us
so we'll be going through some of the
most important ones which will be used
in all of the games and there are other
derived classes of it the ones which I
showed you guys in the flowchart
previously when I showed the inheritance
hierarchy those are the ones that we
will be discussing in detail there are
other classes we'll just be brushing
through few with whichever are important
but if they are not we are going to be
just skipping through them but if we
ever use them in the last part of the
course
we'll be having a look at them in depth
once again
so now let's start talking about actors
now at this beginning of this video I
actually talked a little bit about
actors basically anything that can be
placed in the level is an actor so that
definition still holds good but it is
incomplete there is another thing which
an actor can do and that is it can tick
now you guys have probably seen the tick
function so let's open up an actor
actually let's create one because all of
these have their own base classes so
let's create a pure actor in Blueprint
we'll do one in C plus plus as well
pretty soon
or actually we probably have it so let's
call this one BP underscore a let's say
I just created this for the sake of it
now if I were to actually have a look
over here
you would see that you have three tabs
and the event graph is where you worked
on for the most part but we haven't
actually gone in depth into all of these
little details so first let's actually
go from the top so what we have here is
the class settings and most of the times
you'll just use it to implement an
interface or change its base class but
other than that you aren't going to be
using it now under class defaults you
have a bunch of things which actually
Define what an actor actually can do now
if you were to look at actor tick you
have several options start with tick
enabled tick interval and you also have
several other things now we did talk
about this one so I'll I'll not be
talking about that
but anyways all of these are
self-explanatory and one thing which you
won't see in any other type of blueprint
other than actors is the replication tab
ly if you check this replicates tab this
actor will be eligible to be used in
multiplayer what I mean by that is that
when you spawn this on the server which
we will get to when we talk about
multiplayer basically all your other
clients can see too by clients I am
referring to players in this Con context
and we have settings regarding that
now these are just the flags these are
pretty self-explanatory hidden in game
and visible stuff like that
and under the Collision tab these are
things which we again talked about
but there are a couple more things which
an actor provides us the first one is
your damage now if let's say you have
you wanted this actor to be destroyed so
let's actually do that
let's go ahead and create an object so
let's add in a model here so let's say
we add in a sphere
I don't know uh maybe simulate physics
on this or let's let's leave it as is
what we can do is unreal actually
provides us with default logic to apply
damage to this so if I type in
event damage
you see we get three of these nodes
Point damage radial damage and any
damage so any damage is going to refer
to all types of Damages Point damage is
going to be your damage through a line
trace or something generally radial
damage is going to be something where
you know you damage this actor through
grenade or something like that so you
would have you know a distance and stuff
like that so if I just press this so you
have your origin so that's going to be
where your grenade landed for example
so it need not be a grenade could be
anything else just give an example so
from that point uh if as you go further
away your damage is going to decrease
stuff like that so let's just do event
any any damage so any damage
what we can do is over here we can go
ahead and simply print this out rather
just to demonstrate that that this
actually works now by default unreal
does not give you any health variable
you got to do that yourself and one
thing you might have noticed is this
little icon over here at the top right
hand side of any damage basically that
property is called blueprint Authority
only what it means is that you can only
call this on the server so you cannot
call this on the clients obviously you
don't want your players to be handling
the damage and stuff but anyways let's
actually go ahead and work on this logic
so when we left click we do the line
Trace thingy so let's bring up the line
Trace logic once again
so what we can do is we can line Trace
by Channel
and we get our camera manager get player
camera manager
get the after location
this is some stuff which we've already
done then we get the forward vector
and we multiply this by a certain value
so let's just convert this to a float
and let's multiply this by let's say 50
000. we are going to add this
together
and we can plug that into end and the
start
and from our output we can go ahead and
call apply damage
so there are multiple nodes apply damage
apply Point damage and apply radial
damage will do apply Point damage you
could just do apply damage
and base damage let's just give it a
value of 30. or just to keep things a
little more interesting so Random float
in range
so let's just say anything between 20
and 50 Maybe
so it's just going to select a random
number
and damage doctor is going to be the hit
actor obviously and damage causer is
going to be self
damage type is something we won't be
talking about and hit info we could just
pass in this whole hit result
so what we can do is instead of doing
this we can recombine this
pass this in here
and we can go ahead and break this
separately
so type in Brick
and pass the hit actor once again to the
damage actor
and we can collapse this as is hit from
Direction basically uh that is going to
be something which isn't really going to
affect your damage
but once you know the damage doctor's
location you can actually find the
direction towards it basically so what
we can do is you can do something like
this
so basically use this node called find
unit Direction so unit Direction
so get unit Direction
so it's going to be from our start to
our location and this is going to be our
hit from Direction
so basically uh this is a position
vector and this is a position Vector as
well so we can subtract it to get a
vector joining those two points
basically and now it should compile
if you really don't want to use this you
can go ahead and split this and this is
going to work as well it's just going to
construct a vector in place
so we'll recombine that and use that
and if I go ahead and press play
nothing's gonna happen but if I actually
drag our BPA here
and if I go ahead and press play
so as you can see
we are applying some random amount of
damage
so not sure why the lag exists
but anyways
now once that's done the next thing that
an actor provides us and also just one
one more note here so now we are talking
about the blueprint version of this
we'll also look at C plus plus stuff a
bit bit later there are a few things
that I would like to go over in C plus
plus as well so the next thing is hit
events now remember we had done the
overlap for a character so somewhere
over here so similar to that you also
have hit events so you just type in
event hit
and this is how we set up hit events you
also have hit events for each individual
component so if I click on the sphere if
I scroll down I can actually do on
component hit as well that works too
now other is going to be the actor which
actually hit this
and other component is basically the
component of the other actor which hit
it my component is going to be the
component in this sector which actually
hit the other actor
and hit location is the hit location of
course and we also get a hit result so
way too much for what you need so that's
generally the reason why when I actually
work on these things I I just create an
interface myself
because generally you really don't
require all of these things in order for
your damage logic to work
anyways I'll show you guys how this is
gonna work so if I just go ahead and
print this
and one handy node here is you can
actually get this and if you can type in
get display name
and you're going to get
the display name of the object basically
if my character bumps into this so let
me do that real quick okay I can't it's
too high so let's bring that down
so if I actually bump into this as you
can see you get BP character the reason
it's printing it so many times is
because we are in contact with it for
quite some time
so when we are in contact and we are
sliding on it each frame it counts a new
hit basically that's the reason it's
happening all right so the next thing
that I would like to touch upon when it
comes to actors is the construction
script so this is similar to your
default Constructor in C plus plus now
there is a way to actually uh get an
equivalent of a parameterized
Constructor I will get to that both in
Blueprint and C plus plus but first
let's work with this so let's say I drag
this in now every time I update this
actor the construction script is
actually called so let me just show you
guys so if I just go ahead and print
string
and if I go ahead and move this actually
so first let me compile that
save it and now if I head back as you
can see every time I move it it actually
prints hello
basically every time you spawn this
actor or you update this actor in the
level this construction script is called
at runtime it's only going to be called
when you actually spawn it but over here
in the editor whenever you move it it's
going to be called each time there's
actually an option somewhere in the
class settings
so run construction script on drag so
you can disable that if you don't want
that to happen so it's it's only going
to call it once you finish placing it
I'll just leave it as is
now if you want a parameterized
Constructor
basically let's say you wanted to set a
variable so let's call this
uh I don't know maybe some float
variable
and we'll make this of type float now if
you want to actually set the value of
this outside like a parameterized
Constructor
first select this variable
and head into
this option right there select instance
editable and expose on spawn
now what you've essentially done is your
basically exposed this when you actually
call the spawn act a function
so if I just head into my character and
spawn this on begin play so I'll just
leave this BP pickup and let me just do
this actor instead so BP underscore a
now Health points is not a parameter so
you can alt click that to delete the pin
now as you can see
we can select some float
so I can set this to whatever I want
now this is something which we touched
upon
however there is an equivalent of this
in C plus plus as well
but it is a little more complicated than
this
so if we actually head into our Visual
Studio solution
all right so now that we are in C plus
plus now let's actually test it out with
our CPP underscore actor so let's go
ahead and spawn this from our character
or if we have anything else we could try
that as well so our interaction actor
maybe if we could try that so we can
spawn our interaction actor
now if we go ahead and head in here
inside our character's header file
so we can go ahead and include that as
well so hash include
and we can go ahead and include CPP
interactionactor.h
now let's actually create a function or
we can do it on begin play so head into
begin play
now after we are done with this or we
can actually just remove this logic we
aren't really using this
the way you spawn actors in C plus plus
is by calling the spawn actor function
from world
so in order to get your world you call
this function known as get word
and from here you can go ahead and call
spawn actor
and this actually takes in a template
argument
and this is going to be the type which
this spawn actor function will return
so it is going to be acpp interaction
actor
and I could just spawn it like that it's
going to take in all the default
parameters you can actually set up
subclasses and stuff so let's say
instead of CPP interaction actor you
want it to spawn some derived class of
it which is there in Blueprint you could
do that totally
so let's say I wanted to spawn BP
interaction actor and not CPP
interaction actor so we can actually
test that theory actually
so BP
interaction actors pond
I mean the spelling doesn't really
matter here
so let's delete whatever's there in the
level so BP interaction actor
so interaction actor so I'll just go
ahead and delete that now if I press
play I'm not really getting that
so what I can do this is going to spawn
your CPP interaction actor
but if we actually have a variable here
which stores the exact class which we
are spawning so we can do that right
there so you property
make this one edit anywhere
and make this one blueprint read write
as well
now what we can do is we can go ahead
and pass this in so the type which you
use is T sub class of
and obviously we are looking for a
derived class of
acpp interaction actor so we'll just
copy that over
so this is going to be prefixed with an
a
and we'll call this one class to spawn
or rather we can call it actor to spawn
now this will be available to us in our
blueprint
now one thing to remember you have to
make sure it is actually valid
so if
r
reference is valid here so our subclass
is basically so if this class reference
so if actor to spawn is valid
only then we are actually going to be
spawning this actor
and over here in the arguments list you
can go ahead and pass this in
and paste this in
and you can also pass in a transform
optionally but I won't be doing that
now let's actually pass in some
parameters
so if you want to pass in a parameter
using your deferred spawn actor as I
would call it as the function is called
so we can actually do that with the same
thing
so let's create a variable here which we
would want to edit
so under the public section we can go
ahead and create a new property
we don't need this to be blueprint read
write or anything so we can call this
one in
some variable
and the way you would set default values
for this
is if I go ahead and write the function
again so this is how it's spawn an actor
here you would have what's going to be
returned so if I actually do Auto
temp equals
spawn actor interaction actor basically
this temp will be of type ACP
interaction actor pointer so pointer to
this point actor will be uh returned
now
what what we can do is we can spawn
another one actually so we'll just do
Auto
temp one equals
we can just go ahead and copy this
and instead of this we can do spawn
actor deferred
and just make sure to get the spelling
right so spawn actor
deferred so for this one we have to pass
in the transform so we can just uh write
a Constructor over here so F transform
and that should compile but once you
call this function the actor is actually
not spawned now since we have a pointer
to our actor we can go ahead and call
this function known as finished spawning
so if I type in Finish spawning this is
going to actually complete the spawning
process
now you can just again pass in the
default transform
so once this is done
our spawning would actually be complete
and in between this is where you can
actually set your variables
so you don't have a parameterized
Constructor but now we can go ahead and
set our some variables so some variable
equals 100.
obviously temp one
and now what we can do is in our
interaction actor we can go ahead and
just print it on begin play so you
Kismet system Library print string and
we can go ahead and
continue with this and go ahead and
print in
F string
from end
and we can pass in our value here so
some variable
is what we want
and that should be about it
now if we go ahead and run a debugger
here everything should work as expected
just make sure you close the editor
before you actually build it so
so now if we go ahead and press play we
shouldn't see any print strings
and this proves that our if check here
is actually working if we would have
removed this if check our engine would
have crashed since this actor to spawn
class reference would be invalid anyways
we can set that since we have exposed it
to blueprint so in our character I
assume so this is in CPP character so
it's going to be inherited into BP
character
and under your class defaults over here
you should be able to find your variable
so CPP character under the third section
here actor to spawn and we can select
our BP interaction actor if I go ahead
and press play now as you can see we get
two prints along with one zero and one
hundred for our
Pond actors now the first ones are 0
because in our first Pawn actor function
we actually didn't set any of the values
so this was our class X Pawn actor
and in the second one we actually use
the Deferred spawn actor which let us
set the default values before calling
the construction script
so this is basically how we would
simulate the parameterized Constructor
in Unreal Engine in both blueprint as
well as C plus plus
[Music]
now the next class that I would like to
mention here is going to be the
character class and we have used that
quite a bit so if we just open up our BP
character for example which is a
character class so we have inherited
from CPP character just to keep things
clean and just create a new character
here
and let let this just be called new
character Maybe
now open it up now if I were to just
look at the parent class it says
character
and character is actually a derived
class of Pawn so basically every
character is a pawn and pawn is a
derived class of actors so when I'm
talking about characters I am
collectively referring to both pawns and
characters basically
every character is going to be a pawn
now
the reason why I especially wanted to
mention this even though this is
technically just a derived class of
factor and probably probably many other
classes which I'll mention further are
derived class of factors is due to this
character movement component now this
allows you to do various things now if
you were to just go ahead and look into
these parameters
you can actually have a pretty basic
idea on what you can do at the beginning
of the course if you remember I had
mentioned that you can actually use
functions to modify almost any of these
values not all but most of these values
at runtime so for example now let's just
take our BP character for example and
let's go ahead and press play and we
know that we're using this
so we are walking forward but what if
this feels a little bit too fast for you
now this is where our character movement
component is going to help us
so the maximum speed of this character
is actually set by a variable inside
here so if I just drag this in and if I
type in set max
walk speed
as you can see we are able to set some
value over here so I'll just do this on
begin play you could do it somewhere
else as well
but let's say we wanted him to go only
at 500 default is 600 by the way
now if I go ahead and press play you see
that he moves a little bit more slowly
now if you feel this is a now one more
thing is that the animation will also
slow down along with his speed so that's
not something which you should really be
seeing in this example
so we are moving slower let's say we
wanted him to move a little more fast so
let's say we have 1000
we can go ahead and set the speed and
now we walk much much faster
so stuff like this
and one more useful thing which the
character movement component provides us
is movement modes so if I just type in
movement mode
and get movement mode you can actually
see this is an enumeration we can just
do switch to see what are the
enumerators here as you can see we have
walking nav mesh walking which is for AI
basically falling
swimming flying and Custom
now there are various things you could
even do with this uh apart from
switching between them you can actually
set the movement mode
so for example if I just change this to
Flying for example
and if I go ahead and press play
now you will notice that this behaves a
little bit differently now if the
movement mode is flying
if I go further
as you would see
he's actually floating in the air
so when you actually set this movement
mode to Flying basically it also allows
you to take vertical movement input so
apart from your move forward and
backward you could also do up and down
so let me actually do that so where we
have our add movement input instead of
forward if I do up Vector so get actor
up Vector
if I just do something like this and if
I go ahead and hit W as you can see we
can actually go up and down as well
so this is something cool which you
could do and there are a few functions
which I would specifically like to talk
about right now and one of them is
launch character launch character so
let's say I wanted to implement a jump
pad or something so let's just do it
after a delay so
delay of about 2 seconds
and we can go ahead and give something
for the launch velocity let's just give
10 000 Maybe
now if I go ahead and press play
as you can see
we were launched in the air I mean I
just gave a really high value for the
launch velocity let's say we give
something like 3000 Maybe
if I go ahead and press play
as you can see we are launched in the
air so if you had something like a jump
pad or something which you wanted to
implement this is a really cool way to
do this and the best part about all this
is this is actually networked by default
most of this logic if you just run on
the server is just going to run well for
multiplayer as well
so that's one thing so launch character
and stuff like that there are actually
many other functions which
you would have access to one way to
actually take advantage of the context
sensitive menu is if you just drag off
of self
and if you can just head into character
you can actually look into various
functions over here
this is what I find useful you can act
apart from launch character few more
functions which I would like to go over
or Crouch
so if you set your movement mode to
crouch
and make sure you have you can Crouch so
there should be an option somewhere here
so Crouch
should be under character movement can
Crouch make sure that is true
otherwise it's not gonna work make sure
this is true and if you go ahead and hit
Crouch
and one thing that I would like to show
you guys is by setting this hidden in
game to false so let this be visible in
the game
now if I go ahead and take a look at
this
as you can see everything seems normal
here
let's actually just disable some of this
logic
all right so I'll go ahead and Crouch
so if I go ahead and Crouch as you can
see
our
capsule whatever we had is actually
shrunk
this is basically our Collision now so
let's say you couldn't pass under some
things now you can actually so I'll just
drag this a little bit below average
character height
so let's say about this much
and our walking speed is also very less
even though we set it to thousand
manually now as you can see our
Collision is only up to the capsule you
can change the height by the way
so if I just type in Crouch I should
find Crouch half height you can actually
increase that no issues with that and as
you can see now this has a separate Max
walk speed so stuff like this is already
implemented for you in the engine now
all you have to do if you really want to
learn more is just browse through this
list just look at something which might
be useful so let's say you're doing
multiplayer but have a look at this now
this is not something which would really
be that helpful to be honest
but there may be a few settings which
you might actually find helpful
now there are many many more things
which you can do and if you aren't able
to actually write a certain mechanic
using these nine out of 10 times you're
just doing it wrong it's just one out of
maybe 10 20 times that
the engine is actually deficient of
features
so just like this you could go ahead and
explore this for yourself all of those
parameters which we saw in Blueprint are
also accessible in C plus plus there is
nothing special really so for example
let's say I wanted to crouch so I can
just type in Crouch as you can see the
method Crouch exists here as well
ah not only that if I want to access my
character movement based functionality
there is actually a get function for it
so get character movement is the
function name
so this is going to return a U character
movement component pointer so once we
actually have access to that so let's
say Auto Temp 2 equals okay it's in a
different scope so we can reuse temp
so Auto Temp equals
get character movement and now we can
use this variable in order to just call
our regular functions so for example if
we want to change a movement mode so we
can type in
whatever the function was over here
so movement mode
so set movement mode was the function
name
set movement mode
now clearly it's not happy with us using
this type but fix for this pointer to
incomplete class type so the simple fix
for this is to just look up the
documentation for the header here we
don't have the character movement
component header file so we'll just
paste that in our dot h
and now if you go ahead and look at this
this should work and now we get the
options for the parameters
so for this let's actually type in
e movement mode
and we have move flying for example
and then new custom mode we can just set
this to zero
so like this you can set the movement
mode in C plus plus
so stuff like this is going to be
analogous to both blueprint as well as C
plus plus however note that some of
these headers aren't actually included
by default so make sure you just go
ahead and include them before you start
working with them
[Music]
so we are inside the BP player
controller class
and we have dealt with this before but
going a little bit more deeper player
controllers or controllers in general
are designed to handle input
so if we actually bring in an input
binding so for example I just type in w
on the keyboard
so what's going to happen is
this input will actually be taken over
our input bindings which we set up in a
character so if I just print a string
we'll actually not move instead we'll be
printing hello
so that's one thing to note other than
that the mouse interface has several
important functions such as show mouse
cursor enable click events enable mouse
over events and stuff like that all
these are self-explanatory one thing to
note is that your Pawn or your character
obviously is going to be possessed by a
player controller and without apply
controller you can not actually control
your character and all of these are
actually set inside your game mode
so which black controller class you use
is decided by your game mode class which
we will talk about soon game mode game
State player State and play controller
all of these work in conjunction a
player controller is going to possess a
pawn which you can control
now once that said there are a few other
functions which are important here such
as set input mode game only which will
take your game input basically and when
you have set input mode game and UI only
so in that case you are going to be able
to interact with widgets as well as take
player input in the game
similarly UI only is going to disable
your keyboard input entirely so stuff
like that functionality regarding input
is available in your player controller
[Music]
despite using all of the above mentioned
classes it is technically impossible to
set up a well playable game
so we have a few more classes which
actually set up the whole framework to
actually start developing the game logic
itself
and those are game mode game State and
the player State now the play State
isn't that important but the game mode
and game state will provide you with all
the functionality that you need in order
for your gameplay logic to work so we
have already created a game mode
know that every level will have one game
mode and you have to set that
and the important part here is
these classes this can be set over here
in the world settings
and upon class is as as expected BP
character however this can be changed at
runtime in the sense you can possess a
different Pawn the default is going to
remain the same but you can call the
possess function on your play controller
so let me actually show that so let's
say I'm on new character right now
so now I can't move or do anything
however if I head into my game mode
and let's say after begin play
I just give a delay of few seconds
so delay and I give let's say three
seconds or two seconds
and I get my player controller
now note this is a single player game so
this works otherwise anything that you
do will be with respect to the server
game mode in a multiplayer game will
only exist on the server that's one
thing to note
so from here we can type in possess
and what we can do is we can just spawn
a character so where our player start is
you can just copy this over let's say
or you can have a Target Point instead
so just type in Target point
drag this in
and get the location
so we have something like 10
negative 11420
so head into the game mode class
for an actor
select BP character for example
so BP underscore character and for the
transform
negative 11 420
and we'll do 350 for the Z
and for the pawn this is going to be the
pawn which we will possess
now if I go ahead and press play wait
for two seconds and as you can see we
have possessed our BP character
so stuff like this you can easily set up
in
your game mode so anything such as this
which is handled on the server is done
in the game mode but the game mode isn't
really limited to this
the game mode has several functions such
as post login
and you also have other things such as
on
log out
so this is basically when you join the
game in a multiplayer game this is
basically when you leave the game or you
disconnect
so you'll still have all the references
available to you
so that's where you'll use the game mode
foreign
however let's say you wanted to store
something like a timer now the timer has
to be in sync with everyone
so obviously it has to be on the server
but all your other players must be able
to read it at least so in that case you
use a class known as game state which
does the exact same thing
so if I just type in game state
I'm going to use Game State base game
state is basically game State based with
a few extra functions
so let's call this one DP underscore
gamestate oops BP
game state
open it up
and ignore the viewport and stuff
doesn't really matter
and once you have this
over here we can have something like a
match timer so I'll create a new
variable and call this one timer
so I'll make the subtype integer
over here we can go ahead and start the
timer so set timer by function name
we can go ahead and create a simple
custom event here so custom event and we
can go ahead and call this one for
example timer increment
you can copy the name paste that in we
want it to run every one second we want
it to be looping and it has to run till
the end of the game
so we can do timer plus plus
now this uh value of timer over here can
be read by
your widgets and stuff like that so
there's actually a function which you
can use for this so let's do that in our
widget
head into your UI
HUD BP HUD
and where we have our stuff set up
so let's actually revert our character
settings so change the character to BP
character
and over here for the spawn actor as
well we'll remove that for now
for now we'll forget about it
over here where we actually create our
HUD this is where we have our reference
so what we can do is we can actually
create some more text here so we can
type in timer so whoops you can type in
text
drag in some text here
maybe just increase the font a bit
and we can go ahead and have
has to be light
anchor it to the top right hand side
and instead of this we can go ahead and
set this to be whatever the timer is
so in our game state every time this
happens we have to update it
so what we can do is we can get our
player controller here we don't have a
reference to it currently so get player
controller
we'd have to cast it to our BP player
controller cross to BP player controller
now we can do this on begin play
and we can store a reference in a
multiply again this is not going to work
obviously
so promote this to variable and type in
pcrf maybe
for play controller f
you can go ahead and update
okay we have a update Health function we
can create an update timer function so
custom event
update timer
and this should work as is so give
the timer value to this
so type in timer
get a reference to your HUD
make sure this is variable and we'll
call this one timer text
make sure you compile this
so
timer text
set text
and we can set this to be whatever this
timer reads obviously you can use format
text and you can make this show minutes
seconds and stuff like that
so we have our timer so we can do format
text
so format text
we can have minutes
colon seconds
something like this
so make this
in curly braces
and our timer by 60 is going to be our
minutes
and our timer mod 60 is going to be
seconds
however we also have one more parameter
which we need to take care of is if this
value is less than 10 we want to append
a 0 at the start
so divide so rather convert this to a
string first
so
to string
and once we have the string we can check
if this is actually less than 10
and if it is less than 10
you can use a select instead so select
so if it is true and if it's false
we need separate things
so if this is going to be greater than
10 which means this is going to be false
so we directly want to print that out
but let's say this is less than 10 we
want to append a 0 here so append
type in 0 and then we want to print the
seconds
so some simple logic like this
now we can go ahead and test this out
and if you were to look at the top right
hand corner it does not update because
we have to set the game State as well
so if I just select BP underscore game
State over here
and if I go ahead and press play
this should technically work but it's
not
so let's have a look
under our BP games that we have our
black controller and we are actually not
calling the update function so update
timer
now this function should work as normal
so the timer is going to be the value
which we get over here
and on begin play we can just set the
timer to zero so we'll just call the
update timer function once
I go ahead and press play
as you can see our timer works and it
increments every second
and if we just give it a little bit of
time so we have a runtime error here
we'll take care of that
so it says assessment trying to read
property HUD
this so this error is in apply
controller the reason is uh when the
game state is actually created the
player controller isn't actually yet
created
so that's the reason why or rather the
player controller is created too but the
HUD does not get created
so once this begin place called our
heart is created so a simple fix for
this is to get a validated get
and if it is valid we are going to set
this text and we shouldn't get any
errors now
anyways as soon as we create this HUD we
can go ahead and update the timer
oops update time
and we can set it to zero
for a timer variable we can actually set
it to some higher value right now so
that we go ahead and test out the
minutes part of it so let's just set
this to something 65 it should start at
one minute and five seconds
so one minute and six seconds seven
eight nine ten and our logic works
properly so for stuff like this you
would use the game state
now the game mode is going to drive the
actual logic itself behind your game
functionality
but let's say you wanted to access all
the players information
you would do that through the player
State class
so I'll just be vague about it and if
you right click in your game State and
type get layer array
you can actually get an array of player
States so you can actually Loop through
this in fact
and we can get stuff like the player
name so get player name
and for multiplayer games you can get
the unique net ID
so for these things basically any
details which all players need to have
access of at all points of time those
are the things which your player state
will hold
so that's about it basically and one
last class that we have left to talk
about which is important is going to be
our game instance then we can head into
more advanced stuff and we can have an
example project created
[Music]
unlike all the other classes which we
spoke about till now the game instance
is kind of special
the game instance behaves very
differently compared to all of these
classes so if I actually just open up my
game mode for example so I will open up
the main menu first things first maps
and our main menu level
and now in my uh game mode
I'll just go ahead and print stuff so
I'll just print
host login
and I'll just type in log out maybe
so log out
and we can also have
event destroyed
event end play
so we'll just go ahead and print stuff
over here as well
so destroyed
I'm just doing this in the game mode but
this could be in any other class
and this is going to be end play
all right so if I go ahead and press
play right now and if I go ahead and
press play as you can see our post login
was called
and as soon as I close it or rather I
should switch levels because
if I close the game the logic isn't
really going to be executed so I'll just
type in open
main menu level
as you can see our logout function was
called
so what I'm trying to say here is that
this game mode class will not persist
between levels
so once you log out this game mode
reference whatever we have is not going
to persist
now forget about the game mode reference
you can't even access it from anywhere
else so let me actually show you guys
using the game instance the special
thing about the game instance is that
when you switch levels
your game instance will still remain the
same when you open up the game an
instance of the game instance is created
so basically an object of type game
instance is instantiated and that is
going to remain the same so go to
blueprint Class Type in game instance
and over here we can name this our game
instance our rgi
anything you want
you could put a BP underscore you can
have a C plus plus class as well but I
don't really find the point in having a
base class for this one
now instead of begin play we'll actually
find events such as event in it
so this is when
your game actually starts so if I go
ahead and print this out if I type in
init
and if I head into my project settings
type in game instance I can actually
change this to bprgi
if I press play and if I press play
again
or rather I'll head into the level and
do it
if I press play you'll notice that
init isn't even printed here in the
console
but it was printed way before everything
else that's why it's way down at the
bottom over there the reason is even
before the viewport was properly spawned
and even before it started logging stuff
the event in it was actually called so
the event and it basically refers to
when you start the game not when you
open up a level or not when you create
something else
now one thing which I want to show you
guys is I'll head into blueprint head
into our game instance I'm going to go
ahead and call the get game mode
function
and I'll go ahead and promote this to a
variable
and let's not name it it's fine
and then what I want to do
is after a while
so let's say I switch from one level to
the other now I'm going to go from this
level to the main menu level
so I'll head into main menu level
and in the level blueprint here I'll
just access the game instance get game
instance
and we can cast it to bprji this can
always be a pure cast because it will
never fail
and over here get
whatever the variable was called I think
it was called new variable zero
and we can go ahead and right click and
convert this to a validated get
we can go ahead and print it
and we can say not valid
and this is going to be if it is valid
so valid
so if I go ahead and I'll actually leave
a bit of a delay here
oops delay
let's say about a second not more than
that
so if I go ahead and head into my level
again and if I press play
as you can see everything works normally
but I'm going to go ahead and type in
open main menu level
and as you can see I get not valid
so what this exactly means is that our
game mode object
which was created when we loaded the
level because game mode objects are
specific to a given level as soon as we
change the level
our BP game mode object was destroyed
and whatever game mode we had over here
in our main menu level so this is none
so it's just going to take game mode
base
so that object was created
however our game instance was still the
same so if I actually store a reference
to the game instance somewhere else that
is still going to be completely valid
throughout our game
so anything that is persistent between
levels you would have it set in the game
instance generally you would handle save
games and stuff like that through the
game instance because even if a player
exits a level your save game logic and
stuff should be able to work
and stuff like settings and all those
things are what you would put inside the
game instance anything related to file
handling will also be put in the game
instance
and many other things regarding
networking uh in general outside the
game is going to be in the game instance
for example a database
you could handle it through the other
classes as well but this is going to be
the safest way since this class is going
to have itself instantiated throughout
the program in in our case the game
and even when you actually exit the game
we have events shutdown rather than
event destroyed or event end play so if
I just type in print string
and if I just exit nothing's really
going to happen because the viewport is
already destroyed by the time the
shutdown is called
so stuff like that let's say you had to
close out some connections or something
you could do that through your event
shutdown let's say you have a database
or something like that just give give an
example
anything that's persistent between
levels you would use the game instance
and one thing which should be obvious by
now but I wanted to mention is each
player in a multiplayer game will have
his own game instance and you cannot put
in-game networking code in this you can
put networking code but whatever's
outside the game if you have any in-game
networking code you there is absolutely
no reason to use the game instance
there is no use of calling rpcs through
the game instance since one player's
game instance is in nowhere related to
the other players game instance so if I
actually start two instances of the game
let's say I have two players
even though they may be connected
your game instances will be different so
this player will have a different game
instance unlike the game State or the
game mode where it's going to be common
for one game so let's say two players
are connected both of them will have one
game modern game stat in common which
will be created on the server but in a
game like this game instances will not
be the same so I should have done listen
server or client so Standalone in
Standalone even game mode game State and
classes like that will be different
because in Standalone you are not
actually connected
but in any case your game instances are
never associated with each other
[Music]
so with all the knowledge that you have
now you should be able to create an
entirely complete single player game in
Unreal Engine 5. of course you will need
to refer the documentation at times at
times you will need to mess around with
stuff but this much of knowledge should
be enough for you to create a complete
Game completely functional game using
all of unreal score features however I
am aware that I didn't touch upon
particle effects and audio that sounds
uh we will take a look at that when we
actually create a practical game I am
not a VFX artist nor am a sound design
personally so that's the reason I didn't
touch over them but we will go over some
resources which you can use and I'll
just talk about what I do to actually
get hands on those resources
now that's done we can go ahead and
start talking about plugins until now we
just implemented plugins which were
there in the marketplace or if you have
a plugin from GitHub or something you
would download it and maybe just paste
it inside your project so if I had in
here you just create a plugins folder
and paste that in there that's simple
but what if you wanted to create your
own plugin if you wanted to do that and
this topic is very less discussed so not
many people actually talk about this
stuff so you're in luck because we are
talking about this in detail now
so head into plugins click on ADD and
you see many options now we won't be
worrying about the editor plugins those
are for more advanced users and if you
are in a state where you're creating
editor plugins I really don't know what
is the reason for you to watch this
course so we won't be touching upon this
we'll be looking at third party
libraries later on we'll be looking at
blank content only in Blueprint library
now blueprint library is
self-explanatory it'll just contain a
blueprint function Library let's say you
wanted some functions for a vector or
something maybe you are implementing
another data structure for which you
want functions
you could have a blueprint Library
and content only is basically the type
of plugin where you know you'd have
models and stuff like that without any
code basically
but the one which we'll be doing is
blank and just give an author name in my
case I'll give gaming and description
this is my first plugin
well it's not but just for the sake of
giving a description and let's call this
one
test plugin
and go ahead and create it
so the plugin has been created and we
have Visual Studio open however before
we actually start working on it I want
to touch upon one topic that is the
build.cs file basically everything you
have in the engine is divided into
modules so the core functionality of the
engine is like core choreo object and
engine
so now that you have actually created
your plugin your plugin as well will
have a build.cs file if actually open
the folder over there so plugins test
plugin and if I head into Source test
plugin I have a build.cs file here and I
have content binary stuff like that
so what this basically is is this plugin
itself is actually a modulant in itself
so if I want to use this plugin in C
plus plus let's say I should go ahead
and include that module so I can do that
by typing in a comma and we can type in
test plugin
this concept will be more clear once we
actually Implement a third-party
libraries when we Implement a
third-party Library you actually have a
separate module for the library as well
as your plugin as a whole basically a
plugin acts as a wrapper so that it can
interface with Unreal Engine
because unreal standard API does differ
a little bit compared to your standard C
plus plus what you do generally so you'd
use the plugin as sort of a wrapper to
you know interconvert types so let's say
you wanted to convert all the STD
strings into s f strings which is there
in unreal so stuff like that so you
would have the plugin as a wrapper and
you would interface that uh through the
plugin inside the engine
so let's actually take a look at our
plugin now now that we have a basic idea
of build.cs
in our editor we already have our test
plugin content folder open
we can work with this normally but
anything we created uh inside here will
be actually packaged inside our plugin
so for example let's create an actor
class so let's just call it some actor
and whoops
and we can make it do something let's
say
so for example let's say we have some
logic so
let's say every frame it just prints out
something obviously you would have some
more practical logic in here
so let me go ahead and type something so
let's say
our
actor is ticking
something like that
and we could go ahead and have C plus
plus classes as well
so over here under Tools you can create
new C plus class I'm just showing you
guys how to do it because we did go over
the blueprint itself so you know how to
work with blueprint
it's just that you're creating it inside
this directory and I'll show you guys
how to reuse it in another project
so head into tools new C plus plus class
just like how we would let's say you
wanted to create an interface
so I just took an example
and instead of my interface we can call
this one
R plugin interface
and instead of beginner course you can
type in test plugin because this is a
separate module in itself and now if I
go ahead and create the class
you would see that under our source or
rather under our plugins folder so I'll
just reload the solution under a plugins
folder under the source folder now you
should be able to see our interface
so now you can work with this just like
how we would
with another file
so this is how you would actually go
about doing it
so now if I just go ahead and close this
and rather I'll just close the editor
and remember guys make sure your plugin
is enabled here if you are not able to
see it in the editor make sure you
enable this
so what you can do is first of all let's
see if it actually builds successfully
so we'll just create a new function
so it's going to be a virtual function
because we want to override so virtual
void
test function
and we can go ahead and leave it as is
we don't really require a default
implementation but we will have one
anyways so right click quick actions and
create
a default implementation
and now we should be able to implement
this interface so let's make this a u
function so you function
your function
and just to make our job a little bit
easier we'll just make it a blueprint
implementable event
so that we can actually just give the
logic in Blueprint itself
so this works and now if I just go ahead
and build this you should see that both
this plugin as well as our whole project
will
be actually built so it says blueprint
implementable events in interfaces must
not be declared virtual let's just fix
that
and now it should build as is
just make sure you don't have a
definition here because it will look for
the definition in Blueprint
now let's say I wanted to use this in
another project this is how you would go
about doing this so open up your editor
head into the plugin section again and
where you have your plugin over here
under project other
click on package just select a random
folder I'll just select my documents for
example
and go ahead and package the plugin
it will take a little bit of time
but once that's done you should be able
to implement that in another project so
meanwhile while this is actually
compiling we can go ahead and create
another project so open up your epic
games launcher
so our packaging is actually complete
before the launcher loaded up so you can
actually check it in our documents
folder so head into test test plugin and
you should be able to use this in your
projects and I'll show you guys how to
do that
so just ignore that head into Library
let's actually just launch the engine as
is
and over here we can go ahead and just
create a new project
so we'll just create a blank project
blank with nothing I'll just create
blueprint
and for the project name
uh okay we do have a C plus plus class
so it might actually want to rebuild
stuff once again so anyways what we'll
do is we can
create a C plus plus project call this
one
plugin test
and we can go ahead and create it
so I'll show you guys how to implement
it both in Blueprint and C plus
anyways now that we are actually in the
process of creating it
so it should take a while but eventually
once the project is opened up
we should be able to import the plugin
just like that and I'll show you guys
what steps you need to take in order to
actually get this in the plugins list
now our project has been created so we
are in a blank level just we'll just go
ahead and create a new map and let's
just call this one some level
open it up
save it
and make this the default project
settings
maps and modes make this the default
so that should be good and if you open
up your Visual Studio which we will open
later we'll close this up
and close the editor as well and
beginner course will just minimize that
for now
if I head into my file explorer what I
can do is I can copy this over
and where I have my other project so I
believe I created it under unreal
project so plug and test
and what you want to do is you want to
create a new folder called plugins
and paste this over there
now what I want you guys to do is right
click generate Visual Studio project
files
so this is actually going to integrate
it and once you're done with that if you
want to use the plugin content in C plus
all you have to do is head into source
plug-in test and under plugin test
build.cs
we don't actually need to come here
actually this is for the plugin what's
the plugin using so what you have to do
is head into your plugin test rather I
mean the project head into Source plugin
test build.cs
and over here
so I meant I meant to come here so over
here what I want you guys to do is
where we have our modules I want you
guys to add test plugin
uh just don't get confused plug-in test
is our unreal project name and test
plugin is our plugin name
and now I'll show you guys how to
implement it so we can go ahead and
build this once again
so we'll close everything up
and we'll just generate the visual
studio project files once again
and we'll close our beginner course
we'll open it up and we'll just create
one C plus plus class and maybe a
blueprint class
so we'll do blueprint first since we are
opening the editor anyways
so we have some level and if we actually
go ahead and create something so let me
just create an actor if I head into all
classes
and if I type in
so I'm not sure what I called it so we
can head into plugins and check test
plugin content some actor so
some actor as you can see we get some
actor now if you're not getting this it
simply means that you haven't enabled it
in your plugins so under installed other
you should have test plugin
and you should have your author name and
stuff like that
so make sure you have this enabled over
here
and now if I go ahead and drag this in
the world and if I press play as you can
see our code which we had in our actor
is now working in the other project
similarly we can use the interface as
well
so over here under class settings
implemented interfaces we can go ahead
and look for our interface
I think we called it our plugin
interface
and we have our test function which we
can Implement and we can go ahead and
tell
something
so you could just say test function
called
in order to implement this however we
would require C plus plus since we
actually didn't make this blueprint
callable however we can still choose to
edit it in the source order so if I just
head into our source and if I actually
go ahead and edit the CPP file we can
actually rather in the plugins folder
test plugin if I head into the source
folder and edit the CPP file
or rather the dot hatch file and add the
blueprint callable specifier I would
still be able to you know use this over
here but anyways we will implement it in
some class which we create here so I'll
just go ahead and close Visual Studio
here and I'll go ahead and create
something so we can
create a new C plus class of type actor
we are able to implement this but we
can't call it that's the reason we're
actually doing it so we'll just call it
my actor for now
and go ahead and create it
so live coding should do its thing
so our file should in fact open up in a
new window right now
and go ahead
and just don't mind it opened up in a
separate window
and now we can feel free to go ahead and
include our interface
just gone ahead and reopened the
solution file here now inside my actor.h
since we included the module in the
build.cs file we should simply be able
to include r
plugin interface.h
now you should be simply able to inherit
the interface by using public I or my R
plugin interface and now we have
successfully inherited the interface now
the since this was a blueprint
implementable event you can just go
ahead and use it in Blueprint itself and
just to make things a bit convenient for
us we can head into our R plugin
interface.h file under the plugins
folder and we can add in the blueprint
callable flag
so now we can go ahead and actually call
it from the blueprint
so we can go ahead and run a debugger
now so this is how you implement it in C
plus plus
my main intention here was to show how
to include the header file rather than
using the interface that is something
which we already covered
so wait for the editor to load
and once the editor is loaded in what we
can do is we can go ahead and create a
new blueprint class and we can remove
this actor first of all otherwise it'll
keep printing our actor sticking
so go ahead
select actor we'll leave this at new
blueprint one add this
and under the parent class or we could
have done it over there itself
and select my actor
and now again we have our test function
and we can again go ahead and Implement
our event so we can go ahead and print
something let's say
test function called
or we could have gone ahead and
inherited uh my actor instead of some
actor here but then again you would have
to change some other stuff so we'll just
redo this
and now if I go ahead and press play
nothing's gonna happen headed to your
level blueprint and for example just go
ahead and get a reference to it and now
if I just call in test function
test function message this is what we
want
and now if I go ahead and press play you
see we get test function called
so this is basically how you do it guys
so this is basically how you would use a
plugin which you made and implement it
in another project and as you guys saw
you can absolutely feel free to edit the
plugin contents once you have pasted it
in this plugin folder
foreign
libraries now there is one thing to
understand before we actually head into
implementing them and that is that there
are differences between your standard C
plus plus API and the unreal C plus plus
API a very simple example would be the
difference between STD string and F
string so in unreal you use F string
whereas in standard C plus plus you
generally use STD string now
interconverting between them is really
easy so if you want to implement a third
party Library the way you would do it is
you would build your third party library
inside of a plugin so basically you
would put it in a separate folder and I
will show you guys the procedure so
nothing to worry about that
and the the unreal plugin which you will
create will act as a wrapper to kind of
you know interface between the standard
C plus plus and unreal C plus plus API
so the way you do it is again create
create a new plugin first
select this third party Library template
because
it has most of the important things that
you would need in order to actually set
it up so again I'll just put gaming for
the author and I'll just call it some
third party Library
Library plugin
and over here we can just call this one
TPL underscore Plugin or something like
that
so third party Library plugin so go
ahead and create it
so now this dialog box should appear
over here a rather message box and we'll
just click open or okay
so basically that was just some code
which was written in the example Library
now over here we shall not be using
their Library so they have actually
provided us with a library which we can
use as a reference so if I add into
plugins TPL plugin Source you see there
are two folders here now third part is
the folder where you'll have your third
party library and TPL plugin is the
folder where you would you know have
your plugin content
and anything uh under this folder would
be edited in your project solution file
and I'll show you guys what I mean
so right now heading to third party
third party
plug-in live plug-in Library so what we
can do is over here as you can see there
is an example Library
now whichever file says example Library
dot something that is basically your
actual third party Library so in order
to implement our own third party Library
we can go ahead and delete whatever they
have put over here
so we don't need any of this
so this is just an example and what they
have done is they've used a dll but I'll
be showing you guys how to implement a
static library and a dll separately so
we'll do a static one first so I'll just
go ahead and delete all of this
now what we are left with is a blank uh
folder with just the build.cs file so
what you want to do now is open up
visual studio
and over here you can go ahead and
create a new project
of type static Library
and click next
and we'll just call this
I don't know
test third party library or something
so test third party liability
so we'll create it under a g
repositories or rather we'll just select
our solution folder
so we'll go ahead and select our
beginner course
head into
the plugins folder PPL plugin Source
third party third part TPL plugin
Library select this folder and what we
can do here is we can check Place
solution and project in the same
directory so we would have all those
project files as they appeared in the
example so go ahead and press create
now you should see that our library is
actually created
so if I go ahead and open up
this folder over here
as you see this folder has been created
it's not necessary that you have it over
here
so you can just go ahead cut this and
paste this over here
and you can go ahead and delete this
folder
so it's open in visual studio so I'll
just close everything
so I'll just save it
so we can just cut this and paste it
over here so we shouldn't have opened
that so we'll just replace it as of now
nothing should happen
now once you're done with this we can
open up our build.cs file
and over here you would notice that we
have a bunch of stuff which you
seriously which I seriously don't expect
you to understand uh basically these are
for Linux and Mac so you can just go
ahead and delete this I'm not going to
be showing how to work with DOT so files
and stuff so I'm not really a Linux guy
so we'll just be working with our
Windows Library
so we'll not do the dll now so I'll just
comment this out
we'll do the dll a bit later and what
this is is this is basically our
library directory
and the library file itself
now example library.lib was the file
which they had created so whatever
example Library they had
that file was named example library.lib
but ours isn't yet here so we can just
go ahead and add in some sample code so
that we can actually create it
so head in here
change the configuration to release
first things first
and head into source files add a new
item
and over here you can go ahead and
create a DOT hatch file because we will
need some sort of a header to include it
so we can just type in test class we'll
just create a class
so testclass.h
maybe you can create some static method
inside
and over here uh we can actually move
this over to the header file section
right click on source file add new item
head of source CPP file and we can call
this one
testclass.cpp
and once both of these files are open
over here we can just start writing our
class so we can call this test class
and under the public section we can
simply have a method so under public
and under private we can have a string
variable so STD
string
and we need to include string obviously
so hash include
string
so we have our STD string we'll just
create a variable called
maybe test string
and we can write a Constructor here to
just initialize it so what we can do is
we can go ahead and create
test class
and write the definition for the
Constructor the reason I'm not doing it
in line over here is because I want to
show you guys that the lib file is
actually doing something so if we have
the definition right here so we wouldn't
really need the library file
now I can go ahead and create the
definition for it
and what we can do now is under this
we can go ahead and just
initialize our string so we can say test
string equals
this is some test string
doesn't really matter what you put in
there and we can just have a method so
we can have STD
string
get name maybe
now this is going to return that string
basically
so we can go ahead and test that so we
can go ahead and return test string
now this should be about it for this
so before you go ahead and build it just
set up this pch.h file and stuff so go
ahead over here instead of test class
dot head just include this pch.h
and what you would want to do is you
would want to come here and just include
your test class dot Edge over here so
now this should compile so if I go ahead
and press build
make sure it's in release configuration
and it should work so now if you were to
head into your TPL plugin Library folder
now under this x64 folder which has been
created you should find your dot lib
file don't worry about all these other
files just go ahead and copy this file
name which will be the same as your
library files name I mean your libraries
name
so test third partylibrary.lib that is
the file which we want to include
so now that we are done with this now we
should in theory be able to wrap this
using our TPL plugin now this is
actually the code for our unreal plugin
now inside this we'll actually be
writing some code in order to just wrap
this class whatever we wrote over there
so go ahead and head into your beginner
course solution
that is your main project solution
and now if you head into your test
plugin
or rather the one which you created now
so TPL plugin source TPL plugin
and we should be able to actually work
with this so we'll just do it inside
this header file uh as I showed you for
the previous plugin if you want to add
in more files and stuff you can do it
through the project or we can actually
do that actually since we have our
solution open anyways I mean our unreal
project
so over here we can go ahead into tools
add a new C plus plus class we don't
really require an actor so we'll create
an object so object
create it and we'll call this one
wrapper object
and this will just be under my TPL
plugin
so we can close our solution since it
will open it up once again and create
the class
now if you were to open up your solution
you should see a wrapper object.cpp and
stuff and one more thing uh this is
something which you really don't need
so now you can just feel free to head
into this function here and just delete
all this code and over here as well you
can go ahead and just delete this make
sure you just have the functions and for
this one basically we don't have our
example library.h we instead have our
test class.h
so this will work we don't need it here
so we aren't going to use it so you can
just leave the rest of it as is
and now if we were to continue now
but now if I were to go ahead and build
this so if I just go ahead and hit build
now wait for it and now you notice you
actually get errors even though you
didn't have any code
uh the reason is
well we don't actually have our uobject
module if you get any errors like this
cannot open include file and it's
something like this basically it's the
same thing you haven't included the
module so what you have to do is head
into your
uh TPL plugin
undersource you should find your TPL
plugin build.cs file and if you were to
recall your main build.cs file that is
your projects build.cs file so if I head
into Source begin a course beginner
course build.cs you see there is a
module known as score you object and
this isn't there in the TPL plugin
build.cs so I'll just go ahead and
include that and now it should build
successfully so if I just click on build
now this should build with absolutely no
problems
so now we can go about implementing a
wrapper object basically we are trying
to get our test class to work with our
actual code here
so I'll just do it under the public
section so whenever this uh your object
that is your wrapper object will be
instantiated I want our actual
third-party Library object to be
instantiated as well so we can go ahead
and type in test class
class
obj
equals we had a default Constructor so
we'll just call that and the reason we
get errors is because we haven't
included the header so we can get TPL
plugin
Library so Library
and we call it testclass.h
now we shouldn't get that error now we
should be able to create our object and
now we can go about writing our
functions for it so the only difference
in the main with the standard C plus
plus API and unreals API in our example
is that we used STD string over there
but we want to use F string so we can
write a u function for it so your
function we can just call it get name
and the return type is going to be F
string of course
and we can create a definition for it
create a definition
open it up and inside the F string
Constructor we can get our object obj
dot get name Dot cstr
so C Str
so this is how we can just convert it
now this is something related to the
conversion you can just look into the
documentation or the Forum so this is
how we would go about converting it and
we'll make this one blueprint callable
as well just so that we can test it in
Blueprint are now successfully we have
translated our standard C plus plus
function in our third party library and
this is now usable in unreal so if I
just go ahead and run a debugger here
inside our project now we can ignore
this and we can head into content and
we'll just do it under blueprints go
ahead create a new blueprint class and
this will be of type wrapper object
so we don't find it and we forgot to
make this blueprint table once again no
issues we can make this blueprint table
and you can make it blueprint type as
well if you wish so we can go ahead and
restart the editor now
and now under content blueprints if I
right click create a blueprint class and
type in wrapper object we should get a
wrapper object
and we can go ahead and just call it BP
underscore wrapper
so this is our wrapper class basically
now if I were to actually go ahead and
call the function we can actually do
that so we'll instantiate the object and
call it so our function was called get
name
oops get name
call function get name Target is wrapper
object and we get a string so we can go
ahead and test this method out so in our
level blueprint we'll just construct an
object so we can ignore this
we can go ahead and construct object
from class
and we can construct our wrapper object
so BP wrapper
we didn't really need it to be honest
but anyways we can go ahead and call the
function get name
once it's successfully constructed
and we can print strings so that we can
check if it works
so now if I go ahead and press play
as you would see I get this is some test
string
and this is exactly what we put in our
third party Library so if I head into
third party
testclass dot CPP
as you can see we had our STD string and
we actually called this method through
our wrapper class
so this is basically how you implement a
third-party static Library
[Music]
so now let's get to dlls now working
with dlls is going to be a little more
tedious and if you were to take my
opinion in Unreal Engine at least it's
really not worth the hassle to work with
dlls I always prefer just working with
you know static libraries or any unreal
native plugins but anyways I'll just
show you guys with the example itself
the procedure is the same head into
plugins
click on ADD third-party library and
we'll just call this gamium and plugin
name let's just call it dll test
so we're going to create the plugin and
it should take us into Visual Studio
so we get this message box here
so which is from uh the functions given
in the dll so
just head into your solution Explorer
add under your plugins
you should find a dll test plugin
and if you open up your
third party folder you should be able to
see the code
now we'll just be modifying it in here
so we'll just call a function
so example Library function let's just
head into the definition this is
creating a message box
similarly we could just have our own
function the important bit over here is
the export part so basically you have
this macro which is going to export the
function now
the usage of classes isn't really
covered here so I'm just going to do
that instead of writing my own function
obviously you can implement the same
thing with your own dll but remember uh
the changes to the build.cs files which
you have to make so under plugins dll
test
Source dll test or other third party dll
test library and in this build.cs file
again you will probably have to change a
few parts you can remove this if you are
working on your windows
so this is over here just change the
file name to whatever your dll is
and over here for the lib file as well
just make sure you change it to whatever
your file name is even here as well just
do those changes and you should be good
to go and the addition of modules will
still remain the same so you will still
have to include choreo object and stuff
we'll do that so not to worry
so if you want to actually export a
class
you would have to do it right here in
the dot hatch file you can have the
definition separately in the CPP file
but I'll show you guys how to actually
do it so the way you do it for classes
is a bit different for functions you can
follow this example and move on
but over here let's say I want a class
so I can do example Library export now I
am assuming we are developing for
Windows so I'll just go ahead and delete
all these alifs
so I won't be having any of that so I'll
only have the macro declared even over
here as well so I I'll just go ahead and
remove all of this and I'm just assuming
that everything is
for Windows
so with that assumption let's continue
now if you want a class we can go ahead
and declare it and one more thing in
your dot h file as well make sure you
just have this macro
if you want to work with class if you're
working only with functions you don't
really require
so now what you want to do is let's just
call this one test class
and over here we can go ahead and have
some methods
so let's say in
get num or something and we can have a
variable as well so under private
we can have in Num
and for this we can go ahead and provide
a definition for it
and one more thing for each definitions
so for your class definition here make
sure you put in export
for methods you would put in import here
and export in the definition but since
your class definition is here itself
make sure you have example Library
export
or whatever your library name is
and we can just go ahead and return num
so what we can do is we can write uh
we can just say we can just set this to
some value
what we can do here is we can write a
Constructor actually
so this class is called test class
and we'll just write it in line over
here what we can do is num equals
can grab in a random number
between 0 and 99. so this should work as
expected and then I'll get num function
should work as well
now once you are done with this our
dlls example Library should work
so what we can do is we can go ahead and
before building actually we can create a
new file
so head into your editor
and we can close the solution for now we
can build it and close it
so we have live coding enabled just
ignore that so build it
so this should build successfully
now if I just head back into my project
beginner course
and if I head into my you project file
here
once it loads up you would see the
message box as is if you don't want that
I'll just show you guys how to disable
that if you don't want the message box
head into your dll test third party
third party library or whatever or
rather Source dll test
private
dlltest.cpp this is the file where it's
actually
given the function definition so just go
ahead open that and edit the file to
remove the function definition
so let it open up
and over here what you would want to do
is you would want to remove this
function definition
so you can remove this and then the
message box isn't going to pop up you
can remove this as well
but that's not going to be called unless
it fails so not to worry
and even this path as well so if you do
require to change it you will have to
change it if you are implementing your
own make sure you account for all of
this
so heading back go to tools you see plus
plus class all classes object will go
ahead and just or we can do actor just
to keep things a little more interesting
so we can go ahead and create an actor
click on next my actor make it under dll
test and we can go ahead and create the
class
so this should open up our solution file
and
don't mind if live coding fails we'll
just close and reopen that not to worry
we can go ahead and open the solution
file once again so we'll go ahead and
close this
and once the solution is open we should
be able to go ahead and find our file
here so under dll test
private
dlltest.cpp or rather myactor.cpp and we
should find all our function definitions
and not to worry if you get so many
errors it's just to do with the build.cs
file once again it's kind of dumb but
it's something which you have to deal
with
so over here make sure you include
engine
and make sure you include core view
object
make sure you have these two modules if
you want to access gizmet and stuff like
that you will need engine
if you want to access your your object
type you'll need core your object so
if you don't have an idea of what
contains what you can go ahead and have
a look at the engine module in the
documentation everything is given over
there otherwise you could just follow
along
so head into now it will build
intellisens isn't refreshed yet
so head into your myactor.h and we can
go ahead and include a header so you can
go hash include
dll underscore test Library
and our header is called example
library.h of course if you have your own
header that's going to replace this
and we shouldn't get any sort of errors
here
and over here we can just write a
function we'll just do it in line so you
function make this one blueprint
callable to make things simple so
blueprint
callable and we can call this one
void
run dll function
so I'm not really bothered about the
name too much
and now what I can do is I can go ahead
and write a definition for it we'll just
do it over here
so from our dll we can go ahead and grab
it so the function which we had
was called
get num so we can go ahead and
instantiate an object to that class so
our class was called test class
just call it obj
and we can go ahead and call the
function
we'll do it in the next line
and obj Dot get num we can go ahead and
print this by typing in you Kismet
system Library
print string
and we can just pass in at this pointer
and we can do F string
so it's an integer so from int
and this should be good to go
now what we can do is we can include
Kismet because we don't have the print
string function here so hash include
Kismet
Kismet system Library dot h
now this should build successfully
assuming we haven't made any mistakes
here
now it's giving us an error it says test
class class type redefinition a simple
fix would be just to do pragma once so
pragma once and this should build now
with no problems now we can go ahead and
open up the editor
so once we open it up
we won't get the message box now because
we had disabled that
and over here if we just head into a
level blueprint for example and make
sure under the play mode just change
this to Standalone because we had it set
to multiply we can go ahead and
construct an object from class
or rather we can do spawn actors and
sets an actor so my actor
my actor is what it was called
and we can just have a default transform
it doesn't really have anything and from
this we can go ahead and I'm not sure
what the function was called
so let me just have a look
so our function in my actor was called
run dll function so I can go ahead and
call that
so run
dll function
so in theory we should get stuff printed
over here but this will probably not
work now because we haven't actually
compiled our library itself which is
kind of stupid so heading to dll test
so third party dll test Library example
Library dot solution
and now just click ok
and now what you would want to do over
here is go ahead and select a release
configuration
and go ahead and build it
oh and yeah make sure you close the
editor when doing it that was the error
which we got right there now if you were
to go ahead and open up your beginner
course view project
once that's loaded in now we should be
able to call the function and it should
work as expected so in your level
blueprint where you called it run dll
function and we can go ahead and click
on selected viewport and as you can see
we got 95 if I go ahead and play we get
and we keep getting random numbers every
time so our dll actually worked but
if you do want to implement your own it
is going to be a little more complicated
than this even with just including the
one which was provided to us with unreal
it was a big hassle so make sure you
guys uh avoid using dlls I prefer using
static libraries or I restrict myself to
those for unreal at least
so that's it I guess about third party
libraries we can go ahead and talk about
multiplayer now it's going to get fun
guys
[Music]
now let's talk about networking in
Unreal Engine so networking basically in
unreal revolves around start topology
basically your server client model so
basically you have one player or a
dedicated machine which acts as a host
which we call the server and you have
all the other players which are clients
now there are two types of servers in
Unreal Engine one is a lesson server and
another one is a dedicated server in a
lesson server the server itself acts as
a client as well as the server that is
the host whereas in a dedicated server
the server only acts as a host and does
not have a player controller so these
are the two types of servers and
basically any data that has to be passed
through Network as you can see in this
diagram here there is no connection
there is no direct connection between
two clients always if data has to be
passed from client 1 to client 2 or vice
versa it has to be routed through the
server so that is one thing to note when
it comes to networking in Unreal Engine
now there are many questions which might
arise regarding the efficiency of this
and stuff but most games these days work
based on this principle and it is in
fact very robustly implemented and we
will be talking about all the features
of unreal networking soon
[Music]
I have brought up my main menu level
here and I just want to demonstrate how
you are going to join two Standalone
games that is two games on separate
computers into one so if you aren't
familiar net mode will basically let you
choose between the types of servers
which I talked about play as client is
your dedicated server basically and play
as listen server is going to be a server
which is also a player along with the
other clients Place Standalone will
basically mean two separate games and
that's what we will be doing
now what if you wanted to connect
between these two
so we'll be using the game instance for
it so open up your BP game instance now
I am recording this a little bit later
so that's the reason you may see a few
things which you haven't seen so BP rgi
and we can just set up a couple of
custom events we'll first of all delete
all of this we don't need this
so I'm not sure we may have broken some
reference
doesn't matter so
we'll just go ahead and fix that
so we'll just delete that
and now if I head into rgi and I'll
create a custom event now basically
connecting to a single game is handled
by something known as a session
so every time your players are connected
unreal actually has something known as a
session stored internally we aren't
going to be diving into the C plus plus
part of this we'll just be doing this in
Blueprint but please note that if you
want finer control over these properties
you would want to work with C plus plus
so session is basically what is going to
allow your players to connect
so let's go ahead and create a session
so what we can do is we can do something
like create
Lobby would be inappropriate I'll just
call this one create session
and we'll go ahead and type in create
session
and as you see there is an async task
over here
and if you guys aren't familiar with
this clock symbol and a node like this
this is an async task and public
connections we'll just set that to two
for example so to players and player
controller this is for lesson servers if
you have a dedicated server you don't
have to pass in the player controller
but in our case we are passing it in so
we are going to use the function get
player controller
and then use Lan is set to false you
could do it if you wish and upon success
what you can do is you can go ahead and
load a level so open level
and we can go ahead and open our
beginner course level
all right
and then what we can do is we can go
ahead and create a function
to join
join session
all right I would call this one create
match
so that it sounds a little more familiar
join match
so what we can do is we can first of all
find sessions
so type in find sessions
these are the only few functions which
are there in this Library so that's the
reason I'm not really going over them
that much so we can get the player
controller and what we can do is Max
results you can just set it to something
like 100
and we're going to check if it's a
failure or if it's a success so what we
can do is first of all we can get the
length
so if it's a failure we're just going to
print something
so we could say
failed
to join a match
and what we can do is we can get the
length
and if it is greater than zero
we'll go ahead and just join the first
session obviously you can have your own
logic here
so each session is going to be one
hosted game basically so let's say there
are three uh three members in this array
or three elements in this array what it
basically means is there are three
people hosting a match right now that's
what it means
so now what I can do is I can grab the
results
and I can get a copy of the first one
if the length is greater than 0 and I
can go ahead and type in join session
all right and here we'll again need to
pass in the player controller and note
whoops
and note that you can only run these
session functions either on the player
controller or in the game instance you
cannot run them on other blueprints it
is simply going to fail
now once that's done
let's say we have no sessions we can go
ahead and create a match so create match
and on success we don't need to do
anything engine will handle it for us
over here you can have something like a
progress bar or something until on
success is called you could probably
have some throbber or something like
that to show that it's loading same over
here
so this should be good
and something very simple which you
could do is inside the main menu
so on clicked
what I can do is instead of opening it I
can grab a reference to my game instance
so I can type in get game instance which
is a static function and I can cast it
to BP rgi this will always succeed I'll
just cast it over here I'm not going to
bother storing a reference to it as of
now
and I can go ahead and or actually I'll
just do it the right way so I'll just
call this one main GI you could call it
anything
just a reference to our game instance
and once we have that we can go ahead
and use it and we can go ahead and join
match so join match
now that that's done if I go ahead and
press play if I go ahead and press play
here
as you can see nothing is really
happening but after a while we go ahead
and join the session basically we load
up the map
now now that we have actually created a
session and if I press play on the other
game here and if I just wait for a while
so you would want to disable the input
during this time but anyways for now
we'll just not do anything you would see
that you actually don't join the session
the reason is you actually need to be
listening for incoming Connections in
order to actually be able to join the
game and I'll show you guys how to do
that
over here where you have open level make
sure you just put in listen under the
options
so make sure you do that before you
actually do it and one more thing plane
editor is crashing my game for some
reason so I'm just going to go ahead and
I'm going to run this Standalone so
Standalone game and Standalone so play
Standalone and replace this as a
standalone game so I'm not really sure
why the issue is happening but this is
one way I can test it so if I press play
on one of them and if I go ahead and
wait
so we should land inside a session
as expected we are in the level and we
are able to do stuff
now I'll just go ahead and click on play
here
in theory if everything is set we should
in theory land in the same map so
as you can see post login was called on
the server and if I were to notice my
client has successfully connected over
here
so as you can see I'm able to play the
game like this
so this is basically how you connect two
clients now let's actually talk about
how to set up stuff in multiplayer guys
[Music]
okay then so if we want to work with
multiplayer what we can go ahead and do
is we'll start with a new level because
if I go ahead and press play with two
players here
and
if I actually close the game you see
we'll get a few runtime errors now this
is mostly because our code isn't really
set up for multiplayer and you will soon
understand why
so basically now what I want you guys to
do is head into your Maps folder create
a new level and we'll call this one
multiplayer testing
so go ahead and open it up
so this should be a blank level
so I'll just grab in a sky
and grab in a directional light here
and we should have everything set up
and maybe if you want we could have fog
and we can just create a simple
landscape
so head into your mode selection
and we can go ahead and create it
so I'll just do a little bit of noise so
that we have a starting point so that we
have some sort of
a workable landscape
so increase the brush size
so the strength is a little too much
point of I should be fine
so let me just go back
okay that should be good for us
now what we can do is we can go ahead
and talk about multiplayer
so the main aspects of multiplayer in
unreal are replication and remote
procedural calls
if you are clear with how to use these
two concepts
it's pretty simple to code a multiplayer
game in Unreal Engine it's much more
difficult to do it with general
knowledge of networking but with
unreal's framework it's really very
simple to set up multiplayer
we'll discuss both blueprint and C plus
plus aspects but first the basics
now I want you guys to head into
blueprints
and under here I want you guys to just
select your character and your BPA so I
guess this one is where we had physics
enabled so if we do yep we have physics
enabled so I want you guys to just show
the problem with this running
multiplayer in general so I'll just go
ahead and drag this in
and
what I can do now
is
I can go ahead and grab a few player
starts here so I'll grab one here grab
another here
and make sure they're all facing the
same direction
so what I can do is I can make this one
90.
so they're all facing towards this ball
right there
and now what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to change the world settings to use our
BP game mode
and for the player controller we can
ignore that we'll still get the runtime
errors
so what we can do is we can remove this
logic so we'll forget about the HUD for
now and if I go ahead and press play
now you see the ball has fallen down and
it's rolling down the hill over there
and as you can see I kicked the ball
but if you were to notice
the ball is in a completely different
position
so the ball is over there for me
and if I actually head near the ball
here
you'll see that I am not actually going
near the ball on my other screen so if I
actually turn around
my character is somewhere there and my
ball is somewhere over there
so as you can see both of these are not
in sync now this is something related to
the widget nothing much to worry about
so basically what I'm trying to say is
that these two games which are running
on separate windows are not in sync
but you notice one thing that your
characters are in sync so for example if
I go ahead and run forward
and if I go ahead and run forward over
there and if I actually look up you
would see that my characters are in sync
it's just that the physics object over
there is not in sync
so the reason this is happening is
because in our character if you head
into your class defaults and head into
the replication tab you see that these
two flags called replicate movement and
replicates are enabled
basically this is unreal's way of
telling us that or rather asking us
whether we want this particular class to
be in sync with all players when
instantiated so let's say we instantiate
a BP character it will always be in sync
obviously there are conditions you have
to instantiate it on the server we'll
talk about servers and clients soon
so let's head into our actor and try to
fix it so head into your class defaults
and let's try enabling replicate
movement and replicates if I compile and
if I go ahead and press play
as you can see now the ball is rolling
down it's near me and as you can see
this seems to be in sync
if I go ahead and block this
as you can see this is almost completely
in sync
now uh one of my characters flying is
due to the movement mode just ignore
that but
as far as I can see everything is in
sync
so this is basically how you get stuff
to go in sync in a network game in
unreal this is the most basic aspect of
it
you might see that there are a few more
Flags here such as always relevant call
pre-replication Net load on client most
of these aren't really important we'll
just talk a little bit about net curve
distance squared and net dormancy and
stuff but most of the times 9 out of 10
times you'll only mess with replicates
and replicate movement sometimes you may
need your actor to be always relevant
let's say it's something important to
your gameplay you will have always
relevant enabled
so once that said let's also talk about
net priority basically the higher the
value the more priority is given for
this to be updated so let's say you have
thousands of actors and your bandwidth
is insufficient to actually update all
the actors the ones with higher
priorities will be updated first
basically
so now that we know the basics of
replication
[Music]
let's start syncing up some variables
so if I head into my actor
and if I go ahead and create a variable
so we have some float already
and what we'll do is on begin play
we'll go ahead and set this to some
random value
so we'll get random So Random float
and what we can also do is we can go
ahead and print this string
all right
so let's look at what happens
so let's actually delete some of our
other methods here so I guess we had
some stuff in our character
so we'll just stop calling this function
and we'll ignore the spawn actor
and I'm not sure if anything else is
printing something so we'll ignore the
left Mouse Button as well now if I press
play
as you can see we only get our post
login and we have 0.809
and we have 0.43
now clearly this is not what you want
you want them to be in sync
so if you want variables to be in sync
the first thing you'd want to do is you
would want to set this replication tab
to replicate it
now let's go ahead and try that actually
so if I press play
we still get different values
the reason is
even though we set the value we need to
set it on the server and we also need to
wait for the replication cycle to take
place
basically your value doesn't immediately
get replicated instead your value gets
replicated in the next replication cycle
so every once in a while so in our case
if you head into class defaults you see
this net update frequency parameter it's
set to 100. let's say we set it to
something like 10
now this variable will be updated after
approximately 0.1 seconds obviously it
can be less than that but up to 0.1
seconds if I make it 100 it's going to
be up to 0.01 seconds so it's not
instantaneous
remember that these two players what we
play here
they are not running on the same machine
so you cannot expect
the variable to update immediately
so what we can do is we can actually set
some logic to update this
the principle which actually goes into
this is the fact that all your
replicated variables need to be set on
the server so let's go ahead and do that
now just a quick note here the event
begin play which is there
since this actor is replicated each time
one computer out of all the players
will spawn the actor so for each
computer this begin play will be called
so if you didn't get what I mean if I
actually simply go ahead and print a
string so if I go ahead and type in
print
and if I print hello and if I press play
you would notice that the server and the
client print hello
what that basically means is as soon as
the client logged in that is when the
client entered the game this actor was
born on the client and begin play was
called both on the server as well as the
client
so what we can do is we can check if we
are on the server so we can type in a
server
and we can do a simple if check
if we are the server we can go ahead and
set this value
so we can go ahead and do that and if we
are not the server we can go ahead and
print it
so one more thing we can do is okay this
is going to work let's just do it so we
can go ahead and print some float
and go ahead and press play
as you can see the values are the same
in case you guys have any doubts
regarding that you can go ahead and plug
this in directly
like this
if I press play Let's see 0.718 0.718
the value is the same so basically all
your replicated variables need to be set
on the server that's the first thing now
what if you wanted a client to set the
value so your client cannot actually set
the value however oh and just another
thing this logic is going to work for
three players as well so if I go ahead
and do this for three players
so as you can see all three players have
the same value initialize so that's
going to work as well okay anyways
getting back so let's say
now instead of this we wanted a client
to actually set the value for us
for all the players
so the way you do that is through a
remote procedural call
[Music]
so replicating variables this is about
it there's really nothing much to it so
this is basically how you replicate
variables I will get to rep notify
so let's say you wanted to call a
function when a variable has been
replicated
instead of replicated you can check this
rep notify option so then what's going
to happen is when the value of the
variable is set this function will
actually be called on all the clients so
if I go ahead and play
Let's see we get a Hello as well along
with that
so we can just type in rep notify
so we get whatever string we put over
there so basically that basically shows
that our replication logic is working
that's pretty much it
we can have any other functionality for
example let's say you have rep notify on
a health variable you can update the
health bar so something simple like that
now let's go ahead and run this logic
from the client so let's say we set this
on the client and we already saw that
that does not really work that well
so what you have to do is you have to
use a concept known as a remote
procedural calls basically they're just
custom events meant for multiplayer in
Blueprint so type in custom event
and we'll call this one
set
some float some float is the variable
name so we just made a setup for it
under this replicates tab set this
to run on server
now what this is going to do is this is
going to ensure that this runs on the
server
so if you call this from an owning
client
now we will get to the problem with it
and if we run it from an owning client
we are going to be able to call this on
the server so reliable basically means
you want it to run in order so let's say
you run two rpcs so it's going to run in
the same order if it's reliable if it's
not reliable the order may change since
it's networked it's not instantaneous
so stuff like that can happen so now
I'll just make this reliable I'll just
go ahead and print a string and I'll
call this one server RPC
so now what we can do is we can go ahead
and we'll not do this set with notify
we can go ahead and instead of that we
can call our set sum float
and let's see if we get anything printed
now something weird happens
as you can see
we are not able to actually call this
RPC if I were to actually play this and
if I open up the output log here as you
see it says warning unit driver process
remote function no earning connection
for actor BPA C1 this is basically the
display name of the actor
function sum floor set some float will
not be processed
what has basically happened here is that
unreal basically does not know
which client actually owns this actor
now this actor isn't owned by anyone
and if you were to notice this RPC call
it says reliable replicated to server if
owning client now this if earning
clients client section which is there
that is what is causing our server RPC
to fail
now let's do a similar drill but inside
a character so if I were to just create
an RPC here so I'll just go ahead and
create a custom event oops custom event
and I'll just call this one
as we underscore test something like
that and make this one a server RPC
reliable go ahead and we'll just print
out a string and we can say RPC called
RPC called from character now we want to
be able to call this from the client
instead of big inflations we are in the
character anyway so we can use a more
elegant solution maybe on a key press so
maybe K on the keyboard because we don't
have any other things so okay on the
keyboard
so find it over there
so there is K
so when we press it this will obviously
run on the client which presses the key
we can call SV test
so go ahead and play this
and if I go ahead and press ok
it works on the server and if I were to
press K on the client it works on the
server too I mean obviously it's a
server or PC so the function will run on
the server but the point is our RPC
worked and our client was able to make
the server RPC now what if we wanted to
be able to call this
so from a client
so for this you will basically need to
have an owner for this the way you do it
is through the spawn actor function so
if you have just placed it in the level
like that you will have to use the set
owner method which again I mean if you
were to place something in the level
it's pretty obvious you wouldn't have an
owner for it but let's just see an
example where we use the owner so what
we can do is okay we already have a span
actor function
and for the owner here this is something
which I did a bit later so for the owner
here go ahead and plug in self so spawn
an actor doesn't matter the location and
stuff doesn't matter we aren't worried
about the actual actor itself we are
worried about the RPC
so make owner self and now what I want
you guys to do is run this only on the
client
so let's say for example we'll again do
it on key press so then that's going to
be easy for us to manage so we can
manually call it
so on key plus what we can do and we
want to spawn this on the server
obviously we don't want to spawn this on
the client because it is replicated
remember so you have to spawn it on the
server itself even spawning cannot be on
the client
so make sure you spawn it on the server
so is server only if it is the server we
are going to spawn it and obviously this
will run multiple times because for each
player which will be spawned this will
run
so there's no way for us to actually
ensure that it happens only once but
nothing to worry
so we can just grab a reference to this
and we'll need to make this replicated
if we want access to it from the client
so we'll go ahead and promote this to a
variable
and we'll call this one obj for example
and make this replicated so that we can
access it from the client
and now when we press the K key we can
just check if it is valid I mean it will
be but just for a safety check if it is
valid we can go ahead and call our RPC I
don't know what we called it so we
called it set some float
so we called it set sum plot
go ahead and run this now if I were to
press play
and if I press K on the keyboard
as you see we get server RPC printed
so if I were to check this we have
server RPC over here and let's just test
it on the client as well so go ahead and
press K as you can see Server RPC is
getting printed so we are able to call
it on the client basically the ownership
is important generally it's a good thing
actually that you wouldn't really
require to call any rpcs from actors
like this generally you would have rpcs
in your character game mode game State
stuff like that not in the game mode
game mode everything is going to run on
the server but for the most commonly
used classes networking is already set
up for you and in case you wanted to use
it for an actor like this I have shown
you guys how to do it so this is how you
do it make sure you just set the owner
so let's say I don't actually set the
owner and if I go ahead and press play
this will still work actually so if I
press k
this is going to work but if I do it on
the client it's not going to work
so that's one thing to note from the
client the reason this won't work is
because now that we do this so let me
just set the owner
when I set the owner over here
now when I press play I have two
characters so one is on the server and
the other one is on the client and for
both of these characters the begin play
is going to run so this is going to run
both for the server as well as the
client
so for the first version everything is
going to run fine but when this begin
play occurs on the client's version of
the character
even this character will have a begin
play on both the server and the client
because since this is networked this
character will be spawned both on the
server and the client
so when the RPC takes when the begin
place called on the server for this one
that is when the owner property starts
mattering to us
over here if we don't set self
in in which case it it will refer to
this particular character
in the game
our logic is not going to work
so that was pretty elaborate in my
opinion this is probably something which
you wouldn't even require that much but
this is basically how you do RPC calls
now there's one more type of RPC which I
want to hint upon and that is multicast
what if now we are now that you're on
the server
what if you wanted to print this for all
the players
in which case it's really simple type in
custom event and we'll just call this
one MC underscore
print I mean we actually didn't set the
float here which is kinda ironic but
we'll just do SV underscore print so SV
print
so we'll print this and we'll just
duplicate this over here and make this a
multicast start PC now I generally don't
prefer making these reliable generally
you would use multicast for things such
as particle effects so you wouldn't
really need reliable but anyways I'll
just do it for this example
and we'll call this one multicast
so we'll just call MC print and remember
multicast star PCS have to be called on
the server if they are not called on the
server it will only run on that client
so it's not going to run on all the
others
so if I were to press play as you can
see we get multicast RPC
so this is basically how we would go
about doing this now this worked on the
servers instance uh obviously because we
spawned it over here
otherwise it wouldn't work
so if I were to just go ahead and press
play you would see it works
and if we had more players it's going to
work again
if at three players
it's going to print it multiple times so
it's going to print it on the server
client one and client so we have server
RPC multicast RPC and stuff works like
that
so this is basically how you would go
about calling rpcs so you have SV print
which is routed to the server and we can
actually test that out rather than doing
it on begin play that is kind of an
incorrect way obviously I showed you
guys the right way to do it so this is
some sort of logic which you would never
use
so we'll just ignore all of this go
ahead and press play
if I press K on the keyboard you see we
are calling the RPC if I press K on the
client it works as well if I press K on
the other client it works as well and
all of the players can see the printed
string
now you can also have the logic the
other way around so let's say you are
the server and then let's say for
example I'm just taking an example here
let's say when the game starts you
wanted to show a countdown and the
widget obviously will be spawned on the
individual clients because obviously
it's a widget so it has to be spawned on
the particular client's computer so for
that you will again use a client RPC so
I'll just do it over here so let's say
when I press the K key we will test this
on the server itself client rpcs can
only be run from that owning client or
the server if you run a client RPC from
another client it's not really going to
work
so in order to do that we'll just create
an RPC so we'll make this one cl
underscore test
and make this run on owning client
and what I can do now is I can go ahead
and print a string and let let this just
be there so if I do CL underscore test
and if I were to press play if I
actually press K here RPC called from
character runs on the server
over here as well this runs on the
client
and over here as well this runs on the
so this is basically how you do it it'll
just run on the client
but what if you wanted to run this from
the server so if you do this through a
server RPC it is going to be routed
through the server so I'll just do that
and show you guys
so what we'll just do is we'll just uh
diyte ourselves so we can say SV test
and this will run on the server we can
have another print string and we'll call
This One SV for server and over here
instead of that we'll call the server
RPC
and now what we can do is once this is
printed we can go ahead and call the
client RPC so CL test
now if you were to notice if I go ahead
and press play
if I press K as you can see now both are
called on the server so the server RPC
work and the client RPC worked but if I
do this on a client as you can see the
server printed SV and the server again
called a function on this client so this
is basically how you would go about
using client rpcs so for any multiplayer
logic this is exactly how you would go
about doing this
in C plus plus this logic is pretty
straightforward there's just a few
additional steps for rep notify and uh
replicating variables but other than
that
even the C plus plus part is pretty
straightforward so generally you would
use blueprint itself for core
multiplayer logic unless it's something
uh you know fundamental to your game and
you want it to work
properly like let's say you had like a
firing mechanic or something and you
don't want any sort of performance
issues or any overheads you then you
would use C plus plus otherwise you
would really just use blueprint for most
of the things because it makes things so
simple as you can see you don't have to
do stuff like opening ports and stuff so
all of that is handled by unreal
and now let's go ahead and see how to
run rpcs in C plus plus
[Music]
thank you
now I've gone ahead and opened up visual
studio now we'll just ignore the plugins
part right now and we'll head into our
source folder beginner course public and
we'll head into first of all we'll head
into a character
now what I want you guys to do here is
first of all before you actually use any
networking feature just make sure you
include
net
slash unrealnetwork.h
dot h
make sure you include this header if you
do not include this header you will get
all sorts of weird errors so make sure
you do that
now first things first let's talk about
variable replication so if you want a
variable to be replicated
uh you basically have to make it a U
property first things first
and this one will give the specified
blueprint read right as usual to make
things simple for us
and one more thing which you have to
give is you have to give the specifier
replicated
and we'll make this let's say a float
float
replicated CPP variable Maybe
now one more thing which you have to do
this is additional this is not something
you have to do in Blueprint but one
thing you have to do for the replication
logic to work is you have to actually
write one function in the CPP file of
our character we'll go ahead and do that
and then we should be able to make this
work directly
so I've gone ahead and opened up the
documentation so this is the function
which we actually need so we can go
ahead and copy this and paste it inside
our character.cpp files have opened that
up and I'll just written a comment
called replicating variables go ahead
and paste it and we can go ahead and
have a definition for it
so over here this is going to be acpp
underscore character just put your class
name followed by the scope resolution
operator
then you can go ahead and just move
everything to one line to keep things
clean
and over here you would want to run this
macro called do rep Lifetime and this
takes in two parameters one is the class
which is going to be our current class
and the variable name the variable name
is going to be this
oh it's going to be replicated CPP
variable
now I'm recording this a bit later but
one thing that I forgot to mention is
make sure you call uh super of this
function otherwise you'll get weird
classes when you use the weird uh
artifacts when you use the derived
classes and for the parameter you can
just pass this in so make sure you just
do that otherwise your movement
variables and stuff will not be
replicated if you use your BP character
so that's one thing to note
and now if I were to go ahead and run a
debugger we should be able to do it just
make sure you close the editor and then
run a debugger
so as you can see the build succeeded
and now we should be in theory able to
use this variable as a normal replicated
variable in Blueprint
so I'll just show you guys replicated
variables are shown with those two balls
on the top so BP character is inherited
from CPP characters so we should have it
so if I just type in CPP get replicated
CPP variable and as you can see this
variable is replicated if I were to
actually go ahead and check this
variable over here it says cpf net this
basically means it's replicated so now
this should work like a normal
replicated variable
now I'll show you guys how to handle our
pieces as well
so rpcs are simple I'll show you guys
how to handle server and multicast rpcs
I won't really go over client or PCS
they work pretty much the same
so I'll go ahead and stop this now
and for the for rpcs in C plus plus you
need to basically have a u function
first of all so create a view function
and you cannot make rpcs in C plus plus
blueprint callable however you can wrap
them inside another function and then
make them blueprint callable or whatever
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make call uh put the specifier server
and one more thing I am going to make
this either reliable or unreliable so
this is where you specified
so reliable
or you can make it unreliable
now I can go ahead and actually write
something here so let's say void
test server RPC underscore CPP just to
indicate that this is NC plus plus
now what you need to do is you need to
Define it over there but also
uh rather than defining this you are
supposed to Define
another function known as the
implementation for this
so what we are going to do is we are
going to just copy this over into the
next line This need not be a u function
and type in underscore implementation
okay just ignore the parentheses there
implementation
and now what we can do is we can create
a definition for this instead so I've
already done that so I have the
definition for this and we can do
something simple such as a print string
so you Kismet system Library print
string
and we can go ahead and print in
this is a server RPC from C plus plus
now this shouldn't clearly work and if
we want to call this RPC what we would
do is you can you can just go ahead and
call this we don't have to call the
implementation we have to call this in
order for the implementation to get
called on the server or we could just uh
do something else such as wrapping it in
another function so I'll show you guys
both the approaches actually so I'll
just do it on begin play so on the
gameplay what we'll do is we'll go ahead
and we'll actually delete some of this
code
so we'll delete this and what we can do
is over here we can go ahead and check
so if we are on the server in fact or if
we are not on the server we are going to
do it so if is server
so I guess it's called GS server I think
it's a variable not a method so if this
is not a server we are going to call
this RPC
over here we'll call test server RPC
underscore CPP
and this will work as expected
and we can go ahead and wrap this in a
blueprint view function so we'll create
a new function
make this one
blueprint callable
and from here what we can do is we can
just type in void
wrapper for CPP RPC
and this one we can just write it like
any other function and the RPC will run
now what you can do over here is you can
go ahead and run this function inside of
that
so we'll go ahead and call this
and since this is blueprint callable we
can go ahead and just call this from
blueprint
also realize that just because of the
way the function call works this is not
going to run at all
no matter what you do it is going to
come outside the if
so if it comes inside this it's again
not going to the condition is again not
going to be valid so you're not going to
run this function
so anyways we'll just run it as is and
then we can go ahead and run a debugger
so now if I were to actually go ahead
and wait for it
so once it loads in
and I go ahead and press play
if I press play right now
you'll notice that you get this is a
server RPC from C plus plus so we got
two server RPC calls one from the client
and one from the server
now I'll also set up some logic so that
we run this during gameplay
so under your BP character what we can
do is we can run the wrapper so type in
wrapper for CPP or PC now if I go ahead
and press play and press K on the
keyboard as you can see it runs on the
server
and if I do it on the client that works
as well totally as expected now one
extra feature which I want to cover in C
plus plus rpcs is the validation so if I
just type in a comma and type in width
okay how my caps lock on with
validation
now what I can do is I can write a
function which returns a Boolean and
instead of underscore implementation if
I type in underscore validate
you can make it so that this function
will only run under a certain condition
this is especially useful for something
like cheat detection so if I were to
just create a definition for it
and what I can do is if this returns
false basically this client which is
calling the RPC will get disconnected
immediately so I can just do return true
for now and this RPC is going to run so
if you had something like a health
variable or something and you do
something like if health is you know
less than or equal to 100
and
or maybe if you had any other conditions
so let's say the health you had a set
Health function which is an RPC of
course so then you would check if it is
less than or equal to 100 because you
don't want the player to set the health
to a value greater than 100 stuff like
this but for now we'll just leave this
to true this function will run just to
Showcase I'm just going to print string
once again so this
and we'll call this validate
and will not do this on begin play soops
print string
go ahead and run a debugger and before
we do that I'll actually just show you
guys how to handle rpcs as well I mean
rep notify as well
so let's say I wanted to make this rep
notify I would use the replicated using
flag I will do it after this actually
now if I were to go ahead and press play
as you would see the validate function
was also called on the server so the
server is going to validate and
accordingly it is going to disconnect
the client if the condition is not met
so that function whatever we saw right
there that has to return true in order
for the RPC call to take place
successfully and for the client to
continue stay connected so this is
basically validation and now let's talk
about rep notify
I am back inside the header file and for
rep notify over here you can just go
ahead and create a function so what do
we call this function this need not be
your function but you can make it as
well so we'll call this one
uh on rep it's just a convention to use
on rep but it need not be on rep
wrapper for CPP let's say
for CPP
and this one will just be void no need
to return anything you could return a
value if you wish but there's really
nothing much you can do with it
go ahead and write a function definition
for it
now again what we can do is we can go
ahead and just print something so we'll
just copy this over and rather than
validate we'll just print
rep notify from C plus plus
so now what we can do is now we can feel
free to come in here and rather than
typing in replicated type replicated
using equals and just pass in the
function name
so you don't have to pass in anything
else and this is going to work as you
would expect one thing that you would
want to do is wherever you call this
function uh that will obviously be on
the server make sure you call this
function as well separately
so where you set the variable
so we are setting this replicated CPP
variable so we'll do that
make sure you call this as well so if
you are setting this in Blueprint make
sure you make this function a u function
and make it blueprint callable
so we'll do that actually
there's one issue with it in C plus plus
this is how we would uh the same this
thing works in the same way as it works
in Blueprint
so we'll just do it on our RPC itself
anyways we are running the RPC so in the
implementation for it
will not have the print string rather we
will have our ref notify
the way you do that is we'll modify the
value of the variable if you modify the
value automatically rep notify will be
called Equals I'll just type Rand mod
19 I just chose a random number over
there and what you want to do is you
would want to call this function
only over here
and the rest will be handled for you
now we can go ahead and run a debugger
and you would see that our rep notify
will be called and rep notify from C
plus plus is going to be printed it just
works just like that
so wait for the editor to load in
and once we are inside the editor if I
go ahead and press play as you can see
rep notify from C plus plus and it was
called on the client as well since there
are two versions of the character here
so one on the client and one on the
server both of them called it two times
so that's the reason we got four prints
and the same thing is going to work when
we use the wrapper
so if I just type in k for example you
see the rep notify works so
we get the validate rep notify as well
as anything else that you would expect
so wrap notify on the server and the
client
and if you want to do the same in
Blueprint
so you can go ahead and set
our replicated CPP variable to something
and you would notice something weird
uh first of all I have to do it on the
server so we'll do it on a server or PC
so SV test rather than doing CL test
we'll go ahead and set the value of this
variable
and we can do SV test
go ahead and close this
and if I were to press K let's just wait
for it as you see
this rep notify is only called on the
client this is not actually called on
the server
so in order for rep notified to work
again once you do this you will have to
type in on rep wrapper for CPP
so make sure you actually type that
so now if I were to go ahead and press K
on the keyboard you see it runs both on
the server and the client
so there's just one extra step which you
have to take in C plus plus that is if
you have your replicated variable in C
plus plus
so that's about it for rep notify I
guess we have covered almost all aspects
of replication uh multicast is something
which I'll just talk about so all the
same parameters except or here you would
have net multicast
so don't mind the spelling I mean the
capitalization
so I have my caps lock on net multicast
and this will work as expected you can
again have your reliable and validation
and stuff like that
uh the rest of it will remain exactly
the same so you'll have your
implementation and you can have your
validate if required
but you wouldn't really have a validate
for a multicast RPC so I'll just go
ahead and delete that
and this should work just as expected so
I'm not going to really show that this
is how you would basically set up a
multicast RPC and the documentation is
there we did the example for the server
there are no syntactical changes to this
so it should be totally okay so we'll
just delete that definition and I guess
then we are done with multiplayer guys
[Music]
now that we are done with covering all
aspects of game development in Unreal
Engine let's go ahead and actually take
a look at how to install Unreal Engine
from source so the main part is actually
done now we'll be doing a couple of
things such as downloading the source
looking at how we can build it as well
as we'll be going ahead and changing the
engine version on our existing project
so first of all as I mentioned at the
very start of the course make sure you
guys do get access to this repository
here
as of this date the release Branch
should have 5.1.0 and you should be able
to download the zip file over here so
download the zip
first of all uh especially when you're
installing unreal Source just to avoid
you know the permission issues which you
are going to get make sure you head into
your C drive
new folder and just create a folder
called unreal Source or something it
need not be the C drive just make sure
you do it in your SSD if you have one so
in my case it's the C drive so that's
the reason I'm doing it so I'll just go
ahead and install it there so go ahead
and extract the files
over here under C I'll go ahead and
browse the directory over there
so see unreal source
go ahead extract
and extract it under the directory and
hit OK
now we're just a few steps away in order
to install Unreal Engine so first of all
go ahead and run your setup batch file
and try to run it as an administrator
just to ensure it has all the
permissions for everything so run the
setup batch file as an admin
so something like this should show up
and once it's completed we'll head into
the next step
after the setup batch file has completed
running you can go ahead and run the
generate project
files.bat so this file is basically
going to generate your Visual Studio
solution so let's go ahead and run that
again try to run it as an administrator
it should work regardless but if you do
get any errors just run it as an admin
so you should see something like this
and this should complete relatively
quickly
at this point you should be able to see
our solution file so go ahead and open
it up once the solution is open and you
see ready over here at the bottom left
hand side what you should do is you
should go ahead and head into engine and
if it does ask you to install a few more
components in Visual Studio make sure
you just go ahead and do that just
follow along but in my case I've already
done that so I'm gonna go ahead right
click on you if I and click build
now once your build has succeeded
under your engine binaries when 64 you
should find unreal editor.exe so by
default the build configuration is set
to development editor if you don't see
this it means your build configuration
was probably something else and it
didn't get built so anyways let's go
ahead and open it up and our editor
should load up if we do get any errors
we can go ahead and debug it now
so everything seems to be working fine
and it is going to compile some shaders
once that's done I'll be right back
foreign
course project and now I'll show you
guys how to change the engine version so
headed your beginner course your project
file right click switch Unreal Engine
version and now you should see Source
build at whatever so basically I opened
and closed the editor that's it so
whatever we did there open unreal
editor.exe I just closed it immediately
and now I'm back to this location and
you should see this so if I hit OK it is
going to generate some Visual Studio
project files and unless something's
horribly wrong it should in theory work
out of the box
so that's about it and now you can go
ahead and just Build Your solution once
again because there may be a few API
changes which you might have to make so
those will be lifted and listed in the
output log and as well as in the release
notes and the documentation or whatnot
so head into your solution
now we have switched the Unreal Engine
version
so now we can go ahead and right click
on our beginner course and click on
build
foreign
so we get our first error here and this
is actually fairly common so basically
we have switched the Unreal Engine
version and we have a plug-in over here
which is based on the older version of
the engine there are two ways to fix it
one you can head into the marketplace
and reinstall the plugin which is meant
for 5.1 or I'll just show you guys the
way to do it without up using the
marketplace so in the marketplace it's
really easy you can just go ahead and
update the plugin but over here if you
really want to just use the same one
what you can do is you can head into
your engine installation directory so in
my case it is C unreal Source Unreal
Engine release engine
plugins
Marketplace uh it's not here because we
haven't yet installed so you'll find it
there so we'll go to our previous
installation program files Unreal Engine
this is where I had it
ue5.0 engine
plugins
and you should find Marketplace
and the one we are interested in is low
entry extended standard Library
you don't need to copy it to the engine
installation although you could what
I'll do is I'll just take it to the
plugins folder over here
so over here and under inside the U
plugin file we'll do the same
modifications
over here what we are going to do is
under the engine version we are going to
type in 5.1.0
and now if we go ahead and try to build
this once again
we shouldn't get that error hopefully
so it will take a while and if we do get
any errors we'll go ahead and change it
or fix those
so we have a few errors here and these
are mostly the changes which came
according to the documentation due to
the platform SDK upgrades but it's not
really a problem
so because I don't think any of you guys
unless you guys work for a triple a
studio or something I don't think you'll
be using this and this is from the
plugin this is not something in the
engine so nothing to worry so what I can
do is we can simply just delete this
code and just to return false
and even for the Xbox one so we can just
do the same thing
and I'll tell you guys which file this
is it's basically this file right here
so in the error list you see platform
PS4 whatever so just head into that just
double click on that and you will reach
there
and over here as well
so line 264
so I feel like
this was it so before changing it was in
line to 64. so now it's gone a bit up
anyways let's try building this once
again
and as you can see the build has indeed
succeeded but once the plugin actually
comes for 5.1 what you can basically do
is install 5.1 here like in the epic
games launcher install the plugin from
the marketplace and then you can go
ahead and copy that into the plugins
folder in the engine level
so what you would do is you would have
it over here so see unreal Source
release
an engine plugins
over here you would create a new folder
called Marketplace or something and then
you would like just copy it in
anyways we are not really worried about
that right now
now what we can do is now that it's
built successfully we can go ahead and
run a debugger and we should be able to
run this in 5.1 so I did show you guys
multiple things so the errors which you
get will actually depend on what plugins
you're using and how's your code base
and what changes are made to the engines
API itself
so depending on that you'll have to look
at the output log and the error list and
do something and there are a few
deprecation warnings as well so if you
just have a look
so I'm not really sure
what this is but this will probably be
changed soon once the plugin is updated
but right now I'm not really worried
since it's just a warning so now I can
go ahead and run a debugger
all right so our project has opened
successfully and it is prompting us to
change a few project settings in order
to actually use Virtual Shadow maps and
nanite so that's not really an issue we
can head into the project settings
uh and over here
under it should in theory
be here so platforms
so let's just search for platforms
it'll be under any one of these so
platforms
windows
and you can go ahead and enable Shader
Model 6.
and over here we can go ahead and
I don't think we'll require Shader Model
5 so that should be about it and now you
can go ahead and restart the editor all
right so now I've restarted the editor
and now we are using Unreal 5.1 so
that's about it for installing the
source and changing your engine version
now there are a few more ways you can
handle some of the things such as the
plugin part but on the whole this is how
you do it and if you do want any more
specific references you always have the
documentation which you can refer and
the release notes are maybe the unreal
Slackers Discord server so that's about
it
foreign
ly inside the last section of this
course and obviously it is about how to
package your game
so it used to be very simple before so
you just go file package project but now
it will probably have to just do it
through the project launcher which I
will show you guys it's really simple so
head into tools project launcher
and you can use this but I'm going to be
using a custom launch profile
so go ahead and add
create a custom profile
and I'll just walk you guys through each
option you can give a name to this
profile let's say this is for testing
let's hit uh you are building this for
testing so you can name this profile
testing you can reuse this profile for
the next time when you package the game
as well packaging basically means you
make your game or you turn your game
into an executable basically
now project is going to be beginner
course of course and build configuration
so debug and development will be used
when you're actually you know testing
out your game and you're still not yet
at a stage where you can
uh send it to other people so your print
strings and stuff are gonna work but
under shipping uh none of your print
strings and stuff will work but it will
take a bit longer to build
and testing is somewhere in between
debug development and shipping so it's
below shipping but it's above
development and debug basically
so you can select any one of these I
I'll just select shipping
and here these are settings you don't
need to worry about and about cooking
the content you can do either on the fly
or buy the book
uh basically what on the Fly uh and buy
the book is going to differ in is
basically if you do buy the book
everything is going to be cooked uh
beforehand basically so if you if you're
packaging your game for shipping most of
the times you will have buy the book
and you would select windows
if you're developing a Windows game
obviously if you have anything else
let's say you're making an Android game
you would select Android and stuff like
that and undercook cultures you'll find
English somewhere here so en it should
be selected by default so en
and you can select your Maps which
you want to cook so we're using all so
we'll just select all but you can choose
to cook only
selected Maps but note that if you don't
cook a certain map you won't be able to
open it in game you're going to get
errors your game will probably crash now
that's one thing to note now the release
DLC patching settings these are some
things which I'll not go over and under
advanced settings as well so you can go
ahead and mess with these
so
you can enable this
if you want all the content to go in a
single dot pack file
stuff like that
and everything is pretty
self-explanatory
next package package and store locally
then you can go ahead and give it a path
so generally I'd like to do it in the
project location
saved and I'd like to create a folder
called staged builds
staged builds have used the project
launcher in the in the older versions
you probably already know what this is
and is this just is this build for
distribution to the public we have
selected shipping so I would assume it
is of course it's again your preference
do you wish to Archive
can select yes or no doesn't really
matter
and deploy we can select do not deploy
because we aren't actually launching the
game
so if we select do not deploy basically
you can launch it through the executable
itself
so once that's done you can head back
and you can click on launch this profile
so now once everything has been
completed you can head into the
directory over there you should find a
Windows folder and you should find your
executable right there so open it up and
you should launch your game
so we will end up in this map right here
again you can change your project
settings and you can change the default
map but anyways our purpose here was to
check if the game packages and
everything seems to be working the
physics simulation works and so on
so that's pretty much it
[Music]
okay guys so this is going to be the
last segment of the course as you guys
would know and I hope you guys would
have enjoyed the course till now and
congratulations if you have completed
the course still here
and the further part is going to be
two hours of me creating an entire game
so hopefully you guys will enjoy it uh
see you in the engine
alright guys so this is the last section
of the course and this is not actually
going to be about you know learning
anything new however in this part I will
be live demonstrating without any Cuts
how to make an endless Runner such as
Temple Run or Subway Surfers or any
other which you might have played
so we'll be taking the most simple
approach or at least as far as my
knowledge is concerned if you do have
anything simpler you can let me know in
the comments
and hopefully within an hour we'll be
able to make the whole game with the
menu animations and all that kind of
good stuff
so let's get started so let me actually
have a stopwatch here so that we have
track of our time
so I'll just create a game it's going to
be third person because we'll have the
animation blueprint and stuff but
anyways I don't think we'll be using
that not to worry uh we'll go with blank
actually
C plus plus and we'll call this one
endless Runner
create it
now this will take a little bit of time
and I do have a couple of things being
installed in the background and I also
have a list of plugins that I'll be
using
so you guys will have a pretty good idea
of what will actually do with plugins
and stuff because in the course I think
I just went over these briefly but I
went in depth about how to actually
create your own plugins and stuff
anyways so our project will be created
soon
and this will compile so until then we
can go ahead and open up our epic games
launcher
head into Library
and we can close this editor for now
until we add everything
so what I what I'll do is I'll go ahead
and search these one by one so City
subway tunnel
so I have to create a separate project
for this not going to go over that right
now
so we'll go construction volume
so volume 1 and volume 2 will go ahead
and add this to endless Runner we'll add
this to endless Runner I'll CL I'll
clear the cache later it's just taking
up storage
and we want Ellie extended so early
extend it
so we have already installed it to 5.0.3
so nothing to worry about there
so Adventure character whoops
so this will be the character which
we'll be using and it's going to be
hella fun
ah we don't have time to actually model
our own character that's the reason we
are doing this so I'll just go over this
real quick so FX variety pack
not sure if we will get the effect we
need but I'll just add it just in case
okay I need to download it yet so we're
not gonna do that now so window dialog
box
so I've already installed it
so these two
so we'll use this for obstacles and
stuff
and lastly we'll just have some trees
maybe at the side we could have
something
Stone Pine Forest
and go ahead and add it once everything
is complete
now depending on your system if you have
a hard drive or something this process
is going to be a little bit slow so this
is under my unreal project endless
Runner so we'll be using the file
explorer for this and I'll just delete
this later on
so now once the engine is loaded up we
can start making our game and we'll go
ahead and create a Maps folder first so
right click Maps will have only one and
all the obstacles will be spawned at
runtime dynamically when you're playing
the game so we don't really care about
having multiple Maps but we'll have two
so one is going to be your main menu
and the other one is going to be the
actual map
so I'll go ahead and create the map and
I'll call this one game map
all right save that and go ahead and
open the main menu head into project
settings and just change that as well so
under your maps and modes you should
have open world we'll change that to
main menu
so editor startup map will be main menu
and it's going to be main menu again
so editor we can start with our game map
actually
but the game has to start from main menu
so
just go ahead and click import doesn't
really matter
all right
now over here we can start making our
main menu so right click create a new
folder and we'll call this one content
once again
and inside this will actually create
stuff because the main content folder is
a bit clogged up
so we'll call this one UI and we can
create a main menu right click user
interface widget blueprint create a user
widget and we'll call this one main menu
or BP underscore main menu
and we'll suffix that with a WB to
indicate it's a widget
and it's going to be just quick and
dirty so we'll add a canvas panel here
and at the center we'll just have a
start button and an exit button so we'll
add in a vertical box
so vertical box
and over here we can go ahead and make
this Center aligned first of all
Center align position zero
with 0.5 for the alignment value so this
is going to make sure everything is
centered we can go ahead and increase
the size a bit
even vertically
and we can go ahead and add in two
buttons so button one
and Ctrl D to duplicate
we'll make it so that it fills it and we
obviously want the play button to be
bigger we don't want our users to exit
the game
anyways we'll add in the the text here
so add in some text add in some text and
change the background color for both of
these buttons make it almost black
maybe not exactly black but almost
so I like this shade of color
now rename this to play
or rather start we can try
change the font maybe so the font we'll
use is going to be the light one
so 40 seems about right
make this one 40 as well and this one is
going to be light and this one is going
to be exit
so we can add the functionality as well
because this is pretty simple so on this
button we'll rename this to exit button
or it's really not required I guess
so on click
and for this one as well we are going to
add a non-click this is the start button
so I'll just comment this out
and for this we can go ahead and execute
console command and we can type in exit
now our exit button should work we can
go ahead and test that first of all we
haven't even created the widget so under
content we will go ahead and create a
new folder and call this one blueprints
and we'll have two subfolders here we'll
call one as game and the another one as
main menu because we'll have different
player controllers and stuff for the
main menu and the actual game so under
main menu right click go ahead and head
into blueprint class and create a player
controller
and we'll call this one BP
main menu
player controller so this is basically
for you know creating the widgets and
stuff we'll just use the play controller
now under the event graph we can just do
it on begin play so we'll create a
custom event custom event
create main menu
and create a widget
it's going to be BP main menu widget
blueprint and add this to the viewport
now we I don't think we really need the
reference but we'll just store a
reference to it anyways so
main menu widget blueprint we'll just
have a reference to it
and from this we can go ahead and add it
to the viewport
all right and on begin play we can
create the widget so create widget or
rather create main menu is the function
name
so create main menu
and now if I compile save it go ahead
and press play
as you can see nothing happens because
we haven't changed the game mode yet so
over here we'll create a new game mode
so go ahead all classes
game mode so we'll create a game mode
base
so we'll call this one
BP underscore main menu game mode
now under your world settings go ahead
and change your game mode to BP Main
menu game mode
and over here the player controller can
be our BP main menu player controller
and now if I go ahead and press play we
should get a button start won't do
anything but exit is going to work
now let's actually head into our game
map here so Maps game map will worry
about the main menu a bit later so we
are in the game up we can go ahead and
add our sky so Sky atmosphere Skylight
and we can add in our directional light
we can also have a fog so we can have
exponential height fog and we have
everything set up
now we could change the time of day as
well we'll make this one Dynamic for now
so fully Dynamic light because I don't
have any time to actually build this so
go ahead and rotate it to make it like a
morning or evening scene
this should be about good not gonna
spend too much time on it save it up
and over here under content now we can
start building the actual level
so I'll just go to my blueprints folder
here under game I'm going to create the
game mode and stuff for this one as well
so type in game mode
so I'll create gamma BP game mode
this one is just going to be called BP
game mode because this is for the actual
game itself
under your world settings go ahead and
change that once again so BP underscore
game mode will have a CPP game mode if
we really require but I'll try to stick
with blueprint as much
now let's check our time so 10 minutes
in
now under your game mode will also have
a game state to counter score and stuff
so game state
so game stead base
BP underscore
game state
so we have our game mode oops
and we have our game state
and now we can also have our character
and stuff so we can create that first of
all we can just right click blueprint
class character and we can type in BP
character
open it up and we have some basic things
already set up for this mesh we'll be
using one of these which you bought
under man
under mesh full we have all these
various options so we have four options
so we'll be using these four so these
four will be the options for the players
to choose from That's How we'll do it
so we'll create a derived class for this
for BP character
so under our characters what we can do
is I can type in character
I'll just move this here
and go ahead and type in subclasses
so these with this is like your main
character
so every character is going to be a BP
character but then we'll specifically
make them choose a mesh
so go ahead and create a blueprint Class
Type in character
and
over here we can make it of type BP
character
and call this one character one we can
actually just name them maybe we'll call
one Adam duplicate that we'll call One
John I'm just giving generic names we
had four
so we can call one Json and
maybe we can call one bill I just chose
random names
so open this up and for the mesh we can
go ahead and start replacing it
so head into the location where we had
the mesh so this is going to be a first
character we'll set up the animation
blueprint a bit later
so it's a bit off but not to worry we
can go ahead and adjust that
negative 90.
and we can head into the other classes
here
so under content blueprint game
character subclasses we can head into
bill
and this was called SK manful one so
we'll call this SK Man full 2.
over here we can select SK Man full
three
so SK man
full three
and for this one we can have SK Man full
four so SK man
full four
so that's pretty much all set
so I'm not sure if I should just use the
default one here so man
full one
not sure if it'll inherit the transform
so I'll just try this I'll compile
compile this
so if I open the full blueprint editor
okay it has inherited the transforms
that's a good thing
so we don't have to do everything once
again
all right so we have our character set
up
uh in our main menu we can go ahead and
add a character selection option
so head into content uh our actual
content folder
under the main menu we can have a button
somewhere
and maybe over here we can type in
change character
so I'll change the color of this I'm not
really worried about the visuals as of
now
so I'll just go ahead and change this
okay I change the color so background
color I'll just make this dark again
and we can add in some text
and we'll call this one
change character
all right
make this a little bit wider
so that it's visible for our player so
make this one 45 maybe or 35 35 seems
good we'll make that one light once
again
maybe we could make start a bit
Bolder so let's start be regular because
we want our players to deliberately
click Start
all right so once you click on the
change character menu it should just
give us a list and we will create the
widget for that
now we'll also need a game instance
class
head into Blueprints and game instances
General so we'll create one here so game
instance
go ahead and call this one main GI or
something
and under the project settings we can go
ahead and change it so game instance
oops game instance
change that to main GI
and over here we can have a variable for
selected character
and we can change that actually we can
change that to be of type BP character
class
so we have BP character we should see it
somewhere here BP character class
reference
so this is going to be the the character
which we have actually selected or we
could have it in a struct we'll think
about that a bit later
now once we have that we can go ahead
and start making the actual obstacles
and stuff
so one thing to note is that we want to
make this modular in a way we want to be
able to spawn them one after the other
let's just go ahead and do that
so on when the game starts we want to
have a bunch of obstacles
and then we'll look at what to do
uh we'll work on the obstacles after we
work on the animations actually
so we'll head into the skeletal mesh we
have certain animations
so content content blueprint will add
into character
and we'll create the animation blueprint
right here so animation animation
blueprint and we'll go ahead and select
our ue4 mannequin skeleton
this is the one which comes with the
pack actually
so create
and we'll call this one character and
MVP
open it up and inside this we have a
bunch of things so we'll create a state
machine
doesn't really matter now we can go
ahead and have an idle
so we'll have idle
and we can have we'll create a blank
space for this
so right click go ahead into animation
so basically this is for transitioning
between your idle and walk animations
blend space
and we'll call this one walk run
okay
over here we'll have few things in the
horizontal and the vertical axis
horizontal axis is going to be the
direction and the vertical axis is going
to be the speed
so we'll go between 0 and 600 but we'll
see if we can do something else a bit
later on
now open this and we can have our third
person walk halfway over here
we can have our third person run
full way
and we can have our third person idle at
zero
so we transition between these something
like this for the direction we'll have a
negative 180 and positive 180 obviously
so this will be like your angle from
your forward Direction that's basically
what this is
now we can change the animation
blueprint after we actually set it up
first so for the idle we have our idle
animation playing and we should already
have this working
and we can have this as a new state so
walk run
we will set up the conditions not to
worry
oops go ahead and do that
so on begin play
begin play
we can go ahead and get the pawn owner
and cast to BP character
and we can make this a pure cast because
this will succeed
or if it doesn't we can go ahead and
pull it
and once we get access to our character
what we can do is we can get access to
the speed so get velocity
so get velocity
and we want the vector length
right now we have a vector and we want
the magnitude of this vector
and we can promote that variable and
obviously the magnitude of the Velocity
is nothing but speed so speed
and we can also have Direction so get
actor rotation we'll set it up a bit
later actually
okay so under the update animation
what we can do is
we'll need this on every frame so we'll
use a reference instead so promote this
to a variable
and call this one character ref
we'll be using this multiple times
so we can drag this over there
so this will be our speed
and also
what we can do is we can also get the
direction
so we can use this function known as
calculate Direction
and that is what will set the direction
to be set Direction
so we'll create a new variable called
Direction
it's going to be a float once again
and we're going to set the direction
to be equal to whatever this is
for the velocity we can just uh grab in
or get velocity here
and base rotation is going to be the
actor's rotation itself
so get actor rotation
and we can plug this into the velocity
as well now what we are basically doing
is we're calculating the direction so
that we actually input the value
correctly in our blend space basically
we are not using this value anywhere
else so here we can plug in our
direction and speed so Direction
and speed so these were our vertical and
horizontal axis values in our blend
space
we can also have jump which we will do
we have we don't have a state transition
so if speed is greater than let's say 10
we can go ahead and transition
and over here as well if the speed is
less than 10 we can transition so
rather speed
so speed is less than or equal to 10.
we can go ahead and transition into this
state
so now we shouldn't have any of those
warnings
all right now if I actually create
something here
so I'll just create a player start so
we'll know where to start so player
start
and I'll just go ahead and box out a
simple level
so shapes
so I'll have a cube
and I'll just make this really really
big
so this is just for testing purposes and
for the default Pawn class I'm going to
select BP character
and let's set up the animation blueprint
over here if we go ahead and select our
character anime nmbp
in theory everything should work fine
so our camera is a bit off that's
nothing to worry about
so under our BP character we need to set
up a camera so add a component and this
will be of type camera
go ahead and add it
we can adjust the view that's nothing to
worry about
and if I go ahead and press play we have
our camera here
so we can make that a little bit
further back
maybe tilt it down a bit
and I hope this looks good okay so this
looks good
so we have access none in our character
animation blueprint
so that's only
in the first frame which is happening
basically so we can convert this to a
validated get
that's a simple fix
you can go ahead and turn that into
validated get go ahead and press play
and now we shouldn't get those errors
you can set up our moment logic real
quick here
so if the characters always going to be
moving
and I think we might have to change the
animation blueprint here because we
always want him to be running
because we don't want him to stop so
we'll always have running actually
so sorry for that but anyways
something we can do
so he'll always be running
so this is how he'll always be
and we can also have you know a copy of
this
so we'll just copy this over and we can
type in run fast we can make this go at
a higher speed
so there should be a speed multiplier
somewhere here
so playback speed is what it's called I
assume
so playback speed
so nothing under the details
we'll look into that so there's actually
an option called playback speed so we
are going to increase the speed and make
it so that
it's actually as if he's running
now what we can do
is
we can head into the character once
again
and now that we have him running
continuously we'll actually do it so
that the obstacles in the world actually
go backward
you can create the blueprint for that
now so we're finally heading into the
obstacles so
we'll spend 25 minutes not done really
really that much
and again
in the blueprints folder we can go ahead
and create a new blueprint class we'll
do it in the new folder so we'll call
this one course rather this will be the
obstacle course basically
and we'll create a new actor
and we'll call this one
obstacle
underscore base
and we can go ahead and create a child
blueprint class and we'll call this one
obstacle one obstacle 2 and so on
so obstacle 2
duplicate that duplicate that duplicate
that will have five
we'll see if it if it gets too hectic
we'll reduce this number
over here we'll need some sort of a base
so we can try using some of the things
which we got from the content packs
so under hanger I guess we had a road I
believe
I type in Road
we have this which is pretty tileable I
believe
over here Road set
we have this so we can use this
just that we'll need to know what's the
length of this and stuff
I don't think we'll go for nanite or
anything
this is fine
so close some of these which we are not
using
head back into the obstacle base
over here we can go ahead and add in a
static mesh
and this will be common for everything
so head back select that
and go ahead and
put that in
so this is there at the origin
but not to worry we'll find a way to fix
that
so it would have been nice if we had
multiple Lanes
but we have to live with this right now
so I'll just go ahead and re-center this
I'm not sure how
big this is going to be
so I think that is pretty well centered
we can go ahead and add an arrow
component just for a reference
so add in an arrow component
attached to the root
this one is going to be at the origin
obviously
just rotate that for our reference
or we'll keep the rotation to zero we'll
look into the rotation and stuff so
we'll duplicate this once again
so Ctrl D to duplicate
and we'll just have one over there I
think one is enough but we'll just have
it just in case
all right so this is exactly at the end
now at first we can spawn for example 10
of these
and then we can later see what to do
we can have something in the side by the
way we don't have anything
so we'll just add in a plane
and for this we can increase the scale
of this
maybe we can make this 100 I guess
okay that's a little too big 50.
maybe change it on the Y 50 is a bit too
much 40.
Maybe 30.
2 seems to be about right
so it aligned perfectly here
and it aligned almost perfectly here as
well
I can have 32.
now this is approximate you can do it
accurately when you actually do it
so go ahead and duplicate this once
again we'll attach it to the root
duplicate this will be for the other
side
all right
so we have something on both the sides
now if we head into a derived classes we
should also have all of those
well we can spawn this first of all just
for testing it out
so open the level blueprint
and we can just do a for Loop
so for Loop
and we can have a loop of length 10
let's say
we'll select An Origin
we'll start from a certain point
so Target point
we can start here maybe we'll make the Z
value of this zero
will make the X and Y 0 as well
so this is going to be where we start
and we can go ahead and start spawning
this further on
so we'll have access to this target
point now so create a reference to
Target point
so we are going to spawn actor from
class and it's going to be BP obstacle
I'm not sure what we called it obstacle
base
this is for testing so it's fine
so it can get active location it's going
to be zero I'm aware but in case we
wanted to change it the logic should
still work that's why I'm using the
target point
so get actor location
we'll break this down actually
split the struct PIN
now the Y and the Z are going to remain
zero
so I have to see which is the forward
axis here actually
so in the obstacle base
we have y as the forward axis
we can rotate everything by 90 degrees
if we don't mind
you can just rotate everything by 90.
oops we change the location
so we can change this to 90.
and stuff doesn't seem to be working
we'll have y as the forward axis in our
case don't mind
so the x value is going to be 0.
we are going to split the struct PIN
so we're going to multiply this
multiply this by the index
and we can go ahead and split this and
the Y is going to be this
X and the Z are going to remain zero
let's go ahead and just test this out so
go ahead
selected viewport
so if I click f8 and if I were to notice
we don't have anything
so we should have our
Target okay we are taking the target
points Y location
but
we need the last obstacles location
so we need the value of this actually
we need the location of
this Arrow
so this Arrow
so this arrow is going to be located
at negative 3200.
so we'll just copy the number we'll just
brute force it here
so we have the target point
that's where we start
and into
so it's negative 3200
so I'm not sure if we really need this
this is going to be 0 anyways
so this into 3200
index into 3200 now let's try this
okay so our obstacle course is spawned
successfully
so a bit of an issue with the direction
over there but that's totally okay
all right so we have
that completed so we spawned our initial
course
so we can grab in our player start first
of all and we can rotate that we can
delete one of them
we can maybe rotate that negative 90
degrees
so now we should face the right
direction
now move this a little bit to the left
so for reference we'll just have one
obstacle
so we'll just have obstacle base we'll
set everything to zero zero zero zero
and we'll base the player start
accordingly
so our player start just disappeared
somewhere
okay it's up there
so we'll click end to Snap It to the
Ground
go ahead and do that
and now we should in theory be centered
hopefully
yep we will be centered now
now if I go ahead and press play as you
can see we are centered
now we can also set up the logic to move
sideways
so we can linear interpolate actually
so we'll add in Target points
so copy the server we'll copy the
X location of this
so X is going to be 20.
we need 20 here
and the Y location
really should be the same actually again
so Y location should be the same
now we have got these in the same spot
now we can have few more
so these two are equally spaced now we
can set up some logic
so that we slide between these basically
head back into the character to set that
logic
under your BP character if we press the
right arrow we won't do changeable
controls so right
Arrow
so right
and we can have left as well
so keyboard events left
under right and left we can change them
so if we press right
we also need access to which Target
point we are at right now
we can have all of these in a blueprint
we can have these in the game state
content blueprints game game state
we can type in
will have an enum
it's going to be simple
so content
will create enums so enum
right click create an enumeration
and over here we'll call this one
which side of the road you're in
basically so I don't I don't even know
what to call this e
which side I guess
I mean which is kind of stupid but at
the same time it's descriptive
so it's either going to be left okay or
at the center by default so I'll have
Center first center left and right
so if I save that and head back into my
game State now I should be able to
create a variable of type which side
which side e which side so just my
naming convention
so we'll call this one
with side Maybe
all right
so we'll have access to this at any
given instance
and on begin play we can store a
reference to this
get game state
we can go ahead and cast to our BP game
state
and we'll have a reference to that
promote that two variable and call this
one game State ref
okay
now from here when we press right we can
first of all get access to the variables
the first variable which we need is the
only variable which we have right now
basically which is the side
so we'll type in side
and we'll do a simple switch
so if we are at the center right now
we can go to the right
if we are at the left right now
we can go ahead and head to
the left basically
uh if we are at the left we can head
into the center if we are at the right
we don't need to do anything so
basically on Center and left we can do
that
again we'll copy over this logic
depending on which side we don't want to
do anything if we are on the left side
here in this case
and we can linear interpolate on tick
so a linear interpolate is what we'll
just do so we'll type in lurp
and we should find a linear interpolate
and we should be able to feed in the
alpha we'll think about a logic for that
now we'll have access to where we are by
default we are at the center
just took a small break there now over
here we can continue with our side
switching logic so we'll actually get
hold of all the locations and stuff
so by default we are over here
so if I press play we are over here
but when we want to move we want to move
to either this or this
so we'll actually have a few variables
for this I'm going to be hard coding
this but you can have a more elegant
solution for all of these
so I can go ahead and under my game
State itself I can have right location
right location
center location and left location so
I'll duplicate this
so I'll call this one left location
and I'll call this one Center location
and we'll manually set these values
so this value over here is negative 230
negative 270 and 0. this is the left
location so negative 230
negative 270
to 70 and 0.
we can actually save some data I Believe
by using floats we only need the we only
need to linear interpolate the X
Direction so
we'll just store the X values of this
so
this is 270
20 and negative 230 not sure if they're
spaced equally I'll just have a look at
the top view
I want them to be spaced equally
so between this and this there is a
difference of 250
between this and this there is a
difference of 250 so yep they are spaced
equally
okay so the right location is going to
be 270.
left location is negative 230
and this is going to be 20.
so I'll just store these like this
now what I can do is I can go ahead and
actually
move the character so I'll try set actor
location not sure if this is going to
work
so if we are at the center we'll try
this to try to set this to the right
location so we're going left so left
left location
so we only want to change the X
so go ahead and split the struct pin
change the left location
and the rest is going to be the actors
location itself so get actor location
go ahead and split this Y and Z will
just remain access
all right so we can go ahead and try
this
so if I press the left Arrow
so nothing is really happening here
so we can see by printing if something
is happening
so nope we are not actually taking the
input something has to do
with the input so Arrow
left keyboard not really sure I'll I'll
try to use a and d for now
so a on the keyboard
so we'll use wasd
so when I press a on the keyboard we can
try that a is going to be instead of the
left Arrow
all right so we did we don't have access
to the game State according to this
that's mostly because we didn't set it
so that's pretty simple to handle so we
can change that to BP game instead
now over here we can try the left Arrow
logic itself
so if I type in left
not sure what else we have
so left is the only thing we have
so we can go ahead and try this so left
Arrow doesn't seem to work
okay left Arrow works
so that was the game State issue not
our thing
so we can use this logic
we can linear interpolate instead
or we have our
interrupt nodes anyways
we can have a variable for the Target
location so this is where you know we
want to get our character so Target X
location just to be precise
so linear interpolate is going to be a
little tough so F in term 2 is what
we'll use
it's a pure function so F enter up to
f f interrupt to constant because we
want it to interpolate in a constant
rate so Delta time is going to be Delta
seconds interrupt speed we can adjust
that
so we can promote this to a variable and
we can call him
sideways speed
over here we can
replace this with the target X location
that's going to be the X
oh this is an integer we'll make this
float
so Target X location
and
current is going to be our current X
location
so Target is our Target X
current is our current X location so
current X location
so we can get the actors X location
again
all right
so this should be it for the sideways
movement
and over here we can go ahead and set
these
if we want to go left we don't want to
do anything when we are on the left side
all right we can get the game State and
we want to go left so left location
and we can duplicate that and if we are
right we can get the center location
okay but the logic isn't done yet I'll
get back to it
so we can use a select to just make
things a little bit more simple
so if we are at the center we'll go left
if we are at the right we'll go to the
center
so the logic should make a lot more
sense now
and we can set
this over there
move it in
similarly we can copy over this Logic
for our
right
so that it simplifies things a bit so if
we are on the right we don't want to do
anything
we'll go to the center if we are on the
left
and we'll go to the right if we are on
the center so get the right location
so this is what we'll set it to
all right now our logic should work once
if I go ahead and press play so if I put
put the left Arrow nothing really seems
to be happening let's just check out why
okay our end of speed is zero
okay so now if I try
all right nothing really happens so
let's try 100.
so our actor location
seems to be fine
so current
and Target is okay
and now we can go ahead and print hello
so we are not changing the location I
assume that's what's happening
so when I press the left
key on the keyboard
and when I press the right key so we are
changing the target X and the target Y
location
so we'll try it without the inter first
a little bit of debugging will
so we can just copy this in
so I'll just remove this logic from tick
if I hit left or right nothing really is
happening
so we can print it and check what's
going on
all right once again
the input isn't working we'll use a
so we'll go ahead and use a on the
keyboard Maybe
go ahead and use a
so if I type in a
the input okay it's just about the
window being in focus
all right so if I go ahead and run this
okay this works now we can try it with
the interp logic
so now we don't need this
okay the speed is just way too less
so we can go a bit crazy on this 50
Maybe
nope still very slow 200
okay it's still really slow so 500
.
okay this is not going to help
whoops it's going 50. so if I make this
okay this is a lot better but maybe 1000
would be fine
all right so this seems about right
but now we need to change our actual
State itself
so again we'll use this select node
right there
so if we are in the center
we have to set our side so we'll grab a
reference to the game state
and we'll set the side
depending on where we are
so if we were at the center and we moved
left we'll set our side to left
so Center will set it to the left if we
were at the left it's going to be left
itself if we are at the right we'll make
the center
copy over the logic
Okay so
for this
so everything will remain the same
except when we are on the left and we go
right it's going to be Center if we are
on the right it's going to remain right
if we are at the center it's going to go
right
okay so now we can go ahead and try this
out
so something happened with our logic
right there
okay so we had to get the actors
location instead
we made it zero so we just sunk under
the ground
so go ahead right left right left right
okay so it is a bit glitchy
it is a bit glitchy at times
so let's try enabling teleport sometimes
that should fix the issue
okay when I'm at the right he's moving
to the Center for some reason
so when I'm at the right and I click
right again
so the logic is when I'm at the right
and I click right again I should still
remain at the right when I am at the
left I move to the center
so let's try that
so I go to the right
click right again I go to the Center for
some reason
so when I'm on the right the target
shouldn't actually be this it should be
the right location itself
when I'm on the left this shouldn't be 0
this should be the left location itself
because you're doing the inter Pawn tick
so that's why it's happening
left right and Center
all right so now our logic is working
totally fine and we can stop printing
hello it's just annoying at this point
okay then I think we exceeded one hour
okay we're pretty close
but we are left with our last few steps
now we have to make the obstacle move
which is pretty simple
now we can spawn it dynamically instead
rather than spawning it or rather just
using this
I think we are spawning it yep we are
so I can press f8 head into my
perspective View
and now for the magic
head to the obstacle blueprint itself
course obstacle base
we can try this on tick
so on tick we want to set the actor's
location so we want to change the
location of this actor
we will get the current location so get
the location of this actor so get actor
location
and
when we move forward we are increasing
the y basically
so when we move forward we are
increasing the Y
so the logic was wrong okay when we move
forward we are going more towards the
negative y direction
so
what we can do is we can go ahead and
move it backwards so we want to increase
the Y
so the x is going to remain constant
the X will be as is
delete that
split the strut pin Z is going to remain
constant but Y is going to be y Plus
let's just say 1
times Delta time Delta seconds let's try
Delta seconds itself first this should
remain constant for All actors because
this is tied to frame rate
so I think it's moving but it's moving
very very slowly
yep it is moving as you can see but it's
moving very very slowly
so we can just go ahead and multiply
this so multiply this by some value
let's just say we multiply this by 100
so not sure if
yep there we have it
so as you can notice it's not actually
the character that's moving it's the
whole obstacle course which is moving
and what's weird is our characters
actually following it even though we
haven't actually attached him over there
okay so we can fix the
uh X location of the character as well
because he seems to be just sliding
along
so there is actually a setting somewhere
here
so it shouldn't slide along the surface
so something or there
character movement Maybe
and there is
something over here okay ground friction
let's try zero on that
okay we are just still moving back so if
it if I hit f8 actually the whole thing
is moving back
so instead of that we will just set the
uh location the X location every time to
be constant
or rather the Y location
I'm not sure what it was so we'll copy
it
so Y is negative 270 so negative to 70.
I don't want that to change
and as you can see our logic is working
and it seems like we are moving forward
the speed is something which we can
worry about a bit later so maybe make
this 300
and as you can see it feels like
they're actually moving but what's
actually happening is the whole course
is just moving the character is actually
standing still
so
now our man is going forward
we can finally go ahead and set up the
obstacles itself I guess
and add in a jump State obviously
because right now he doesn't jump so we
can adjust the speed maybe 350 a little
more quick would have been nice
go ahead
okay with that something we'll worry
about later
now
uh for our next step
so I don't think we really require
teleport so our X Y and Z is all set
so for this we'll be using the jump as
well so we'll go ahead and create a
binding for our space bar
space bar and we'll call this one jump
and when I release this we are going to
stop jumping
okay
so now we should in theory just go up
we can adjust the settings of the jump
under our character movement component
and we can also have animations so
under our animation blueprint we can set
it up
so content blueprints game character
and MVP
we can ignore this and we can add a
state and this is going to be jump
jump start
and jump Loop
jump Loop
all right so jump start
and we'll see what animations we have
and from our jump Loop
we want to go back to our run animation
basically
so jump start is going to be a third
person jump
and for the transition we'll have we'll
check if we are jumping
so if we have our character reference
here
so
is there any variable
not sure
we can try this
okay nothing's really happening
okay we are getting a runtime error
saying we don't have
the character ref
so we'll only access this in the anim
graph
so go ahead if this is valid we will go
ahead and okay we can check if it is not
valid first of all
so we only get it once
and occasionally it's going not valid
so we can promote this two variable and
call this one jumping
and
in our transition
you can set it up
okay so the variable isn't doing
anything
so we can head back to the character and
create a variable for it in the first
place
so jumping
now we can go ahead and set this to true
we can go ahead and set this to false as
soon as we release it
get jumping
okay this logic should work
uh this is jump start to jump Loop so
when
our time remaining for our jump
is less than let's say 0.05 seconds
we'll enter this transition
and jump Loop to third person run when
this jumping is false basically
so not
not Boolean I guess it's called
so we'll just invert the value
now if I go ahead and press space okay
the animation is weird
so we can
again do and maybe and
if the jump Loop has at least played
once so jump Loop
so we can get access to the jump Loop
here
so time remaining time
remaining for the jump Loop
is less than 0.05 we can try this logic
okay we just went into a completely
random State there again probably some
logical error
okay so in our jump Loop we haven't fed
the animation
okay
so our jumping logic is working
so we can change this to maybe something
a little more smaller
0.02 so this is going to feel a lot
smoother
okay
so we are jumping
now we can start adding the actual
obstacles
under the course we can
head into obstacle base and over here we
don't want anything this is not
something we'll actually be spawning
obviously
obviously what will spawn is going to be
these
so
under obstacle one we can have stuff
I'm not even sure at this point if
you're able to see the sides we're
barely able to see it
and we also need to destroy it once we
actually reach a certain point
and we also need to keep spawning it
basically
so wherever our player start is
so let's go ahead and add a trigger
volume
so trigger box
so the x is going to be 20.
the Y is going to be
whatever this is and Z is going to be
0 let's say
and we'll just increase the extent of
the box maybe 500
500 and 500.
okay and we'll set the hidden in game to
false so hidden in game is false
so f8
so this can go way ahead
so a little more
so we can select this trigger box
and we can do
times two
by the way that's a pretty handy thing
which you can do in Blueprint
so just a little bit more
so more
okay I want to simulate now
so go ahead and simulate
okay so as soon as we end overlap on
this we want to spawn a new one so
go ahead
on actor and overlap
on actor and develop trigger box we'll
try to print first
okay
so as soon as we go out of this
first of all for the last index we'll go
ahead and promote this to a variable
so we'll call this one last spawn
obstacle
so we'll always have a reference to that
go ahead copy this over
so spawn actor
we will make use of this
remember we had our Arrow component
so
the the arrow which is there opposite to
the origin is what we need
game course obstacle base
so near the origin we have an arrow and
over here as well we have an arrow we'll
make use of this Arrow
so the location of this Arrow so this is
called Arrow one so we'll call this one
end
so that's a little more descriptive
under the level blueprint now
so we'll get the end
so get and
and from end we can
get
uh get the location
so get World location
and we can probably copy this over just
like that
and we can change this to this
and the rest of the logic should
actually work just like that
okay so now
if we actually wait for this
as soon as this goes away one more is
going to be spawned
but there's another thing uh we want to
destroy it uh once we actually
go after a certain point we want to
actually just destroy it like once we
are behind the player we have no reason
to still have it so we can have a
trigger box for that once again so 500
maybe 500
and 500
go ahead and over here as well we'll set
up begin overlap for this instead
so on actor beginner
so begin overlap
on active begin overlap destroy Act
okay let's try this out
so I'm not sure where this box is
let's unhide it so hidden game
set to false
okay so in theory we should be
destroying it okay we destroyed
the Box itself
so other actors what we have to destroy
whoops
we need to take this a little more
further back
so now if we wait for it to reach there
so we are continuously spawning the box
over there
and if I actually head back into my view
I cannot see anything happening
and our world is spawning normally
how cool
so over here we can add a couple of
things so obstacle one we can add a few
shipping containers Maybe
oh we can make it random actually that
would be nice
if we just make this completely random
so somewhere at the center
I'm not sure where the center is I think
it's negative 1600
so this is where the center is going to
be
oops I moved the end itself so first
duplicate it
and this is going to be negative 1600
this going to be Center obstacle
and
we can go ahead and duplicate this
and this is not going to be called
Center obstacle this is going to be
called Left obstacle
and we can call this one right obstacle
so our right obstacle is going to be to
the right obviously
and our left obstacle is going to be to
the left obviously
so this is 250 this negative 250.
okay
so we have set that up we should have
done this in the base actually
so we'll cut this and we'll paste this
in a base
so
don't mind that
now we should have our obstacle both in
the base and the others and obviously
the logic is going to be in base itself
so since we are randomly spawning it
it's totally fine
we can use the base itself I assume
now in the event graph
on event begin play
we can go ahead and create
a static mesh or rather spawn a static
mesh at that location
for that we'll need a few actor classes
so obstacles
over here we can delete this
and
if we play everything should work
however
under r
under this folder we can
make a few actors actually
so obstacles
we'll call this path actually
path underscore base in case we need any
derived classes
now click on blueprint class actor
and this is just going to be obstacle
one
uh few will be dodgable few will be not
so we'll make a dodgeable and
non-dodgeable obstacles
dot double
I will just have three for each
will create Childs
so child
Ctrl D Ctrl d
and we'll name this one child three so
one two three
so this one is going to be non-dodgeable
so we'll go ahead and create a child
Ctrl D Ctrl d
and this is going to be Child 3
obviously
okay
so finally we can go ahead and add stuff
to these obstacles
so optic obstacle dodgeable child one
we can instead of the default scene root
obviously
obstacle dodgable here as well
we'll simply have a static mesh
so static mesh
so that's done
I will leave the root it's fine
and we can look for some stuff here
so we have quite a few meshes so we can
have a barrel
in one place
so we can have boxes we can have barrels
we have so many options here
so we're going to select this let's say
let's try this
so in path
you want to spawn actor from class
so for the class we'll make this
obstacle dodgeable
so spawn transform is going to be this
so oops
uh Center obstacle let's try this first
so Center obstacle
and get word transform
go ahead and try this out
okay it's just sliding along for some
reason
and we want to attach it yeah that's the
reason so
attached to component
we want to attach this to our actual
plane or we can just uh do it for the
root component
so now
in theory this should work
okay so this seems to be working fine
uh one more thing we can make this a bit
faster actually
now we can promote this to variable
so speed
so we'll make this one 500.
okay as soon as we hit something uh we
should stop
and our game should get over
so we'll have event hit here
first we'll print something
go ahead and test this out
so if the other actor is an obstacle
pass to obstacle
uh we should have made a base class to
be honest
go ahead and
head into content blueprint game
course obstacles
we'll create one called
actor of
type obstacle
obstacle base
and will inherit these from
the base classes
so class settings
so obstacle
obstacle base
and these will also change
so We'll Inherit this from obstacle base
so obstacle base
obstacle base
all right so we can go ahead and cast to
and we're going to print
or rather we can just exit the game
execute console command
and we'll type in exit let's try this
okay our logic is working
okay we still hit it
so we need a better jumping logic
that's that's the problem with our
jumping logic it's not our
obstacles
so
under this
we can go ahead and change stuff in the
character moment so under jump
we should
have this parameter here so if we change
this to 500 for example
so now we are able to dodge this
obstacle successfully
and there are a little bit too far apart
I believe
these obstacles
so what we can do is
we can have two actually in each one
so go ahead and select all three of
these
foreign
of 3200 so 0.75 into 3200
it's going to be 2400 so at negative
2400 we'll have it
and we'll go ahead and duplicate this
so
these
and we'll have these at 800.
so we'll have a gap of 1600
between each obstacle
and now if I go ahead and press play
we have to set up more logic actually
so we are spawning the obstacle
dodgeable here now we'll make some
non-dodgeable obstacles as well so
set up the non-dodgeable one we can have
something like a shipping container or
something
hmm
so the way I do it
is going to be
if I add in a static mesh once again
and we'll have
a shipping container maybe container
okay we have quite a few that's nice
let's try with
only the non-dodgeable one
non-dodgeable
other rotations of
go ahead and rotate it by 90 degrees
okay
so this is not exactly on the floor but
we can fix that
head into the left view okay it is on
the floor
not sure why
it's not on the floor over there
you can try just moving it a bit
that about fixed our problem
and we obviously should be able to move
aside and dodge it
so
we are spawning obstacles
and
now we can set up a little bit of logic
to make this random a little bit
uh for dodgeable we can have few more
so for dot double
we'll leave it as is child one let it be
as is child two we can make something
else
so this static mesh can be
we can look over what we have here can
have this roadblock thing
and change the logic obviously so
dot double
I think it was child one so child one
child two rather child two
open it up I mean it is
a bit down
but you get the point
so change that
10 20 we'll just move all of those by 20
units
and for the third one as well we'll just
add one now obviously you can go ahead
and
make more of this
I feel like if we have some sort of a
traffic cone or something like that so
I'm just looking for what I can have so
okay these seem like the perfect choice
let's try that
again forgot to change it
so under my
path
so course path base
we can go ahead and change this to child
three
to test it
again it's a bit low but that's not an
issue okay I forgot to get the window in
Focus once again
that's my fault
and we have to move it down I believe
so move it down by 20 units
okay
so we have our dodgable obstacles let's
set up our non-dodgeable obstacles as
well
so in our child one we can again look
for what else we have maybe if we have a
truck or something
nope
uh we can look for what we have so
construction volume one meshes
so
can have a fence
yeah that's not a bad idea
so this is child one so let's child one
be the same
let's actually open up child two and
let's actually open up child three so
these are the ones which we'll try to
change
over here meshes we will select the
fence for one
uh the rotation can be zero
uh change this
non-dodgeable child three
so it's a little too big
so we can scale this down maybe 0.8
okay so I don't think you can dodge this
one
okay we can dodge it when we move aside
so we'll just have one last one
so for this one so obstacle Child 2
I will change it right now so child two
these are the various obstacles
basically
non-dodgeable child to
select that and this is child two I
assume yeah
so we can look for something else which
we may have
okay this looks like something
interesting
or light generator whatever this is
let's try that
I don't think this should be something
which you should be able to dodge
okay
so that works
now we can set up some randomizing logic
so that we spawn everything in random
so this logic is the same we need to
select the class basically first we can
select a random integer So Random
integer
so this is going to be
the number of random integer in range
actually
so this is going to be the number of
dodgeable obstacles so we need at least
one dodgeable obstacle otherwise the
game is going to get unplayable so we
can either have one or we can have all
the way up to three
and what we can do
is
depending on the number now this is
going to be number of dodgeable
obstacles what we have so promote this
to a variable
so number of
dodgeable
obstacles
okay so now that we have this if we have
only one
what we can do is we can select one so
number of dodgable obstacles
so we can switch on int
and we can select something
so
so we can start at one so start pin type
one
if we have only one obstacle our logic
is going to be really simple so we'll
just select a random one over there
we need to do this Two Times by the way
or multiple times probably I'm not sure
so
uh we'll have we'll have more obstacles
to be honest these are not enough
so we'll space them a little more closer
copy these
right obstacle left obstacle Center
obstacle
Ctrl D to duplicate and
left obstacle two
press Center obstacle to okay we didn't
duplicate everything
so Center
left and right
so Center left and right
Ctrl D to duplicate
okay wait we aren't duplicating anything
we'll just duplicate this so okay left
Center and right
you can move this somewhere in the
center
right at the center
and we can space these two equally apart
which I believe they already are
are they equally spaced yep but
we need to space them out a bit more
we have 800 for the spacing here
so we can select our obstacle one
we can try
giving you know negative
600 maybe so if I do negative 400
so that will be way too much space 500
maybe we can try 600.
so I have 3200 let's divide it let's
take 33 percent of that so calculator
so it's somewhere around 1066.
so we'll have 600. it's fine if they're
not equidistant
you can obviously do the math yourself
so obstacle
this is what we need so one
whoops
two and three
so 3200 minus 600 is going to be 2600.
okay now let's see if this works
yeah obviously we are not spawning it
that's different
but now
in theory we our logic should work
so we can actually Loop through
so we can select the number of dodgeable
obstacles for each level so we'll have
an array of this
so we'll create an array so change the
type it's fine
so we can do for each Loop
and for each index we can try
and get a random integer
so we can
set array element
so this is the index
we can do a simple for Loop so for Loop
so from 0 to 2
so size to fit we'll do that
and we'd actually want to reserve
three locations so one two three
so we don't need size to fit so
in this index we are going to set this
item
so for all our three levels we have we
know the number of obstacles which will
be dodgable
once we have that number we can go ahead
and spawn them
so we can have this in an array and
randomize them actually
anyways don't worry too much about the
logic
just my logic which I'm making up
um
we can select this
so we can store these in an array
so create an array so
promote to variable
or you can actually just have an array
so what are we using this for we're just
using this for the location
so we can get the transform of this
we can only have the transforms in the
array that's that would work I guess
so first we'll
have the transforms go ahead and create
an array for
transforms
transforms one transforms to transforms
three we'll need three arrays so
will the location is enough for us so
array of vectors
transforms to
transforms three
I know I shouldn't be calling them
transforms but we'll take a look at the
right obstacle
uh the first level ones basically
so we have this selected so right
obstacle one will will go according to
naming order
transforms one
we'll compile this blueprint
so we have three elements
we can access it right here
so the first one is going to be this I'm
not sure if we can
paste this see if we can
we have right obstacle copy this
okay we took that so left obstacle
copy this and
okay
the right and the left have okay they
don't
so paste one has negative 250
and the center one will have probably
will have probably have zero so we'll
paste it we'll have zero over here
okay and now that we have this
let's grab our obstacle tools or
obstacle ones
so this is negative 600.
one two three negative 600 this will be
constant so 1 is going to be 250 another
one is going to be negative 250.
similarly we can grab our two
so negative 1600 this is basically our
midpoint
negative 1600 250 negative 250
and this is about it
no
once this is done we'll collapse the
function
so determine
number of
dodgeable
obstacles
okay
we have the number of dodgeable
obstacles now
now what we can do is we can Loop
through this
so for each loop I really wish we could
have a two dimensional array for this
that would have helped us a lot
now
what we can do is
we can go ahead and randomize this
can we not randomize this
okay we cannot so we have a plugin which
will help us so low entry
I can restart
save everything
all right so
back here I think now we should have
okay we're coming close to two hours I
think this will be done in two hours not
one
blueprints game uh course pathways
and we should have a randomize
oops nope we don't
so I think we might need a few functions
so
how do we go about randomizing this we
can look at the epic games launcher if
we have any plugins
so array helpers I guess I had one
so we'll go ahead and install this to
the engine we can simultaneously use it
once we have this so once we actually
randomize this
uh depending on this
we can go ahead and set this so switch
on end
and
will you select for this
so just close the editor just to let
that happen
and now if we go ahead and launch Our
Endless Runner
okay go to edit
plugins so edit plugins
and array array helper
go ahead and restart
so this is the sort of stuff I just hope
it doesn't take too long
right hopefully we have some sort of a
randomized function so randomize
okay we still do not have a randomized
option option
so let's just look for it so randomize
array unreal
I don't know
is it called is it just called something
else so okay never mind
it's called Shuffle
so first of all we'll Shuffle the arrays
we'll shuffle all the three we'll do
that before we actually set this
we'll go ahead Shuffle this
go ahead and Shuffle this once again
uh we'll put that in the previous
function itself
so we can go ahead and Shuffle
generally I don't recommend you guys uh
do array operations in Blueprint but
anyways
once the slope is completed we can do
that
and this will go to the return node
just for you to understand the flow of
logic
and now
depending on this
we can go ahead and spawn them
so the array element is going to be the
number of obstacles so this switch is
going to start from 1 so start index is
one
you will either have one two or three
so if you have one or two way can you
select probably
copy the server
so
everything else is zero so we can just
leave it as is
so we can go ahead and over here
if this is one
if we have one dot zipper obstacle
we can go ahead and spawn
just one of them
as dodgable so dot double
so 1 is going to be dodgable and the
spawn transform will just use the first
index
so we will select
so depending on which index it is
so transform 1 transform to transform
three
so option one
option two and option three
so we'll select any one of these arrays
and if we have to spawn only one dot
zipple so we can get
uh we can get a copy of the first one
we'll split the struct pin here and
we'll just get this location
now we we need to just repeat this logic
so Ctrl d
and we want to do two non-dodgeable ones
so dodgeable and index 1 and 2 are going
to be Non DOT triple so non dodgable
uh we have to spawn a child class of
this so
you can use the select once again
so Random
integer
and Max is going to be 2.
so it's going to be
Max S2 so
1 and 2.
so it's random number between 0 and Max
minus 1 let's just use random integer
and range
it's a little bit confusing so minimum
is zero maximum is 2.
okay
and this is going to be dodgable so
dodgeable
obstacle dot double child one child two
and child three
this is what we have
done
and for this one this is non-dodgeable
so we'll copy the logic
but instead of dodgeable we'll have
non-dodgeable
so child one
child one
child two and child three
okay
and we need this once again so copy over
this entire logic
all right so this is going to be the
same this is going to be for index 2.
now if we have 2 we can go ahead and
copy this over so Ctrl C and Ctrl V
and we can just move this aside
so for index 0 it's going to remain the
same
whoops Ctrl V
oops uh copy this
Ctrl C and Ctrl V
index is still going to remain the same
once this is done we need the attach as
well we didn't copy over the attach
okay so we have to duplicate this whole
thing
so index is this
and index is going to remain the same
everywhere
so now we need two dot double obstacles
so for this one as well we have dodgable
and this is going to be index one
obviously
and for index 2 we can go ahead and have
this
all right so copy this
and again we can pass the index
so array index
go ahead and pass that in
and when we have all three dodgable
obstacles
uh we'll just go ahead and copy this
much Ctrl C and Ctrl V
so in case of three this is what we'll
do
so index is still going to remain the
array index
Ctrl d
and Ctrl d
copy this over move the execution pins
and the index will obviously just remain
the same
so the last one is going to remain the
same and this is going to be 2 this is
going to be 1.
and this is going to be 0. so make sure
you have 0 1 and 2.
okay
so now our logic should work
and if I were to go ahead and press play
okay
everything works okay
all right so
okay we stepped onto something
uh we need to make sure this doesn't
happen in our first one so
okay we have to just ensure that the
obstacles aren't spawned in the first
one basically
so we'll create a Boolean
first box
so if this is not the first box
we'll go ahead and do this
so inside the level blueprint
under this
if we go ahead and refresh nodes uh we
have to pass this in so expose on spawn
all right so now if I refresh
I should get this
so only if this is uh index 0
so double equal to zero then this is the
first box otherwise it's not
okay so now our logic is working
let's go ahead and play the game now
all right
so as you guys can see our game is
working as expected
we don't have a score yet we'll just set
it up quickly
so as you can see our logic is working
so we can set up a scoring system real
quick and dirty here
content
I will do the start thing also it's
really simple so
go ahead and open level
um we call this one game map I believe
so Maps
game up go ahead and paste that in
or we can start from the main menu
go ahead and play start
and we started the game
so as you can see everything is working
as expected you could have some stuff at
the side
and we'll have a scoring system we can
have a time-based scoring system
so it's the score is going to go up at a
constant rate
content
will create a widget further so
user widget
and we'll call this one HUD
and we'll we'll just simply have a text
so we'll wrap this with a canvas panel
and this is going to be our score
once we will set the game mode and stuff
so game map
over here we'll have BP uh we don't have
a black controller we'll create that
game
go ahead head into blueprint class
player controller BP underscore player
controller
so you should have BP player controller
so on begin play we can go ahead and
create the widget
so create widget
it's going to be HUD
and we can go ahead and add to viewport
right so let's look at our time we don't
have much I think it'll take probably
just a little lower two hours but
it'll be done
so once we create this we can grab a
reference
so promote this to a variable and we'll
call this one HUD now I don't recommend
you guys use bindings but I think in
this case just to make this real quick
I'll use bindings
so we can have game State uh on
construct we can get reference to the
game state so get game state
cast to BP game state
and what we can do is we can grab a
reference to it
and we can create a score variable
content blueprint
uh blueprint main menu I guess no game
so game
game state
and we can have a score
so we'll make this an INT 64. so that we
can have larger scores so integer 64.
and we can have a timer so set timer by
function name
and
it's going to be something which
happens every 0.5 seconds let's say
and we are going to increment the score
so promote to variable
score timer
and we can have a custom event
increment score
or increase I'll call it
doesn't matter we'll not worry about
that
we are going to get the score and we'll
set it to score plus 2 maybe
Plus
set score
so we'll go ahead and do that copy this
put it in the function name make this
looping
and we can use a binding here so we can
bind this
you can get the game state
you can make this a validated git
this is a little more expensive on your
computer so don't do this
so we can get the score
and we can convert this to text
you can use a format text node and stuff
I'm not really going over that so we'll
just do that actually so format text
all right
and we don't need to convert this
if we press play
as you can see our score is increasing
at a constant rate and you can see it on
the top left hand side for those of you
on mobile phones and who are not able to
see it I'll just make this text a little
bigger so 40
make this one regular we don't need bold
and this should be good
so as you can see everything is working
fine
and you can go ahead and set up any
logic if you want if you want to like
you know save it or whatever
but for now I'm happy with this
so that's it for this video guys thanks
for watching we do have a complete game
and instead of exit you can just show
the score on a widget or something I
will do that let's not leave it halfway
the last part before we just complete it
so we'll create a widget
and we'll call this one end screen
okay we'll add a border
wrap this with the canvas panel
so we can go ahead and wrap with canvas
panel
and this border should take up the whole
thing so offsets are going to be zero
and the brush color is going to be
something black black Maybe
and we can just go ahead and add some
text
so we need to align it right at the
center so
vertical box
uh
we can use an overlay
rather
overlay is going to be helpful here
so overlay
so border is going to be filled
the overlay is going to be filled as
well
so 0 0
all right and over here we can have text
and there's the advantage of using a
canvas panel
so 40
can make this regular Maybe
then go ahead and put score
and we can go ahead and
give the value
so
let's go ahead and set that so event
construct get game state
cost to our BP game State and we can get
access to the score variable get score
and we can set the text of this
so set the text
set text
and this is going to be about it we'll
format it
so format text
so this is the score
so let's go ahead and Center that make
it 0.5
and make everything else 0 here
oops uh the size shouldn't have been
zero
uh make this one central line
and the make sure for any vertical
alignment which we have
okay nope we don't so I'll just reduce
the size of this maybe to 100
okay this should be good now if I go
ahead and press play nothing will happen
because we haven't spawned the end
screen
uh where we have our event hit in our
character
so we can cast to obstacle and instead
of that we can go ahead and create a
widget
create a widget end screen
and we can add it to the viewport
all right
let's go ahead and do that
so I'm testing the end screen so I'll
just die immediately
okay so our score is 300 apparently
which is nice
okay not sure why we didn't exit
immediately there
uh we need to do once I understood the
problem so do once
because once we die the game's over
don't want to redo that
so
okay we need to do once from here
actually
now we just went over the obstacle which
was kind of stupid
so go ahead and try this out
and our score is 280.
so that's it for this video guys I hope
you guys really enjoyed this entire
course I know it's been over 11 hours at
this point but hopefully you have
learned something new and I hope you
enjoyed the last part where we actually
made an entire game and we didn't use
any C plus plus to be honest
so that's about it hope you guys enjoyed
and see you guys later goodbye